BUT NUMBER THREE IN HEALTH,
HUMAN SERVICES WILL COMMENCE.
UM, THANK YOU SO MUCH, UH, FOR
THIS FULL HOUSE. UH, WELL, MAYBE
PERHAPS WE'LL LOOK AT THIS AS A
POSITIVE THING THAT YOU CAME UP
HERE TO ADVOCATE. IT COULD ALSO
BE A NEGATIVE THING BECAUSE YOU
HAD TO TRAVEL SO FAR TO COME
HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR A SYSTEM
THAT PERHAPS WE DON'T ALL AGREE
WITH. BUT EITHER WAY, I THANK
YOU FOR COMING FOR EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU TO COME UP HERE
AND, UM, VOICE YOUR CONCERNS
YOUR THOUGHTS AS WE PROCEED AS
ONE OF THE MOST, UM DIFFICULT,
UH, SYSTEMS I'VE COME TO LEARN
ABOUT AND FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN
REALLY MEND THIS SYSTEM THAT
SERVES THE ENTIRE POPULATION. MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ON THEIR WAY, BUT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND START
WE'RE DOING TWO DEPARTMENTS
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
PUBLIC COMMENTS AFTER EACH
DEPARTMENT EXCEPT WHEN WE GO TO,
UH Dð Dð S¼. WE'RE GONNA DO
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FIVE, THEN DO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO, UM ENSURE
THAT OUR A S¼ L INTERPRETER MAY
BE ABLE TO INTERPRET FOR THOSE
ITEMS AND THEN WE'LL CONTINUE
THROUGH SIX THROUGH 10 ISSUE SIX
THROUGH 10. THEN ONCE AGAIN DO
PUBLIC COMMENT. I DO ASK FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END THAT
IF WE COULD PLEASE FOR, UM MY
PROVIDERS AND MY, UM MY LOBBY IS
HERE IF WE COULD PLEASE GIVE
ROOM. FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE COME HERE SO FAR, OR FROM
SACRAMENTO TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMON FIRST, THEN FOR PROVIDERS
AND THEN FOR LOBBYISTS AGAIN,
FAMILIES, INDIVIDUALS FIRST AND
THEN THE REST OF THE PARTY
THERE. SO I WILL ASK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER Dð Ó R TO
PLEASE STEP INTO THE WHALE.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ISSUE
ONE. AN OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THEN A Ó AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO START?
PLEASE, SIR. GO AHEAD. WELL
FIRST OF ALL, GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE. UM ALWAYS APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
WORK THAT WE ARE DOING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM. I'M JOE
XAVIER. I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION. A
FORMER CONSUMER BUSINESS OWNER
AND NOW DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. SO THE AGENDA DOES A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF DESCRIBING
THE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. I'M
JUST GOING TO EMPHASIZE A COUPLE
OF KEY POINTS AND THEN SPEAK TO
THE ITEMS THAT YOU'VE ASKED US
TO ADDRESS, UM WHO WE SERVE IS
INDIVIDUALS WITH ALL
DISABILITIES, WHICH INCLUDE
SENSORY INCLUDE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SPECTRUM. ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE WORK
THAT WE DO, IT'S NOT JUST THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HERE TODAY.
IT'S THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL
ACQUIRE DISABILITIES. IN THE
COMING YEARS. THE CHILD WHO CAN
BE BORN TODAY WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITY, THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS GOING HOME TONIGHT AND
TOMORROW MORNING IS A
QUADRIPLEGIC OR A TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY SURVIVOR INDIVIDUAL
WHO WAS INJURED, ACQUIRES A
DISABILITY AND SERVICE TO
COUNTRY TO STATE AND TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT BECAUSE OF ILLNESS MIGHT
LOSE THEIR EYESIGHT HAVE A LIMB
AMPUTATED, ACQUIRE ANY OTHER
SORT OF DISABILITY? AND IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO REMEMBER THAT WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT DISABILITY,
THERE'S THE INVISIBLE DISABILITY
. THE INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SUFFERING FROM DEPRESSION
, LEARNING DISABILITIES AND THE
LIKE. AND WHILE EACH OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
PATH AND DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT ARE ALL SEEKING TO PURSUE
THAT FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGE TO
BELONG AND FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITY TO
OUR SOCIETY, AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT ALWAYS CALL OUT IS
THIS MEANS WE LEAVE NÓ ONE
BEHIND EXCEPTION. NONE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EMPLOYMENT. UM, IT IS
PREVENTION. IT IS INTERVENTION,
AND IT IS RECOVERY FOR SO MANY
INDIVIDUALS. IT CREATES THAT
SENSE OF BELONGING OF VALUE OF
PURPOSE. IT CREATED FOR ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE FOR MY
FAMILY AND TO SAY ENJOY THE VERY
THINGS I'VE JUST OUTLINED. IT IS
ALSO AN ESSENTIAL PILLAR AND
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. WE HAVE
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAMS
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT. UM THEY
ADVANCE THE OLMSTEAD DECISION,
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY TO RECEIVE
SERVICES AND TO LIVE IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
IT SUPPORTS DIVERSIONS FROM
INSTITUTIONS AND THE FACILITATE
TRANSITIONS OUT OF INSTITUTIONS.
UM SO ITEM NUMBER ONE ON THE
AGENDA ACCESS TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
I WILL GET INTO THE PROPOSED
BUDGET SOLUTION TO CONFORM TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES RATES. IT'S $1.6
MILLION, WHICH IS PROPOSED TO BE
DELAYED UNTIL NEXT YEAR. AND IT
CONFORMS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THE DELAY
THAT THAT IS ALSO BEING TAKEN
PLACE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES RATE. WE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION SHARE BOTH
CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. AND HISTORICALLY WE
HAVE ALIGNED OUR JOB COACHING
SERVICES RATES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
THAT ENSURES THAT THERE IS NÓ
DISPARITY IN THE RACE FROM ONE
SYSTEM TO THE OTHER. UM AND WE
ARE NOT CURRENTLY EXPECTING THAT
THERE WILL BE ANY IMPACT INTO
THE VOLUME OF CONSUMERS THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO SERVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
THE SECOND PART OF THIS ITEM
ASKS THAT WE SPEAK TO THE
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY PROGRAM.
UM THE HÌ èC B S¼ SPENDING
PLAN. AND THE AGENDA DOES A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF DESCRIBING
THE EXPANSION OF SERVICES WITH
THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN ISSUE
PROGRAM. SO THE QUESTION IS, ARE
WE ON TRACK TO EXPAND OFF ALL OF
OUR FUNDS AND YES, WE ARE ON
TRACK TO FULLY EXPAND THE
DOLLARS BY THE END OF THIS
DECEMBER. THE NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL CLIENTS THAT WERE
SERVED THROUGH THE EXPANSION IS
ESSENTIALLY DOUBLING THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS WE WERE SERVING.
SO COLLECTIVELY, WE'RE SERVING
JUST OVER 15 5 1560 INDIVIDUALS.
WE WERE ALSO ASKED TO SPEAK TO
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CLIENTS THAT
ARE RECEIVING SERVICES FROM THIS
EXPANSION. UM ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD CALL OUT HERE IS
THAT ALL SITES, INCLUDING THOSE
FUNDED BY HÌ èC B S¼ DOLLARS
HAVE CONTINUED TO EXPAND TO
EVOLVE THEIR CAPACITY TO SERVE
THIS POPULATION. AND THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD LIFT UP HERE
IS THAT THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN
ANGIOGRAMS ARE PERIODICALLY
RECOMPETING, AND WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A COMPETING THOSE IN
THE COMING MONTHS. UM THAT MEANS
THAT ALL ELIGIBLE CBOS
COMMUNITY-BASED ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING THE EXISTING HÌ èC B
S¼ EXPANDED SITES ARE ELIGIBLE
TO COMPETE FOR THOSE GRANTS. UM
WE ALSO ASKED TO SPEAK TO WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THERE IS A TRANSITION, SO WHEN
THERE IS A TRANSITION OF
PROVIDERS OF COURSE, WHERE THERE
ISN'T A PROVIDER CONTINUES.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE SUPPORT THAT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE TO THE
CONSUMER ON THAT FRONT BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALREADY CONNECTED. WHERE
IT IS A NEW PROVIDER. WE WORK TO
LINK THE CONSUMER WITH THE NEW
GRANT RECIPIENT. WHERE THERE IS
NÓ PROVIDER. WE LOOK TO LINK
THAT INDIVIDUAL WITH OTHER
SERVICES THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
WITHIN AND IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
WHERE THERE IS A VIRTUAL OPTION.
WE OBVIOUSLY LOOK TO LEVERAGE
THAT VIRTUAL OPTION FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. SO I. I WILL STOP
THERE UNLESS YOU LIKE ME TO
CONTINUE TO NUMBER TWO. UH, JUST
A QUICK QUESTION ON YOU SPOKE
ABOUT THE SITES ARE GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO COMPETE FOR Tð B I
GRANTS. ARE WE CONFIDENT THAT
THERE THAT ABILITY WILL MAINTAIN
THE SITES? UH, CAPACITY
CONTINUE. WELL IT YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY WILL CONTINUE TO AS
WE'VE SAID IN THE PAST TO LOOK
FOR RESOURCES TO DO THAT. UM,
BUT THIS RECOMPETING OF THE
GRANTS IS SOMETHING THAT WE DO,
UM EVERY NUMBER OF YEARS. SO AT
THIS POINT, WE DON'T KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT YET LET OUT
THAT R FA AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO
IS GOING TO BE APPLYING.
MEMBERS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS,
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU. I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON THE, UM
ON PROGRAMS FOR INDIVIDUALS ON
THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE ISSUE. UM,
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE, UM
THROUGH THE, UH, THROUGH OUR
CONSULTANTS THAT 15,000 PEOPLE
ROUGHLY HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS IN
THE I Dð Dð COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THE SET MINIMUM WAGE YOU HAVE
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
GUYS ARE EMPLOYING. AND I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS, IS THAT WHAT IS
THE RESULT OF THOSE PROGRAMS? UM
AND I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT REGULAR
FULL-TIME EMPLOYMENT LIKE THEY
HAD WHEN THEY HAD SUB MINIMUM
WAGE. I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
SOMEBODY WORKING 1 TO 3 HOURS A
WEEK WHEN YOU HAVE A JOB IN ALL
OF THE SECU, JUST EVERYTHING
THAT YOU HAVE WITH SELF ESTEEM
AND INTEGRATION. I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS CONTINUE
TO BE EMPLOYED. UM BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING AGAIN IS THAT
15,000 INDIVIDUALS IN THE I Dð
Dð COMMUNITY HAVE LOST THEIR JOB
BECAUSE OF THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE
BILL THAT WAS PASSED OUT OF THIS
BUILDING. YEAH. SO BE GLAD TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AT THE
DEPARTMENT. I ALSO WOULD POINT
TO THE MEMBERS IN THE INTERESTED
PARTIES TO THE REPORT THAT THE
STATE COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT OF
DISABILITIES DISTRICT ISSUED, UM
, ON THE PHASE OUT OF THAT'S THE
MINIMUM WAGE, WHICH REFLECTS THE
WORKS OF BOTH, UM THE
DEPARTMENTS OURSELVES AND
DEPARTMENT. DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. UM WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE REDUCTION OF 15,000
INDIVIDUALS, UM I WOULD SAY THAT
MORE APPROPRIATELY TO REPRESENT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. YES, THEY MAY
NÓ. BE SUB MINIMUM WAGE THAT
THEY ARE NOT EMPLOYED. I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE MOVED ON
INTO COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED JOBS
. SOME OF THEM WE WOULD KNOW
ABOUT BECAUSE WE HELP THEM. UH,
THERE WERE OTHERS MAY HAVE DONE
SO THROUGH OTHER AVENUES. WE
KNOW THAT AS OF RIGHT NOW. THERE
ARE CERTAINLY MANY, MANY FEWER
PEOPLE IN SUB MINIMUM WAGE THAN
IT WAS BEFORE. AS WE KNOW THAT
PHASE OUT IS COMING UP. SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME IS WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS TO GET THEM INTO
EMPLOYMENT. WE OBVIOUSLY DO THE
WORK WITH THE STATE AS AN
EMPLOYER. WE DO THE WORK WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES. I WAS JUST
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EARLIER THIS WEEK TO CELEBRATE,
UH, TWO SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HIRED INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES INTO THEIR
WORKFORCE. AND SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INITIATIVES.
WE EVEN AT OUR OWN DEPARTMENT
HAVE STOOD UP A PATHWAYS TO
EMPLOYMENT, WHICH HAS THE
ABILITY FOR SOMEONE TO COME IN
AND GET A PAID WORK EXPERIENCE,
SO THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE EXPOSED TO THE WORKPLACE. AND
THEN MANY OF THEM ARE BEING
HIRED NOT ONLY WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT, WHERE VACANT
POSITIONS ARE AVAILABLE, BUT IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS IN OTHER
SYSTEMS AS WELL. DIRECTOR
CURRENTLY IS IT ACCURATE THAT WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY 2 TO 4000
PEOPLE ONLY. SUB MINIMUM WAGES.
YES I BELIEVE THAT IS THE NUMBER
THAT IS REPORTED. YES, OK. AND
DIRECTOR JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
YOUR COMMENT THAT YOU MADE
BEFORE AND THEN IF YOU NEED TO
FINISH AFTERWARDS, THAT'S
COMPLETELY FINE WITH ME. AS LONG
AS IT'S FINE WITH THE CHAIR. UM
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE DATA TO SAY THAT IT'S NOT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE CATEGORY,
WHICH WE KNOW WE STILL HAVE. BUT
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY 15,000
PEOPLE FROM MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND YOU SAID IN YOUR STATEMENT
JUST NOW THAT THAT NUMBER IS NOT
ENTIRELY TRUE, BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE GONE ON TO INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER AVENUES.
UM, DOES THE DEPARTMENT TRACK
THAT AND CAN WE GET A NUMBER
THAT SAYS THESE PEOPLE WENT ON
TO GAINFULLY BE EMPLOYED?
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT, OR ARE
THEY IN DAY PROGRAMS STILL PAID
FOR BY THE STATE? IN TERMS OF
THE FOLKS THAT COME TO US, SO WE
KNOW THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
SERVE AND THEY GO, UM, THAT THEY
ALL END UP IN COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. WE'VE HAD
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS HUNDREDS
OF CASES THAT WE HAVE OPENED
THOUSANDS OF CASES. BECAUSE WE
PROVIDE CAREER COUNSELING,
INFORMATION AND REFERRAL AS PART
OF OUR FEDERAL MANDATE. WHAT WE
DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REPORT ON THAT DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DISABILITY,
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ON
WHO IS IN THE PROGRAMS. THAT IS
NOT A PROGRAM THAT WE TRACK IN A
DATA FOR AND WE MAY KNOW SOME OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT COME TO US
THAT WE ARE IN SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS, BUT CERTAINLY NOT ALL
OF THEM UNLESS THAT IS MADE
KNOWN TO US, SO DATA ON PEOPLE
THAT COME TO US WHETHER THEY GO
TO WORK YES, SPECIFIC DETAILS
ABOUT HOW MANY WERE HERE AND
ENDED UP THERE THAT IS NOT DATA
POINTS THAT WE TRACK. OK SO THE
REASON I'M ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS IS BECAUSE MY FORMER
COLLEAGUE WES CHESBRO INTRODUCED
EMPLOYMENT FIRST, OBVIOUSLY IN
2013, AND THEN AGAIN THE S¼ B
639 A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. THAT
HAS, UM WHAT I THINK CREATED A,
UM AN UNFAIR, UNFAIR
DISADVANTAGE TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL NOW END UP
IN A DAY PROGRAM VERSUS ACTUALLY
BEING GAINFUL NOT I REALIZE IT'S
SUB MINIMUM WAGE IS NOT
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. I GET THAT
BUT THE IDEA OF SELF ESTEEM AND
GOING TO WORK AND YOU KNOW, EVEN
WHEN THEY DID THE WORK OUT AT
THE TONE RANCH FACILITY, THE
REST STOP WHEN THEY HIRED OUR
BAKERSFIELD ARC TO GO UP THERE.
UH AND THEN THAT WAS TAKEN AWAY
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T PART OF S¼
èC IU. AND THERE WAS THIS WHOLE
BIG, BIG ISSUE, BUT, UM, THEY
HAD PRIDE. THEY GREETED PEOPLE
WHEN THEY SHOW UP. THEY KEPT
THAT PLACE. LIST. I MEAN, IT'S A
IT'S A HAVING A JOB CREATES SELF
ESTEEM. AND, UM AND PERSONAL
ACHIEVEMENT AND IT HAS A BIG
BENEFIT, AND I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE DATA THAT WE
RECEIVED THAT 15,000 PEOPLE HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS BECAUSE OF THE
SUB MINIMUM WAGE JOB OR THE BILL
THAT CAME OUT AND IN YOUR
STATEMENT JUST NOW. YOUR EXACT
QUOTE. WAS THEY ALL ALL THEY ALL
MEANING THIS POPULATION END UP
IN COMPETITIVE WORKPLACE, UM,
EMPLOYMENT. THEY ALL DO. YOU
HAVE DATA TO SHOW ME THAT ALL
15,000 PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY IN
COMPETITIVE WORKPLACE EMPLOYMENT
. I DON'T BELIEVE I SAY THEY ALL
I SAID THOSE THAT COME TO US
THAT END UP IN EMPLOYMENT ARE
ALL IN COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OUR
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT PLACE
ANYBODY OTHER THAN IN A
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. IF I COULD JUST LIFT
UP THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING ABOUT
THE VALUE OF WORK THAT I SPOKE
TO AT THE OUTSET. ARE YOU A REAL
LIFE CASE? A YOUNG LADY THAT IS
NOW WORKING FOR US. WHO IS THIS
INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS IN THIS
SUBMIT WAGE SETTING. CAME IN
WITH WHAT YOU DESCRIBED VERY
LITTLE CONFIDENCE. VERY AFRAID
OF THE WORKPLACE. AND TODAY IS A
STATE EMPLOYEE FULL OF
CONFIDENCE ABILITY TO PERFORM
ALONGSIDE INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T
HAVE AN INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ABILITY TO ENGAGE WITH ME, JUST
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE. AND YES,
SENATOR EMPLOYMENT DID THAT FOR
HER. SHE NOW HAS THE INCOME TO
BE ON PAR WITH THE REST OF
SOCIETY TO PROVIDE FOR HERSELF
TO CARE FOR HERSELF TO GO ENJOY
WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE GETS TO
ENJOY. THAT'S WHAT WE DO. AND
THAT'S THE FOCUS THAT WE TAKE ON
EVERYBODY THAT COMES TO US FOR
SERVICES. THANK YOU, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT'S THAT'S
THE GOAL THAT WE WANT. AND
THAT'S WHAT I MEAN ABOUT SELF
ESTEEM. I HAVE A SEVERELY
DISABLED INDIVIDUAL WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. AND UM HE WAS SO
EXCITED TO HAVE HIS JOB AND HE
FELT VALUED IN THE SELF ESTEEM
AND THE CONFIDENCE THAT THAT
GAVE HIM THAT'S A PERSONAL STORY
THAT I COULD SHARE WITH YOU. I
GUESS MY THING IS IN THE MARE
VICE OR BEFORE MAY REVISE, I
GUESS I'D LIKE TO KNOW THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU HAVE. AND I
REALLY WANT TO DRILL DOWN ON
THIS 15,000 PEOPLE. I IT'S THE
ONLY ONES THAT COME TO YOU, BUT
IF THEY DON'T COME TO YOU, HOW
ARE WE TRACKING? UM THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND IF THEY DON'T GO
TO WORK ANYMORE, WHERE ARE THEY
GOING, AND IF THEY GO TO THE DAY
PROGRAM INSTEAD, THERE'S COST
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE STATE. FOR
THAT, AND I'M JUST SAYING THAT
TO GO TO AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE SIGNIFICANT KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THE DAY PROGRAMS AND IF THEY'RE
CREATING THAT SAME SELF ESTEEM
AND THAT SAME SELF AWARENESS AND
THAT SAME SELF ACHIEVEMENT, UM,
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HAVE OPTIONS TO EITHER HAVE
EMPLOYMENT OR IF THEY GO TO A
DAY PROGRAM, LET THEM GO TO A
DAY PROGRAM, BUT I WANT THEM TO
HAVE THE BEST AVAILABLE
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE FOR
THEM, AND I'M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT 15,000 PEOPLE THAT LOST
THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF THESE TWO
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. DURING
FINAL COMMENTS ON THIS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
AGENDA. I. I THINK I SAID WHAT I
CAN SAY ON THE TOPIC. I'M SORRY,
MADAM CHAIR WAS I NOT ON THE
AGENDA? ITEM NUMBER TWO, SAYS
IT'S ITEM NUMBER TWO EMPLOYMENT.
MY APOLOGIES IF I STEPPED AND
WAIT, YOU'RE OK, SENATOR. THANK
YOU. OFF. I REALIZE THIS IS NOT
PART OF OUR PROGRAM TODAY, BUT I
FEEL COMPELLED TO SAY SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW, I. I HAD MY CONCERNS
AND QUESTIONS. UM AS MY
COLLEAGUE TO MY LEFT DID WHEN WE
FIRST DID THIS, UH, ACTION WITH
RESPECT TO THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE,
BUT I'LL TELL YOU THAT I HAVE
COMPLETELY CHANGED MY VIEW AND
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF VISITING PHOENIX
TECHNOLOGIES, WHICH IS A COMPANY
, THE MANUFACTURE FIRE HELMETS.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE FEW IN THE I
GUESS. CERTAINLY THE COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD THAT DO THIS, AND, UM
THEY HAVE, UH, MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY TO JOB COACH
AND EMPLOY AND I VISITED THE
MANUFACTURING FLOOR AND I TELL
YOU, IT WAS IT. IT TOOK MY
BREATH. AWAY AND IT WAS PRETTY
CLEAR TO ME AFTER WATCHING, UH,
THE EMPLOYEES. FIRST OF ALL, I
COULDN'T TELL WHO HAD A
DISABILITY AND WHO DIDN'T HAVE A
DISABILITY WAS PRETTY CLEAR TO
ME THAT THE KEY, UM TO HELPING
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES IS
HELPING THEM SECURE A JOB AT A
REGULAR WAGE. NOT A SUB MINIMUM
WAGE. UM AND WHEN I SPOKE TO
PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR AND,
ACTUALLY, UM WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES. SOME OF THEM WERE
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
TALK TO ME, AND I SPOKE TO THEM.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
JOBS AT A SUB MINIMUM WAGE. IN
FACT, THERE WAS ONE EMPLOYEE WHO
WAS THE EMPLOYEE OF THE QUARTER.
AND HE TOLD ME THAT BECAUSE OF
HIS JOB AT PHOENIX TECHNOLOGIES,
AND I HOPE YOU DON'T MIND ME
MENTIONING THEIR COMPANY. UM HE
WAS ABLE TO BUY HIS FIRST CAR,
HE BOUGHT A NEW MUSTANG. AND HE
WAS SO PROUD OF THAT CAR THAT HE
HAD A CAR AND HE WAS ABLE TO
DRIVE. AND THE MANAGERS AT THE
FACILITY TOLD ME THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WERE THE ONES WHO GOT TO WORK ON
TIME. THEY CAME BACK FROM BREAKS
ON TIME. THEY DIDN'T STOP THEIR
WORK. THEY WERE THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE ON THE SHOP FLOOR.
AND SO EMPLOYERS CAN DO THIS,
AND I THINK AS A STATE INSTEAD
OF LOOKING BACK AT THE SUB
MINIMUM WAGE PROGRAM THAT
EXISTED FOR SEEMED LIKE FOREVER.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS WE SHOULD
LOOK FORWARD. EMPLOYERS ARE
GOING TO NEED TO BE INFORMED AND
EMPLOYERS ARE GOING TO NEED
ASSISTANCE AND THEY'RE GOING
UNDER ANY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS NOT SO DIFFICULT
THIS IS ABOUT THIS IS ABOUT
SCREENING. IT'S ABOUT JOB
COACHING. IT'S ABOUT TOLERANCE.
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING CULTURE IN A
WORKPLACE THAT ALLOWS EVERYBODY
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE.
AND SO I WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. I KNOW YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD.
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING, AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR. TO PROVIDE
PROGRAMS TO EDUCATE AND INFORM
EMPLOYERS, PERHAPS TO ASSIST
WITH JOB COACHING AND SCREENING
TO PLACE PEOPLE IN JOBS WHERE
THEY HAVE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO SUCCEED. AND IF THE
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT ARE
ANY INDICATION, THEY WILL
SUCCEED. THE BUSINESSES WILL
THRIVE AND EVERYBODY WILL BE
BETTER FOR IT. THANK YOU SO
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DELIVER A SPEECH.
FINAL FINAL THOUGHT I AGREE.
100% WITH WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID
I DO. MY I GUESS MY CONCERN LIES
WITH THOSE, UM INDIVIDUALS WHO I
THINK HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AN
OPPORTUNITY. UM, BECAUSE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE DESCRIBES. I SEE EVERY
DAY IN THE WORKPLACE. I SEE HERE
IN THE BUILDING. I SEE AT MY
COMPANY II. I SEE THAT EVERY DAY
, BUT THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE NOT AS HIGH FUNCTIONING WITH
I Dð Dð, AND WE WANT THEM TO
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPETITIVENESS. AND IF YOU
CAN'T IF THERE'S NOT SOMETHING
OUT THERE FOR THEM, UM THAT'S
WHERE MY CONCERN LIES, AND I
AGREE, 100% WITH WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS, UM NÓ ANECDOTES, NÓ
THINGS WE COULD ALL GO BACK AND
FORTH ON STORIES. UM AND I KNOW
THE CHAIR IS READY TO MOVE ON. I
WANT NUMBERS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO EMPLOYMENT. THE HIGHER
FUNCTIONING I Dð Dð COMMUNITY IS
NOT. I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT'S
NOT WHERE MY CONCERN IS. I
BELIEVE THEY ARE THRIVING. █150
MILLION PERCENT BETTER WITH WHAT
WE HAVE IN BUYING MUSTANGS AND
PAYING FOR APARTMENTS. I AM
WORRIED ABOUT THE ID COMMUNITY
THAT IS NOT AS HIGH FUNCTIONING.
DO THEY STILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO A WORKPLACE? UM AND THAT'S
MY CONCERN, AND I WOULD LIKE
THOSE NUMBERS IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE THEM FOR ME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DIRECTOR. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE NUMBERS.
I THINK ALL THE MEMBERS HERE ON
THE D¯ÚI WOULD BE EAGER TO SEE
THOSE NUMBERS AS WELL. WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM. OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
VOICE OPTIONS PROGRAM. OK, THANK
YOU. SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO PROVIDE SPEECH
GENERATING DEVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS, SO THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK AND COMMUNITY
COMMUNICATIONS. MORE BROADLY. SO
IN FEBRUARY OF 20 THREE, THE èC
PU MADE THE VOICE OPTIONS
PROGRAM PERMANENT, AND WE
ADMINISTER THAT AGREEMENT THAT
PROGRAM TO DO AN INNOVATION TO
AGREEMENT WITH THE èC PU èC.
$3.6 MILLION IS TRANSFERRED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
FOR THE ANNUAL ADMINISTRATION OF
THIS PROGRAM. UM, AND IS THREE
THREE 0.75 POSITIONS THAT WE USE
TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. WE
EXPECT TO SERVE ABOUT 1260
INDIVIDUALS ANNUALLY THROUGH THE
PROGRAM. AND THE NUMBER THAT I
SHARED HERE. THIS 1200 IS
DETERMINED BY THE EXPERIENCE
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE PROGRAM.
UM, THUS FAR. UM LET ME SHARE
WHAT THIS MEANS IN REAL TIME FOR
FOLKS, SO I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT A VERY YOUNG GIRL. UH,
RILEY. WHO HAD NEVER SPOKE AND
WHO WAS NEVER ABLE TO ARTICULATE
WHAT HER WANTS AND NEEDS WERE OR
EVEN ENGAGE AROUND HER PEERS.
SHE WAS PROVIDED WITH AN IPAD
WITH THE SPEECH GENERATING
APPLICATIONS AND BEGAN TO
UNDERSTAND HOW SHE CAN USE THAT
TO COMMUNICATE WHAT SHE WAS
WANTING AND WHAT SHE WAS SEEKING
WITH THOSE AROUND HER, AND AS
SHE RECOGNIZED THE CAPABILITY OF
THIS AND START TO SEE THE
POSSIBILITIES, IMAGINE THE
SMILE. THAT SHE HAD ON HER FACE
WHEN SHE REALIZED I FINALLY CAN
BE HEARD. I FINALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WHETHER THIS
IS OK OR NOT OK? SHE IS NOW
ROUTINELY COMMUNICATING WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. BECAUSE OF
THIS DEVICE. LET ME TALK ABOUT
MINA. SO SHE'D BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE. BUT WHEN SHE HAD A
DRACH, IT DID IT ELIMINATED HER
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE. A WHILE
IN TREATMENT. SHE WAS PROVIDED
WITH A SPEECH GENERATING DEVICE
THE IPAD WITH THE APPS ON IT IT
IT ENABLED HER TO AGAIN START TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THOSE AROUND
HER THAT ARE PROVIDING HER WITH
CARE, AND IT ALSO ENABLED HER TO
COMMUNICATE OVER THE TELEPHONE
REAL TIME TRANSLATION WITH HER
FAMILY WHO IS IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY. WHEN YOU THINK OF
SPEECH DEVICES, YOU GOT TO THINK
OF TWO THINGS. FOR SOME IT
UNLOCKS SPEECH FOR THE FIRST
TIME. FOR OTHERS. IT RESTORES
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE THAT
THEY MAY HAVE LOST. SO I WILL
STOP MY COMMENTS THERE. I'M GLAD
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS AS
WELL. THE DIRECTOR. HOW HOW CAN
ONE INDIVIDUAL APPLY TO OBTAIN
ONE OF THESE EQUIPMENTS? WELL SO
WE HAVE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE TRY TO MAKE
THIS PROGRAM KNOWN AS PROBABLY,
AS WE CAN, THROUGH ALL OF OUR
VARIOUS NETWORKS, INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS, ORIENTATION OR
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BLIND
PROGRAMS. UM INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEB PAGE. SO
IT'S AGAIN. HOW DO WE KEEP
MAKING IT KNOWN? AND THEN WE
LINK THE INDIVIDUAL TO THE
PROVIDERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
GET THE DEVICES AND THE
APPROPRIATE APPLICATIONS IN NEED
OF TRAINING INTO THE HANDS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL, BUT THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER TO REQUEST THIS NÓ. THEY
DO NOT, AND THEY DO NOT NEED TO
BE A REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER TO
REQUEST THIS, WE WORK
ESSENTIALLY WITH ANYBODY THAT
HAS THAT BARRIER TO
COMMUNICATIONS. OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
AND CLOSE OUR DEPARTMENT. UH,
REHABILITATION. WE ARE NOT GONNA
NOW GONNA DO PUBLIC COMMENT, UM
I'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE OUR S¼ A
S¼ L INTERPRETER. WE'RE ALL
GOOD. EVERYONE CAN SEE OUR
INTERPRETER. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND IF WE NEED TO ACCOMMODATE.
ANY FURTHER. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE UM YOU CAN SEE. OK, PERFECT
. ALL RIGHT, SO WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING PUBLIC COMMENT FIOS, ONE
AND TWO ON DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION ONLY. PLEASE
PROCEED. YEAH. MADAM CHAIR CARL
LONDON ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH I Dð Dð.
WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
PROVIDE A RANGE OF SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK VERY QUICKLY ON
ITEM ONE AND ALSO TO SORT OF
REINFORCE THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS RAISED BY MS GROVE.
CONCERN IS THAT AS WE LOOK AT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THE SUB MINIMUM
WAGE OPTION SHE'S RIGHT ON
TARGET. THERE ARE ABOUT 15,000
PEOPLE WE BELIEVE THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR OPPORTUNITY FOR EMPLOYMENT
STATEWIDE, AND THERE IS NOTHING
GOING ON IF THIS DEPARTMENT OR
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AT SCALE TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE A SHOT AT
EMPLOYMENT. YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO GIVE MONEY OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS FOR
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT FOR PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS. AND WE THINK YOU
DESERVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE THE
DATA ON HOW SUCCESSFUL THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE. HOW MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE SUCCESSFUL AT
TRANSITIONING? AND I THINK THE
OTHER IMPLICATION HERE IS THAT
IF THEY DON'T STAY IN SOME KIND
OF EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM, THE
QUESTION IS, WHERE ARE THEY AND
MANY OF THEM ARE SITTING AT HOME
OR THEY'RE MOVING TO A DAY
PROGRAM, WHICH RATE WISE JUST BY
RATES COST THE STATE MORE MONEY.
SO IT HAS A BUDGET IMPLICATION.
WE THINK YOU OUGHT TO BE ASKING
THE IS FOR DATA ON THIS TO GET A
CLEAR PICTURE AS TO WHAT'S GOING
ON. NOT JUST THIS DEPARTMENT,
BUT ALSO DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON ONE
AND TWO SEE NONE. THANK YOU,
DIRECTOR FOR COMING IN. YEAH.
WE'RE MOVING INTO OUR SECOND
DEPARTMENT. DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE. WHICH IS A Dð Dð S¼.
OVERVIEW. I ASKED THE DEPARTMENT
TO COME STEP ON IN. THE
DIRECTOR. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
QUESTION NUMBER ONE. OK? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. NANCY BARGEMAN
, DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. UM AND I
HAVE WITH ME. MY COLLEAGUE UH,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR JIM KNIGHT
THAT'S GOING TO ASSIST WITH
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ONE AND TWO.
I JUST LIKE TO FLAG A COUPLE OF
THINGS WITH THE CHAIR'S
PERMISSION TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF INVESTMENTS AND POLICY
CHANGES TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
VISION AND THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF OUR DEPARTMENT. UM
JUST HIGHLIGHTING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS REALLY EXPRESSED
THE INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE, UM, REALLY LIFTING UP
THE FACT THAT WE WANT A SYSTEM
THAT IS SUPPORTIVE OF EQUITY AND
CHOICE AND OPTIONS. AND OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, MANY OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO START LEADING WITH INCLUDE
THINGS THAT, UM, LIFT UP THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUTREACH LIFT UP
THE IMPORTANCE OF WORKFORCE
ISSUES, LIFT UP THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE SERVICE, ACCESS
AND EQUITY AND MANY OF THOSE
INITIATIVES. I WANTED TO COMMEND
THE, UM THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
AND ON THE AGENDA. THERE'S MANY
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE OUTLINED
IN THERE. AND WE, UM, ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
NOT EVERYBODY'S EXPERIENCE IS TO
THE STANDARD OF OUR VALUES AND
OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLES. WE ARE
AWARE OF THAT. WE ARE AWARE THAT
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THOSE INITIATIVES, AND I
APPRECIATE THE LIFTING UP SOME
OF THE KEY AREAS IN THE AGENDA
THAT WE'RE GONNA ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THOSE. UM, BUT I DO WANNA
JUST GIVE YOU SOME, UM, UPDATES
ON SOME OF THE INITIATIVES, I
I'M VERY PLEASED WITH THE FACT
THAT I GOT A CHANCE TO MEET WITH
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE TODAY ON SOME
OF THE INITIATIVES AND HEARING
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE ADVANCING ON
WORKFORCE BUT ALSO, UM,
LISTENING TO MY COLLEAGUE,
DIRECTOR XAVIER TALKING ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY, YOU KNOW, REALLY
REALIZING THAT THESE
ADVANCEMENTS ARE REALLY LIFE
CHANGING FOR INDIVIDUALS, WE GET
THE OPPORTUNITY WITH MANY OF
THESE THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW ON IN OUR YOUNGEST
POPULATION AND AFFECTING A
LIFELONG JOURNEY AS THEY LOOK
FOR SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT
MEET THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS AT
VARIOUS TIMES OF THEIR AGES AND
STAGES OF LIFE, SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND OUR
COMMUNITY ON ADVANCING IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES AND IMPROVING THOSE
EXPERIENCES. SO WITH THAT,
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ONE AND TWO,
I'M GOING TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE JIM KNIGHT. THANK YOU
AGAIN. JIM KNIGHT, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SO THE
FIRST QUESTION YOU ASKED WAS
ABOUT INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
DECREASE IN EXPECTED
EXPENDITURES IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND SO CAN I TAKE A STEP
BACK AT A HIGH LEVEL WHEN WE
DEVELOP OUR ESTIMATE? WE ARE
LOOKING AT, WITH MOST CURRENT
DATA AVAILABLE AND TRYING TO
PROJECT TRENDS AND LOOKING AT
TRENDS OVER THE YEARS TO SEE
WHERE EXPENDITURES HAVE GONE. AS
THE AGENDA NOTES THAT DURING
COVID, WE SAW A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN THE EXPENDITURE
LEVEL. AND SO WHEN WE WERE
DEVELOPING THE ENACTED BUDGET,
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN ABOUT A
YEAR AGO, THE EXPENDITURES AT
THAT TIME WERE STILL IMPACTED
AND INFLUENCED BY THE
EXPENDITURES THAT WE WERE SEEING
DURING COVID. AS WE NOW COME TO
IN THIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, YOU
NOTICE THAT THERE WAS A AN
ASSUMED REDUCTION IN ESTIMATED
EXPENDITURES IN THE CURRENT YEAR
, AND THAT IS REALLY BECAUSE NOW
WE HAVE A LOOK AT MORE CURRENT
DATA SO LAST FISCAL YEAR AND
IT'S BEEN AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH
WITH COVID TRYING TO DETERMINE
WHEN THAT NEW TREND OR WHERE
THAT NEW BASELINE IS. WE THINK
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE IT NOW,
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A REDUCTION
IN ESTIMATED EXPENDITURES IF YOU
LOOK AT ACTUAL EXPENDITURES OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. THOSE HAVE BEEN
TRENDING ON AVERAGE ABOUT 11%
INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR, WHEREAS
CASELOAD HAS BEEN ABOUT 5% SO
THAT'S BEEN RELATIVELY STABLE,
SO AND THIS ADJUSTMENT REALLY
GETS US BACK TO THAT TREND, SO
OVER TO DO FROM 2223 TO THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THEN FOR BUDGET
YEAR THAT TREND IS REFLECTED IN
OUR CURRENT ESTIMATE NOW.
ANOTHER WAS A QUESTION ABOUT
COULD IT POSSIBLY BE RELATED TO
ACCESS OR PROVIDER AND
WORKFORCE? HE AT A HIGH LEVEL
THAT DATA AGAIN. IT'S NOT REALLY
SURE. CERTAINLY WE'RE VERY MUCH
AWARE OF THE IMPACT OF THE
WORKFORCE AND THAT'S GOING ON.
NOT JUST IN THIS SYSTEM IN THE
STATE, BUT BUT EVERYWHERE BUT
REALLY, WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS MORE AT A HIGHER LEVEL
AND CERTAINLY IN DIRECTOR BARS
TOUCHED ON SOME OF THE WORKFORCE
ISSUES, AND I THINK WE'LL GET
INTO SOME OF THOSE, UM,
INITIATIVES IS LATER ON IN THE
AGENDA AS WELL. THINK YOUR NEXT
QUESTION WAS ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
WITH MEETING THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES, FINAL
RULE OR THE SETTING REQUIREMENTS
. THE AGENDA DOES A REAL GOOD
JOB OF LAYING THE BACKGROUND.
AND REALLY WHAT THE SPIRIT OF
THOSE RULES ARE ABOUT. AND EVEN
THOUGH WE CALL THEM RULES, IT'S
REALLY SETTING THAT EXPECTATION
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS AND REALLY HOW SERVICES
SHOULD BE PROVIDED. AND WE WERE
WE TALKED ABOUT LAST TIME GIVEN
AN EXTENSION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE PROVIDERS ARE DELIVERING
SERVICES IN LINE WITH THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT INVOLVED
US OVER THE, UM EXCUSE ME.
THROUGH AUGUST FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTERS, MOSTLY DOING VISITS AT
EACH OF THE LOCATIONS WHERE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED. SO WE
OUTLINED INCREMENTAL STEPS WHERE
WE GET TO 25% BY THE END OF
FEBRUARY AND SO ON UNTIL ALL
VISITS WERE COMPLETED IN AUGUST.
AS YOU POINTED OUT THAT ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL, UM SEEM TO BE
TRACKING PRETTY WELL. BUT THERE
ARE SOME REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE
WE ARE SEEING SOME SOME, UH
THEY'RE NOT AT THAT SAME PACE,
SO WE ARE HAVING CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM. WE'VE
OUTLINED THEY'VE OUTLINED AND
WORK WITH THEM TO DEVELOP A PLAN
TO MEET THOSE THOSE VISITS HAVE
STARTED. UM AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ARE COMPLETED
AND WE GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO
BE. AND IT'S MORE. I JUST ALSO
WANNA POINT OUT. IT'S MORE THAN
JUST THE WORK WITH THE
PROVIDERS. AS I AS I SAID, THIS
IS ABOUT EXPECTATIONS FOR PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE SERVICES AND WHAT
THEIR EXPERIENCES ARE SO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT WORK OF
NOT ONLY TRAINING, INFORMATION
SHARING AND THE LIKE, SO THAT
EVERYONE IS AWARE OF REALLY WHAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE RULES
ARE. AND SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD. SO THANKS. DOES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LEO
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO
THIS? CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOTHING
FOR THEIR DAD. I DON'T OK, UM
CAN YOU CLARIFY A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER ON THE REMAINING
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO MEET OUR STATEWIDE?
UM TRAJECTORY IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION? I WILL. I WILL WANT
TO NOTE THOUGH. LAST YEAR IT WAS
A MORE Dð. IT WAS A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION. I KNOW WE'VE DONE
SO MUCH BETTER SINCE LAST YEAR,
SO I DO WANNA COMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT ON THAT. BUT ON THOSE
SINGLE ONE OFFS, UM, CAN YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
NOT JUST MERELY TALKING TO THEM,
BUT WHAT ARE THE REMAINING
BARRIERS FOR THOSE CENTERS TO
GET ON PAR WITH THE REST OF THE
CENTERS? IN ONE CASE IN
PARTICULAR, IT'S ABOUT THEM KIND
OF ORGANIZING THEMSELVES, EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE HAVING SOME
CHALLENGES. WORKFORCE CHALLENGES
, IN PARTICULAR OF TRYING TO
BRING SOME EXTRA FOLKS ON
HELPING REPRIORITIZE AND MAKING
SURE THAT THIS GETS DONE SO IT'S
NOT JUST TALKING, BUT WORKING
THROUGH AND HEY WHAT IS THE
PLAN? HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
THERE? SO OK AND THEN, DIRECTOR.
I HAVE JUST I DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS, AND WE DIDN'T PUT
THIS ON THE AGENDA BECAUSE WE
HAVE A HEAVY PACKED AGENDA FOR
THREE ITEMS THAT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE FOR THE MAY REVISE,
ARE CONSIDERED AS WE'RE LOOKING
TO FIND SOME UNSPENT DOLLARS
WHEN WE COMES TO PORTERVILLE, UH
, HOW THE GOVERNOR IS ASKED TO
REPLENISH THE 20 EXTRA POSITIONS
, EVEN THOUGH OUR NUMBERS
HAVEN'T INCREASED IN RESIDENTS
WONDERING IF WE REALLY DO NEED
THAT MONEY FOR THE EXTRA 20
EMPLOYEES, UM FOR THE WORKLOAD
INVESTMENTS, THERE'S POTENTIALLY
SOME UNSPENT FUNDS IN THAT AREA,
UM ENSURING THAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT THAT SPACE AS WELL.
AND FINALLY, FOR THE COMPLEX
NEEDS HOME. WE HAVEN'T REALLY
DONE A LOT OF THAT BUILDING. UH
SO AGAIN UNSPENT FUNDS THERE
THAT WE CAN TRACK BACK THIS
YEAR. THOSE ARE THE THREE THINGS
THAT CAME TO MIND. HELLO. DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT? I
MEAN, YOU'RE NOT A LÀ. PERMANENT
FIES. MADAM CHAIR CHRIS O'NEILL
AGAIN. I'M JUST CLARIFYING THE
ON THE PORTERVILLE REQUEST, NOT
20 POSITIONS. IT WAS WE? WE
ALWAYS BUDGET UM DEPARTMENTS
BASED ON THEIR AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS, AND SO WHEN WE DID
OUR NUMBERS AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE? WE LOOKED AT WHAT
WAS A REASONABLE, REASONABLE
SAVINGS IN CURRENT AIR BASED ON
MY VACANCY RATE, AND THAT ENDED
UP BEING $20 MILLION THAT WE
SCORED ON THAT. YES EXACTLY. SO
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY, UH, $20
FIGURE NÓ NÓ. THANK YOU. LEO ANY
COMMENTS ON GREAT AND THEN MY
OTHER QUESTION IS REGARDING. UM
I KNOW YOU SPOKE ABOUT IN REGARD
TO THE FIRST QUESTION.
POTENTIALLY THE WORK CASE, UM,
RATIOS. YOU DIVE A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER ON THE BIGGER UMBRELLA
WORKLOAD. I MEAN WORKFORCE,
RIGHT? BUT DO WE ALSO SEE THAT
IT'S ALSO SOME BARRIERS THAT
STILL EXIST THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY IMPACT OUR RATIOS AS
WELL? THEY ARE. THEY ARE
IMPACTING OUR ISSUES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. SO I. I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IS RELATED TO THE
RATIOS FOR THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND THE WORKFORCE WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. SO WE, UM
COMPLIANCE. I HATE TO USE THE
TERM COMPLIANCE, BUT IT IS WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT OUR CASELOAD
RATIOS ACROSS THE STATE OF THE
21 REGIONAL CENTERS. WE ARE
SEEING SOME REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE KIND OF HIRING TO, UM,
FOR EXAMPLE, OUR BIRTH TO FIVE
CASELOAD RATIOS THAT WE'VE TO
GET TO THE 1 TO 40. SO WE HAVE
MANY OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHED BEING
ABLE TO GET THERE. WE HAVE OTHER
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE
REALLY STRUGGLED IN HIRING THE
STAFF. SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN GETTING A WORK
GROUP TO PROVIDE SUPPORTS AND
THINK A STRATEGIES OF HIRING.
AND HOW DO WE KIND OF BUILD
AROUND THAT? UM WE HAD THE
INVESTMENT OF THE TUITION AND
HELPING WITH PROVIDING TUITION
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR SOME OF THE
EMPLOYEES WITHIN THE REGIONAL
CENTER. TO ADVANCE THEIR
EDUCATION, BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE'S STILL SOME WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES, PARTICULARLY EVEN
BEYOND THE SERVICE COORDINATORS,
CLINICIANS. WE STILL CONTINUE TO
SEE A SHORTAGE OF CLINICIANS. UM
IT IS, UM HIGH ON OUR RADAR AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE. ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL KIND OF COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS THAT CAN BE DONE IN
BEING ABLE TO HELP SOME OF THE
CENTERS THAT ARE LAGGING BEHIND
IN LOOKING AT STRATEGIES AND
EFFECTIVENESS TO BE ABLE TO HIRE
THE SERVICE COORDINATORS FOLLOW
UP ON THE ONES THAT ARE FALLING
BEHIND IS THAT FURTHER EXPANDING
OUR RACIAL DISPARITIES IS, IS IT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS THAT ARE IN
THE AREAS THAT ARE MOST LEAST
SERVE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES OR BY COMMUNITIES?
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION. YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA IS VERY DIVERSE STATE
SO LARGELY THE MAJORITY OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS REALLY DO
SUPPORT OUR BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. UM THE PARTICULAR
REGIONAL CENTERS. UM, I WOULD
SAY THAT IT'S NOT THE MAJORITY
OF THE INDIVIDUALS, BUT IT
IMPACTS ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS,
YOU KNOW, AND CERTAINLY WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
COMMUNITY THAT'S MARGINALIZED
AND MAKING SURE WE ARE
SUPPORTING THEM. UM BUT WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT ARE ARE ARE VERY
FAR BEHIND. HIRING THE STAFF,
AND THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO PUT
SOME FOCUS ON IT AND SEE HOW WE
CAN ASSIST THEM AND BEING ABLE
TO ADVANCE AND BE ABLE TO FILL
THOSE GAPS. OK, MY LAST QUESTION
I'LL TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES IS
REGARDING, UM, LAST YEAR IN THE
BUDGET WE ALLOCATED FOR
POSITIONS REGARDING IN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF A B 1957 FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK DA DATA ON THE IP
P, S¼ AND SO FORTH. HAVE WE
STARTED HAVE THOSE POSITIONS
BEEN WORKING WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION? YEAH, WE'VE BEEN
HIRING POSITIONS. UM, WE HAD A
LARGE NUMBER OF POSITIONS THAT
WE NEEDED TO KIND OF FILL AND
RAMPING UP. WE HAVE I. I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU. I DON'T HAVE IN
FRONT OF ME TODAY EXACTLY HOW
MANY OF THOSE POSITIONS BUT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. WE HAVE A
ELECTRONIC RECORD SYSTEM THAT
HELPS US TRACK. UM MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IS CENTRALIZED.
I WON'T GET INTO TOO MUCH OF THE
DETAIL OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF
BEING ABLE TO UPDATE THAT SYSTEM
. UM IS NOT THE MOST INTUITIVE
AND FLEXIBLE. UM, SO WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. I IS
APPARENTLY RIGHT, SO IT IT. I
WILL TELL YOU WE'RE NOT AS FAR
IN THAT PARTICULAR INITIATIVE
AND MANDATE THAT I'D LIKE TO BE.
UM, WE ARE SOMEWHAT BEHIND IN
THAT AREA, BUT WE ARE DEVELOPING
THE STRATEGIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COLLECTING IT GETTING IT
POSTED. UM BECAUSE IT IS
INFORMATION THAT WE ALSO WANT
BUT KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DO IT
FOR THE TRANSPARENCY INTENDED
FOR THIS BILL, OK? PAN. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW, I
VIEW THIS AS SORT OF A CORE
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT. THE
SERVICES THAT YOU PROVIDE AND
YOU SUPERVISE, AND IT'S SORT OF
A UNIQUE SITUATION. AT LEAST IT
SEEMS TO ME SOMEWHAT UNIQUE IN
THAT THE MANAGEMENT AND CONTROL
IS NOT AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. I
MEAN LOCALLY IS NOT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL, BUT INSTEAD AS
WITH A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE REFERRED TO AS REGIONAL
CENTERS, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HAD
SOME ISSUES WITH PAYMENTS TO
VENDORS AND OUT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER IN THE DISTRICT THAT I'M
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT, UM AND
IT APPEARS TO ME THAT THE SYSTEM
THIS WHOLE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE SET
UP LONG AGO THAT WILL NOT NOT TO
CHANGE IT BY THE WAY, BUT THAT
THE SYSTEM ITSELF LACKS
STANDARDIZATION IN TERMS OF
PROCESS AND SYSTEMS, UM AND
PERFORMANCE. UM IT MUST BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO AUDIT AND TO GET
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY CRUNCH
TOGETHER. THAT MEANS ANYTHING.
IT SEEMS TO ME. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THIS. HOW HOW DO YOU
PROPOSE OR HOW? WHAT SHOULD WE
DO? I'M A MILITARY GUY TO
STRENGTHEN THE COMMAND AND
CONTROL OF THIS WHOLE THING.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH. GREAT
QUESTION, UM, WITH AND IF YOU
WILL, I'D LIKE TO GO AND
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE MORE
RECENT INVESTMENTS BUT NOT ONLY
THE INVESTMENTS, SOME OF THE
POLICIES THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN,
UM, OUTLINED THROUGH SOME
LEGISLATIVE ACTION, CERTAINLY
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
STANDARDIZATION YOU'RE RIGHT. IT
IS HARD TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
STANDARDIZED MEASURES TO BE ABLE
TO EVALUATE. UM MUCH OF THE WORK
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IN LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE STANDARDIZE VENDOR
ORGANIZATION FOR EACH REGIONAL
CENTER? WE KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN
VERY FRUSTRATING FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. SOMETIMES WHEN THEY
HAVE TO GET VENDORED AND GO TO
21, DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS
AND MAY HAVE TO FOLLOW 21,
DIFFERENT RULES. YOU KNOW, WE
ALSO KNOW INTAKE HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR, UM FAMILIES THAT
FOR US TO EVEN PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
TO HOW INDIVIDUALS ARE
EXPERIENCING INTAKE. A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS WHEN WE I'M
I'VE BEEN HYPER FOCUSED ON DATA
RECENTLY BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY
GONNA BE ABLE TO MAKE CHANGES
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE. ONE OF THE AREAS IS
CERTAINLY AN EARLY START AND
INTAKE WHEN WE HAVE A MANDATE
FOR UNDER OUR FEDERAL GRANT TO
HAVE FROM 45 DAYS FROM THE POINT
OF CONTACT WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER TO THE POINT OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY SERVICES PLAN,
AND THEN ULTIMATELY DISSERVICES
WELL. WHEN WE WERE MONITORING TO
THAT WE WERE SEEING THAT GOSH,
WE'RE REALLY CLOSE TO 100% THEN
WE STARTED DRILLING INTO THAT
DATA. WE REALIZED THERE WAS A
DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF THAT
POINT OF INTAKE. SO SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS WERE DOING IT
FROM THE POINT OF COMPLETING AN
APPLICATION. THEN WE'RE DOING IT
FROM THE POINT OF THE PHONE CALL
, SO I THINK THIS GETS TO YOUR
POINT. HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT IF WE DON'T
HAVE SOME OF THOSE STANDARDS, SO
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED NOW? A
STANDARD DEFINITION. OF THAT
POINT OF CONTACT SO WE CAN HOLD
REGIONAL CENTERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT TIMELINE. THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
REALLY DRILLING INTO THE DATA
THAT WE'RE GETTING. WE'RE WHILE
WE'RE STILL YOU KNOW, TRYING TO
CATCH UP WITH MODERN DAY
TECHNOLOGY ON SOME OF THE DATA.
WE HAD FAR ADVANCED IN THE LAST
2 TO 3 YEARS FURTHER THAN WE'VE
HAD, I WOULD SAY, SINCE I'VE
BEEN AT THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
LAST 10 YEARS. THIS DATA, WHICH
WERE ULTIMATELY ALSO STARTING TO
PUT INTO DASHBOARDS. WHAT CAN BE
TRANSPARENT FOR THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL, BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AS A
DEPARTMENT FOR OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, WE ALSO HELP
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
TRANSPARENT TO THE COMMUNITY, SO
WE CAN ALSO HAVE THE COMMUNITY
BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE MEASURES. SO MUCH OF
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW IS REALLY GETTING TO IT. I
WILL FLAG THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA. I THINK DOUBLES DOWN ON
THOSE EFFORTS TO SAY FROM A
MASTER PLAN PERSPECTIVE. GAPS
STILL, WHAT IS THAT FUTURE? WHAT
IS IT THAT MODERNIZING AND
REALLY EVALUATING THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
AND THEN WHERE CAN WE GO? SO I
HOPE THAT KIND OF ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION OF SAYING WE'RE NOT
WAITING TO SEE WHAT IS KIND OF A
SYSTEM IN THE 21ST CENTURY. WHAT
IS IT THAT WE CAN DO TODAY TO,
UM, MEET THE PROMISE OF THE
LANTERMAN ACT AND TO PROVIDE
THAT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY? MANY INITIATIVES
ARE THERE. IT'S EXCITING TO SEE.
UM AND IF I HAD MY MAGIC WAND,
THEY'D ALL BE DONE TODAY. UM,
BUT WE'RE STILL GONNA NEED A
LITTLE TIME TO IMPLEMENT THEM.
WHAT SEEMS TO ME? THE PROBLEM IS
WE'RE DEALING WITH NONPROFITS. I
THINK THAT HAVE BOARDS.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS SET THEIR
OWN. BEAT UM, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE MONEY PASSES THROUGH US
, AND THIS IS A CORE GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION OF THE STATE TO PROVIDE
A SYSTEM ASSISTANCE TO FOLKS WHO
ARE MOST VULNERABLE. UH, WHO
NEED OUR HELP AND THE FACT THAT
THINGS ARE NOT STANDARDIZED
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THINGS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT, IS INTERFERING
WITH OUR ABILITY AS A STATE TO
PERFORM OUR CORE GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION. UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
NOT LIKE ONE OF THOSE FAMOUS Tð
VÆ SHOWS WHERE THAT YOU'RE
FIRED. AND BRING SOME OTHER TEAM
IN BECAUSE YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
IT'S HIGHLY DISRUPTIVE WON'T
WORK. CREATES PROBLEMS FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE THINK ABOUT
TALK ABOUT WORK FOR EVERY SINGLE
DAY WHO WERE IN THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE SITUATIONS. UM, SEEMS
TO ME THAT WE'RE GONNA WE OUGHT
TO COME UP WITH WHAT OUR
TEMPLATE IS FOR HOW REGIONAL
CENTERS SHOULD PERFORM, WHETHER
IT'S SYSTEMS WHETHER IT'S
POLICIES PROCESS TIME LINES. IN
A WAY THAT YOU CAN MONITOR YOU
CAN MEASURE AND YOU CAN TAKE
ACTION. PUT IT OUT THERE. GIVE
HIM A PERIOD OF TIME. ALL OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS A PERIOD OF
TIME TO GET IN LINE, AND IT MAY
TAKE A WHILE IT MAY TAKE A YEAR
MAY TAKE 2 MAY TAKE THREE IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SYSTEMS
COMPLIANCE BUT THEN EVERYBODY'S
ON THE SAME. PLAYING FIELD AND
EVERYBODY CAN BE MEASURED AT THE
SAME WAY. I THINK THE
INCREMENTAL APPROACH
UNFORTUNATELY, I'M CONCERNED
THAT WE'LL NEVER GET IT DONE. UM
BUT BUT THAT'S JUST MY THOUGHT,
AND WE DO HAVE A AN AGENDA THAT
IS 10 MILES LONG. SO I AM GOING
TO ZIP MY LIPS. THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW, I THINK, NÓ SENATOR, I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU HIT IT ON THE
NAIL FOR THIS AND JUST LAST YEAR
OR WITH OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. WE DID A BIG CHUNK OF
THAT, AND ISSUE THREE IS TO SEE
HOW FAR THAT EFFORT HAS COME
SHORT ISSUED THREE. WE'RE GOING
TO LEARN ABOUT SOME OF THE
STANDARDIZATION THAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED AND THEN SEE HOW
ISSUED TWO ON THE MASTER PLAN OF
AGING CAN THEN SUPPORT OUR
EFFORTS AND EXPAND ON THAT. SO I
THINK YOU HAD IT RIGHT ON THE
NO. AND YOU'RE ON THE AGENDA.
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. SENATOR
EDMUND. I JUST HAVE ONE FINAL
THOUGHT QUESTION FOR YOU, MR
KNIGHT. QUESTION NUMBER TWO YOU
SPOKE ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOW WE'RE HELPING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS, BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF I REMEMBER YOU ANSWERING
THE LAST PORTION OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDERS THAT
DO NOT COME. INTO COMPLIANCE.
YES SORRY. UM, SO KIND OF A
GRADUATED, UH, WAY THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH PROVIDERS. SO IF
FIND THAT THERE ARE SOME AREAS
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED, ARE
SUPPOSED TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT DOESN'T WORK WORK UP TO A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
ULTIMATELY THERE'S STILL NOT
MEETING THAT WE CAN WE'LL THEN
MOVE INTO WHERE THERE'D BE A
MORATORIUM IF YOU WILL ON
REFERRALS FOR NEW INDIVIDUALS TO
SERVE. ULTIMATELY THOUGH, IT
COULD LEAD TO THAT THAT THE
PROVIDER WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES ANYMORE.
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO GET
THERE, BUT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH IN THE REQUIREMENTS
IS THAT WITHIN A SIX MONTH
PERIOD ONE YEAR PERIOD WE'RE
TALKING IN FIVE YEARS. MAYBE WE
COME BACK TO THAT PROVIDER OR
NO, IT WOULDN'T BE FOR FIVE
YEARS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT I CAN
GET YOU SOME MORE DETAILS ON
WHERE WE'RE WHAT TIMELINE WE
LAID OUT IN THE DIRECTIVE THAT
WE HAVE OKAY, AND IT'S A
STANDARDIZED TIMELINE FOR EVERY
PROVIDER IF THEY DON'T MEET A
CERTAIN GOLD BENCHMARK. WELL
RIGHT NOW, WITH THE CORRECT WITH
WHAT WE HAVE TO FIRST WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WE SAID, WE
HAVE TO BE IN COMPLIANCE OR MEET
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS BY THE END
OF THE THIS YEAR. SO PERFECT.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THAT ITEM WORD NOT HOLDING
CENTER GROWTH. SHE HAS THE HABIT
OF LOOKING THAT WAY TO HER RIGHT
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T ALWAYS GRACE
US WITH HER PRESENCE AND NOT
USED FORGETS. I'M HERE. UM
TOUCHE. THE ONE THAT SO I DO
HAVE A QUESTION ON PAGE 15 OF
OUR INFORMATION INFORMATION. I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ON YOURS
FAIRLY WARM. SHUT DOWN. $11.3
MILLION. WHAT IS A WARM SHUTDOWN
? AND CAN YOU DESCRIBE THAT TO
ME? YES SIR. FOR FAIRVIEW, JUST
AS A REMINDER BACK IN 2015. WE
TOOK ACTION TO GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE ALL THE REMAINING THIS WAS
A HISTORICAL EVENT OF CLOSING
ALL THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FAIRVIEW WAS ONE OF THE LAST
ONES AS WELL, SO THERE'S STILL
EFFORT THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
UNTIL THE DISPOSITION OF THE
PROPERTY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID
WAS SONOMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
SO THE WARM SHUTDOWN IS MAKING
SURE THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE STILL
IN OPERATION BECAUSE IF YOU TOOK
ALL TOTALLY SHUT DOWN SOME OF
THE UTILITIES AND THE THINGS
THAT KIND OF GENERATE THE WORK
IN THE LIGHTS ARE ON AND THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN EVEN
FOR THE NEXT PHASE FOR THE
DISPOSITION OF THE PROPERTY. SO
THAT'S WHAT WARM SHUTDOWN IS
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE STAFF
AND THE RESOURCES TO DO THAT.
HOW MANY STAFF ARE AT THAT WARM?
SHUT DOWN. I'D HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND THEN ON PAGE 16. IT
TALKS ABOUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
A MASTER PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND LIKE A
LARGE PROVIDERS, OR EVEN SMALL
PROVIDERS THAT SPECIFICALLY
THAT'S THE NEXT ISSUE. OKAY,
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
WHOLE PANEL ON THAT. THANK YOU.
MHM OKAY, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WE'RE GOING TO
DO OUR FIRST PANEL OF THE OF THE
AFTERNOON. THE MASTER PLAN FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES DIRECTOR
WELCOME YOU TO STAY SEATED, AND
THEY WERE GOING TO WELCOME UP
THE REST OF OUR PANELISTS. FOR
HOUSE, SO GET COMFY IN THERE.
OKAY? ONE OF YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
IF YOU NEED TO BE ONLY ONE L, A
CHAIR TODAY. HERE. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SHIRTS. WE GOT ONE MORE
CHAIR OVER HERE. I THINK WE
MIGHT BE OKAY. I CAN SWAP OUT WE
MIGHT NEED ONE MORE PERFECT.
SWITCHBACKS. I ASKED WHEN IT
GETS TO YOUR TURN TO SPEAK TO
PLEASE, UM, INTRODUCE YOURSELF
SO THAT I DON'T PUT YOUR YOUR
NAMES. WE WILL START WITH OUR
DIRECTOR WHO WILL KICK US OFF.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, NANCY
BARGMANN, DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES, AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE THIS TOPIC FOR ISSUE
TWO ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. UM WHEN
THE INTRODUCTION OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
WAS INTRODUCED AND ANNOUNCED BY
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY IMMEDIATE
QUESTIONS CAME UP FROM OUR
COMMUNITY, AND I JUST WANT TO
KIND OF LEAD WITH THAT. UM SOME
OF THE CONCERNS WERE WAIT. IS
THIS GOING TO AFFECT OUR
ENTITLEMENT IN CALIFORNIA WERE
VERY UNIQUE. WE ARE ONE OF A
KIND IN THE NATION AND HAVING AN
ENTITLEMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. OR IS THIS REALLY
MOVING US TO MANAGE CARE? OR IS
THIS GOING TO BE A BUDGET
SOLUTION? SO I JUST WANT TO LEAD
WITH THAT'S NOT WHAT THE MASTER
PLAN IS ABOUT. IT REALLY IS
ABOUT INTENDING A VERY
INTENTIONAL APPROACH TO CREATING
A VISION FOR WHAT THE SYSTEM CAN
LOOK LIKE LONG TERM. INCLUDING
THE VISION AND INPUT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ARE ADVOCATES SYSTEM
PARTNERS. WHEN I SAY SYSTEM
PARTNERS, IT'S OUTSIDE A
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FROM SELF ADVOCATES
AND FAMILIES. IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO THIS
SYSTEM IS THEIR SYSTEM AND SO
HAVING THE VOICES AT THE TABLE
AND REALLY BEING ABLE TO CREATE
THAT CREATE THAT VISION. WITH
THAT CENTRAL POINT AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE EMBRACING THAT
IS EXTREMELY CRITICAL AS I
SHARED EARLIER, THERE'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE INVESTMENTS WERE
STILL IN ANY VARIOUS STAGES OF
IMPLEMENTING THOSE INVESTMENTS
TO AFFECT CHANGE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE STRENGTHENING OUR
SYSTEM TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES THAT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
TRANSPARENCY, MAKING SURE WE'RE
ADVANCING THOSE REALLY CRITICAL
AREAS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING A SYSTEM THAT IS
MEASURING QUALITY OUT. COMES AT
THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL, BUT IT'S
MORE THAN THAT. SO REALLY HAVING
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A MASTER PLAN
TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT YOU KNOW WHAT IS
THE FUTURE? SO LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE NEXT 10 YEARS? YOU KNOW,
WE'VE BEEN AS A LANDERMAN ACT
ENACTED SINCE 1969. AND SO
THERE'S BEEN MANY CHANGES,
HISTORICAL CHANGES WE MENTIONED,
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE CLOSURE OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
THERE'S BEEN MANY OTHER THINGS,
BUT RIGHT NOW, WITH MANY OF THE
INITIATIVES AND MANY OF THINGS
WE'VE BEEN DOING MANY TIMES IS
KIND OF IN REACTION TO SO WHAT
IS GOING TO BE THAT VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY OF LISTENING TO
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES, AND
THAT IS REALLY THE PRIORITY OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING AND
VERY AUTHENTIC ENGAGEMENT WITH
OUR COMMUNITY NOT ONLY BY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE GOING OUT
TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
LISTENING TO THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES. IT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY DIVERSE OUTREACH IS GOING
TO BE VERY DIVERSE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE TOUCHING ALL
COMMUNITY. WHETHER IT'S RURAL,
WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW, TAKING A
LOOK AT OUR RELATIONSHIP IN
TALKING WITH OUR BIBLE
COMMUNITIES. THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES LOOKING AT ARE VERY,
YOU KNOW, VERY DIVERSE COMMUNITY
THAT WERE CHANGING AS A SYSTEM
LOOKING AT THE DATA WHAT THAT
MEANS. BUT AGAIN, MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A MASTER PLAN THAT
IS REALLY WRITTEN AND FOCUS OF
THOSE WHO RECEIVE SERVICES. ALSO
REALLY PLEASED TO SHARE WITH
YOU. THAT THIS SECRETARY HAS
ALSO SELECTED VICTOR VICTOR
DORAN, WHO IS A CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF REHAB
TO BE THE DIRECTOR OF THE MASTER
PLAN. I'M PARTICULARLY PLEASED
BY THIS. HE'S JUST AN INCREDIBLE
PARTNER AND I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE WORK THAT HE IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO WITH THIS
LEADERSHIP. I WILL ALSO FLY JUST
A COUPLE OF OTHER LEADERS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE WORKING AND
SUPPORTING THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE. CATHERINE BLAKEMORE
IS THE FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA
SHE IS GOING TO BE A SUBJECT
MATTER. EXPERT DR OLIVIA
REINER'S THE DIRECTOR OF THE
SERGEANT CENTER AT YOU. CLA IS
FORMER DIRECTOR OUT THERE IS
GOING TO DO A COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT FOR SELF ADVOCATES, AND
THEN FURTHER WE HAVE MANY OF THE
LEADERSHIPS WITHIN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
TO INCLUDE THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER. AND THEN WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO LEAN IN AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE PEER SUPPORTS FOR
OURSELF ADVOCATES. SO RIGHT NOW
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND HAND
IT OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE AND HAVE
VICTOR DORAN BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOU MORE DETAIL TO THE WORK AND
IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DIRECTOR OF ARGUMENT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE ABOUT THIS REALLY
EXCITING WORK. WE'RE ABOUT TO
EMBARK ON FIRST. I JUST WANT TO
SAY WHAT AN HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
IT IS TO HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
SUPPORT THIS INCREDIBLE ENDEAVOR
THAT I HAVE NO DOUBT WILL CHANGE
COUNTLESS LIVES AND REALLY SET
US ON AN ASPIRATIONAL PATH FOR
THE FUTURE. OBVIOUSLY THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM IS
CORE TO THIS WORK, BUT WE
RECOGNIZE AND IN THIS MASTER
PLAN WE WANT TO SEE REFLECTED
THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT TOUCH THE
LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS WITH ID ARE
MUCH GREATER THAN JUST THE CORE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM,
RECOGNIZING EVERYTHING FROM
EDUCATION TO EMPLOYMENT TO
HEALTHCARE IS A PART OF THE
LIFESPAN OF ANY INDIVIDUAL,
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE A
DISABILITY, AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
TO DEVELOP A MASTER PLAN THAT IS
ASPIRATIONAL THAT WILL LAY OUT
PRIORITIES AND BOLD GOALS AND
HELP HOLISTICALLY LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND AT THE
INDIVIDUAL AS A WHOLE PERSON. IN
ORDER TO LAY OUT A VISION THAT
LOOKS AT WHAT WE IN CALIFORNIA
WANT THE ARC OF THE LIFE OF A
PERSON WITH I DECIDED TO LOOK
LIKE AND TO BRING ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS DAY IN THIS STATE
TO BEAR ACROSS ALL STAGES OF
LIFE FOR A PERSON WITH I D D D
UM THIS MASTER PLAN WILL REALLY
BE ANCHORED IN BRINGING THE
VOICES OF LIVED EXPERIENCE
FORWARD, BRINGING DIVERSE VOICES
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MOST
DIRECTLY IMPACTED WHO HAVE THAT
LIVED EXPERIENCE OR AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS ENDEAVOR. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE STRONGLY ENOUGH IS
THAT THAT EQUITY LENS WILL BE A
CORE PART OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO IN THE MASTER PLAN, SOMETHING
THAT IS, UH, SO IMPORTANT TO ALL
OF THE COMMUNITIES AS WE'VE BEEN
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS, AND
I'LL JUST SHARE FOR ME
PERSONALLY AS A MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT AS A FAMILY MEMBER TO
PEOPLE WITH, I'D DÍAS REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF MY CORE VALUES
AS WELL. AND TO THAT END, I ALSO
WANT TO FLAG THAT CENTERING THE
VOICES OF THE COMMUNITY OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE WILL BE FUNDAMENTAL
IN WHAT WE CREATE. THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE THE ADMINISTRATION,
CREATING A MASTER PLAN. AND THIS
WILL BE THE ADMINISTRATION,
CREATING THE SPACE AND PROVIDING
THE RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY WORK
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE
AND HAVE OUR STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE HELP US LIFT UP OTHER
VOICES THAT NEED TO BE AT THE
TABLE. TO DEVELOP A MASTER PLAN
THAT WILL SET THAT VISION THAT
AND THOSE BOLD GOALS FOR FUTURE
SO I'LL TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON
THE TIMELINE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT. WE HAVE JUST LAUNCHED THIS
ENDEAVOR. WE ARE SO EXCITED.
I'VE BEGUN MEETING INDIVIDUALLY
WITH MEMBERS OF THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE, AND WE'VE PLANNED OUT
THE FIRST SERIES OF MEETINGS.
THESE MEETINGS WILL BE OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC AND WE WILL BE
BUILDING IN ROBUST PUBLIC
COMMENT OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT
ALL OF OUR MEETINGS. OUR FIRST
FULL STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE
MEETING WILL BE SCHEDULED, AND
WE HAVE SHARED THIS INFORMATION
WITH YOUR STAFF AHEAD OF TIME,
BUT I'LL JUST RESTATE HERE THAT
IT WILL BE SCHEDULED FOR APRIL
10TH HERE IN SACRAMENTO WITH A
VIRTUAL OPTION, WE WILL HAVE A
SECOND MEETING ON APRIL 24TH
THAT WILL BE ALL VIRTUAL, AND WE
WILL HAVE A THIRD MEETING IN LOS
ANGELES ON MAY 15TH THAT WILL
ALSO HAVE A VIRTUAL OPTION. IN
THAT FIRST MEETING. WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO FOCUS ON WHAT ARE OUR
SHARED VALUES THAT ARE GOING TO
GUIDE OUR WORK AND BEGIN
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS THAT
ASPIRATIONAL VISION FOR THE
FUTURE THAT OUR STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE AVAILABLE TO
PARTICIPATE WANT TO SET FORTH
THAT WE WILL ANCHOR OURSELVES IN
AS WE DEVELOP THIS MASTER PLAN
IN THAT SECOND MEETING, WE WILL
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE
LOGISTICS OF HOW WE WILL CONDUCT
OUR BUSINESS MOVING FORWARD, BUT
REALLY GET INTO THE BRAIN
STORMING OF WHAT WILL THOSE TOP
PRIORITIES LOOK LIKE AND HOW
WILL THEY INFORM WORKING GROUPS
AND SUB COMMITTEES THAT WILL
DEVELOP TO CARRY OUT THIS WORK?
AND THEN IN THAT THIRD MEETING
REALLY FOCUS ON EQUITY, A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT ARE THE
EQUITY ISSUES AT PLAY? HOW ARE
WE LOOKING AT EQUITY? AND WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESS AND ACHIEVE EQUITY IN
THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
MASTER PLAN? WE INTEND THIS
PROCESS TO RUN ABOUT A YEAR OR
GOAL IS TO HAVE A DRAFT OF THE
MASTER PLAN THAT WE CAN PRESENT
BY MARCH OF 2025, YOU KNOW, AND
OF COURSE, TRYING TO MAINTAIN
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THAT, GIVEN
THAT THIS WILL BE DRIVEN AND
REALLY CENTERED AROUND
PARTICIPATION WITH THE
COMMUNITY. AND WE INTEND TO
SHARE THE FULL CALENDAR OF THE
REST OF THE MEETINGS BEFORE THAT
MAY 25TH MEETING SO THAT
EVERYONE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ARE ABLE TO
PLAN AND BE AWARE AND
PARTICIPATE TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEIR AVAILABILITY PERMITS IN
THE MEETINGS AND IN THE PROCESS.
THE INTENT IS THAT BY THE TIME
WE COMPLETE THIS PROCESS, WE
WILL HAVE A MASTER PLAN THAT NOT
JUST HAS BOLD GOALS. BUT THAT'S
A ROADMAP FOR HOW WE ACHIEVE
THEM. WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE FOR
US TO KNOW THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
ON THE RIGHT TRACK, SO IT'S
ASPIRATIONAL BUT CONCRETE, WE
WILL HAVE MILESTONES AND WE WILL
HAVE A WAY TO TRACK WHETHER WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
ACHIEVING THAT ASPIRATIONAL
VISION. AND AGAIN, I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT ALL OF THE
PRIORITIES ALL OF THE GOALS WILL
REALLY BE DRIVEN BY THE VOICES
OF LIVED EXPERIENCE, WHICH IS
THE MEMBERS OF THE STATE QUARTER
COMMITTEE AND THROUGH OUR
ENGAGEMENTS IN WITH IT THROUGH A
NUMBER OF OTHER VENUES THAT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO DESCRIBE AND ALSO
LIFTING UP. THE VOICE IS AT THE
ADVERTISEMENT OF THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE REPRESENTED AT THE TABLE.
YOU. CAN YOU ANSWER ONE OF THE
LAST QUESTIONS WITHIN THREE. ARE
WE LOOKING TO CREATE A CABINET
WORKING GROUPS SEEN AS THE
SERVICES ARE OFFERED BY A
VARIETY OF DEPARTMENTS LIKE WE
DID FOR THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING. SO AT THIS TIME, A
CABINET WORKING GROUP IS NOT
CURRENTLY PLANNED. BUT WE'RE YOU
KNOW, REMAINING OPEN TO A
VARIETY OF OPTIONS AND AGAIN, WE
REALLY WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
NOT PREMATURELY DECIDING WHICH
DIRECTION WE WILL OR WE WON'T GO
IN BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT THIS
TO BE DRIVEN BY THE FEEDBACK
THAT WILL BE GETTING AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. WOULD YOU
FEEL COMFORTABLE IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE BUSINESS
ANNOUNCED HAVE EXPERTISE IN
OTHER AREAS, NOT OUTSIDE OF D.
D. S. OVERSIGHT. WE SELECTED THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH THE INTENTION OF GETTING
DIVERSE VOICES WITH A WIDE RANGE
OF VIEWS AND EXPERTISE,
RECOGNIZING THAT EVEN WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS ROBUST AS THIS ONE,
IT'S 36 MEMBERS. THERE WILL BE
MORE PERSPECTIVES AND MORE WORK
THAT WE WILL NEED TO LOOK INTO.
AND SO IN ADDITION TO THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE MEETINGS,
WE WILL BE USING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES. WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT PUBLIC ROUNDTABLES.
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT FOCUS
GROUPS. I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
HAVE ALREADY REACHED OUT AND
SAID THEY WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
HELPING HOST SOME OF THE
ROUNDTABLES AND WHERE WE MAY
HAVE GAPS. WE WILL BE LOOKING TO
OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE AND TO
THE OTHER ENGAGEMENT TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE ARE THOSE GAPS? AND
WHERE IS THE EXPERTISE THAT CAN
HELP US FILL IT? CAN YOU CLARIFY
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU ARE
LOOKING TO HAVE BOARD GOALS, BUT
WITH MILESTONES IN A WAY TO
TRACK THAT, WERE YOU SPEAKING IN
RELATION TO WHAT IS GOING TO BE
INSIDE THE PLAN? WE CREATE THE
PLAN. AS A WAY TO ALSO TRACK
ARGOS WHILE WE ARE ACHIEVING THE
PLAN, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
POINT OF CLARIFICATION. THAT'S
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT WE EXPECT
WILL BE IN THE MASTER PLAN. WE
WANT THE MASTER PLAN TO NOT ONLY
SET THAT ASPIRATIONAL VISION FOR
THE FUTURE BUT ALSO IN BUILT
INTO THE MASTER PLAN. WHAT DOES
SUCCESS LOOK LIKE? WHAT DO THOSE
MILESTONES THOSE GOALS THAT WE
WILL ACHIEVE? AND HOW WILL WE
TRACK THAT? WE ARE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THEM. ARE WE GOING TO
REPLICATE THAT AS WE IMPLEMENT
THIS CREATING THIS PLAN OR HOW
ARE WE GOING TO BE TRACKING?
THAT WE DO HIT THAT MARCH,
POTENTIALLY MARCH DRAFT DATE.
WELL AGAIN. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
NIMBLENESS AND FLEXIBILITY. SO
SOME OF IT WILL BE ITERATIVE AS
WE GET FEEDBACK AND START
IDENTIFYING WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT WE'RE GOING TO WANT
TO FOCUS IN ON. BUT REGARDLESS
OF WHAT ENDS UP BEING BUILT INTO
THE PLAN IN TERMS OF PRIORITIES
AND GOALS, ONE OF THE INTENTIONS
FROM THE OUTSET WILL BE TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO EVALUATE
AND REEVALUATE THE PLAN AFTER IT
IS IMPLEMENTED. ID SO THAT WE
CAN SEE WHERE WE NEED TO PIVOT
RIGHT, RECOGNIZING THAT WHEN WE
DEVELOP A MULTI YEAR PLAN, YOU
KNOW THERE MAY BE CHANGES IN THE
ECONOMY AND TECHNOLOGY IN OUR
LANDSCAPE, AND WE WANT TO MAKE A
PLAN THAT IS BOTH RESILIENT AND
STANDS THE TEST OF TIME, BUT
THAT IS NIMBLE ENOUGH TO PIVOT
AS THE SORT OF REALITIES IN OUR
SOCIETY CHANGE. DO WE HAVE? DO
WE ANTICIPATE WHICH PROGRAMS IS
PLAN WILL IMPACT ARE WE LOOKING
TO ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE SERVICE
UNDER THAT COVERS HIS POPULATION
. SO I THINK FOR ME, THAT WILL
REALLY THAT WILL REALLY BE A
CORE PART OF THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH
THE PUBLIC AND WITH THE FOCUS
GROUPS, I, UM I HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
PRESUMPTUOUS AND I WANT TO
APPROACH THIS WITH HUMILITY,
RECOGNIZING THAT WHILE I MIGHT
HAVE TO HAVE SOME IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT WILL BE THE SYSTEMS OR OR
AREAS ARE PRIORITIES THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY TOP OF MIND. I REALLY
WANT THOSE VOICES OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO BE THE DRIVERS
BEHIND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
ANTICIPATE ANY FUNDING REQUESTS
TO ENSURE THAT THIS PLAN IS
IMPLEMENTED TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU WERE RIGHT NOW THE AREAS IN
WHICH WE'RE SEEKING, LIKE I
TALKED ABOUT PEER SUPPORTS AND
LOOKING AT BEING ABLE TO HAVE
SOMEONE THE CONSULTANTS THAT'S
HELPING ASSIST US. THE
DEPARTMENT HAD ALREADY STARTED A
STRATEGIC PLAN PROCESS AND SO
THE FUNDING THAT WE HAVE FROM
OTHER KIND OF MAJOR INITIATIVES
AND LOOKING AT SOME OF THE WORK
WE'RE DOING IS CURRENTLY FUNDING
THESE EFFORTS AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PROPOSALS FOR EXTENDING
THOSE REQUESTS. LITTLE DEVIL'S
ADVOCATE HERE DIRECTOR JUST
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD IT FROM THAT,
AT SOME ADVOCATES GIVEN THE
PROPOSED DELAYS IN THIS SECTION,
HOW DO WE FIND THIS TO BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO IF WE FOUND
SOME FUNDING FOR THIS? TO NOT
FUND THE THINGS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED FOR DELAY IN THIS
DEPARTMENT. SO WHEN, WHEN
ALIGNING THE STRATEGIC PLAN WORK
. UM WE'RE LOOKING I WAS GOING
TO WANTING TO DO STRATEGIC
PLANNING WORK BECAUSE THESE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT PRIORITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
ROADMAP TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING SOME OF THE DELAYS.
SO THIS IS THE WORK THAT I
REALLY BELIEVE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
CURRENTLY. AND SO BEING ABLE TO
MARRY THAT WITH A MASTER PLAN IS
REALLY WHERE WE IDENTIFIED THE
PRIORITIES. WE COULD ACHIEVE
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE PRIORITIES AND I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO, UM CFR COLLEAGUES AT
FINANCE HAVE ANYTHING ADDITIONAL
TO SAY, BUT THE PRIORITIES THAT
WE PUT FORWARD IS WHERE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON I GUESS
CONTINUING WITH MY DEVIL'S
ADVOCATE HERE PUSHING BACK A
LITTLE BIT, UM, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD THEN SAY THE DDS RATE
REFORM WAS A HUGE PRIORITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT, AND I'M
WONDERING HOW WE THEN SHIFT TO
THIS BEING THE NEW PRIORITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT. WELL WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT A LARGE
NUMBER OF DOLLARS FOR AN
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORT TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE KIND OF THE SUPPORT
FOR THIS EFFORT. UM THERE'S WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE PROPOSALS
FOR DELAY AND I'M NOT. I THINK
THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY AS WELL. SO I
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO AHEAD OF
THAT. BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE IDENTIFYING
THAT. WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT. AND THAT'S WHY
ABSORBABLE VERY EASILY
ABSORBABLE. IT'S WITHIN OUR
CURRENT AUTHORITY. IT'S NOT NEW
AUTHORITY AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I HAD ALREADY IDENTIFIED AS
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
OUR WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO. AND
THEN NOW SHARING THAT FOR MORE
OF A FORWARD THINKING ALONG WITH
THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
TODAY. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO OUR OUR SECOND
PANELIST FROM DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
HAVING MY BACK TO YOU. I'LL TRY
TO TURN A LITTLE BIT. MY NAME IS
JUDY MARK AND I AM A PARENT OF A
27 YEAR OLD SON, WHO SERVED BY A
REGIONAL CENTER WHO'S MOVING OUT
ON APRIL 20TH FROM OUR HOUSE.
AND SO THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND VERY EXCITING TIME FOR US.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT, CO
FOUNDER OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED. WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION
DIRECTED EXCLUSIVELY BY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. MADAM CHARGES
WANT TO SAY TO THE PANELISTS
YOUR EUROPE ON THE T V TWO, SO
YOU'RE OKAY. THANK YOU TALK HERE
ON TV, SO I CAN FEEL SO BAD IN
MY BACK TO YOU VERY DIRECTLY.
SORRY OKAY. UM OUR ORGANIZATION
IS EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WITH ITS PRIORITY OF
MAKING THE SYSTEM EQUITABLE,
ACCOUNTABLE AND PERSON CENTERED
WITH QUALITY OUTCOMES ARE
ORGANIZATIONS SHARES THESE GOALS
FOR THE SYSTEM AND HOPES THAT
THIS PROCESS WILL IMPROVE THE
SERVICES AND ULTIMATELY THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THE MASTER PLAN ON
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IS AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
IT'S SO RARE TO GET THE CHANCE
TO STEP BACK. THINK COLLECTIVELY
ABOUT WHETHER THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING AND HOW IT CAN BE
IMPROVED. FOR FAR TOO LONG. OUR
SYSTEM HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
COMPLIANCE RATHER THAN OUTCOMES
AND BUREAUCRACY RATHER THAN
FREEDOM AND INCLUSION IN
PREPARING MY TESTIMONY TODAY, I
ACTUALLY READ THROUGH THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING. AND WHICH IS A
MODEL FOR THE SEPARATE AS YOU
KNOW, AND AS PICTURE SAID IT
CONTAINS FIVE BOLD GOALS. AND
THAT INSPIRED ME TO THINK ABOUT
THE HOPES AND DREAMS I HAVE FOR
MY SON AND HIS FUTURE AND, UM,
AND THE SYSTEM THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO SUPPORT HIM FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE AND TO THINK ABOUT
THOSE BOLD GOALS FOR OUR SYSTEM.
AND SO I WAS BOLD AND I CAME UP
WITH SOME OF THOSE GOALS IN
ADVANCE. FOR TODAY. SO GOAL ONE
THAT I THINK IS A PRIORITY IS TO
RESTORE TRUST IN THE SYSTEM. WE
WILL EXPERIENCE A SYSTEM THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE
WHERE WE FEEL HEARD COMFORTABLE,
SAFE AND SUPPORT IT GOAL TO
EQUITY AND ACCESS TO SERVICES.
WE WILL RECEIVE SERVICES FROM
CULTURALLY HUMBLE AND RESPONSIVE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS WITHOUT INSTITUTIONAL
BIASES AND COMPLEX PROCESSES,
REGARDLESS OF OUR RACE,
ETHNICITY, LANGUAGE OR WHERE WE
LIVE. GOAL THREE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCLUSION,
GOOD HEALTH, EMPLOYMENT AND
SOCIAL LIVES. WE WILL GET THE
SUPPORTS. WE NEED TO HAVE HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FOR OUR LIVES AND
OUR HEALTH, ACTIVE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WORKPLACES
AND HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS. GO FOR
IS AGENCY OVER OUR LIVES. WE
WILL BE SELF DETERMINED FROM THE
EARLIEST AGE AND RECEIVED TO
SUPPORT AND RECEIVE SUPPORT TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW AND
WHERE WE LIVE AND WHO WORKS FOR
US. FINALLY GOAL FIVE, A SYSTEM
THAT CONFORMS TO US WE WILL BE
SUPPORTED BY AN AUTHENTIC,
PERSON CENTERED SYSTEM THAT
RESPECTS US AND ARGUED IT NEEDS
MORE THAN IT RESPECTS,
COMPLIANCE AND STANDARDS. BUT
THESE BOLD GOALS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
CANNOT BE ACHIEVED BY TINKERING
AROUND THE EDGES. IT REQUIRES A
FUNDAMENTAL REEXAMINATION OF THE
WAY THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
STRUCTURED. MASTER PLAN PROCESS
MUST ASK US TO REIMAGINE THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THE SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS IT US.
BUT IS THIS EVEN POSSIBLE? MANY
SELF ADVOCATES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN PART OF WORK
GROUPS AND TASK FORCES FOR YEARS
AND HAVEN'T SEEN MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENTS. I AM ALREADY
HEARING FROM COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THEY ARE EXPRESSING
SKEPTICISM OF THE MASTER PLAN.
THAT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US. WHY
WOULD THEY TRUST THE PROCESS
BEING SPONSORED BY THE SAME
SYSTEM? KEEPING WITH THIS BOLD
THEME. I AM HERE TO SAY THAT I
AM HEADING INTO THIS PROCESS
WITH ENTHUSIASM AND OPTIMISM. I
AM VERY ENCOURAGED BY WHAT WE
ARE HEARING. SO FAR, THE LEADERS
OF THE PROCESS ARE ALREADY
REACHING OUT TO THE COMMUNITY TO
BUILD TRUST. THEY'RE OFFERING TO
HOLD SESSIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
TO MEET US WHERE WE ARE IN THE
LANGUAGES. WE SPEAK AND TO
LISTEN EVEN IF WE COMMUNICATE
WITHOUT SPEAKING MY ENTHUSIASM
IS ONLY TEMPERED BY THE PROCESS
BEING CONDUCTED IN THE MIDDLE OF
A BUDGET CRISIS. WE CAN'T LET
OUR VISIONS OF THE LONG TERM
FUTURE BECAUSE STRAINED BY THE
IMMEDIATE ISSUES, BUT WE CAN
LEARN FROM THESE TIMES THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON THE SERVICES PEOPLE NEED AND
THE STAFF THAT DIRECTLY SUPPORT
US NOT IN THE BUREAUCRACY THAT
SURROUNDS THAT. ULTIMATELY
REGARDLESS OF THE ECONOMIC
CLIMATE, IF THE RESULT OF THE
MASTER PLAN IS THAT THE LANTERN
TAX BILL OF RIGHTS ARE FULLY
REALIZED, WHICH MANY PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW, BUT IT STATES WHERE
PERSONS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES HAVE THE SAME LEGAL
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES
GUARANTEED ALL OTHER INDIVIDUALS
BY THE CONSTITUTIONS OF THE
UNITED STATES AND CALIFORNIA.
WELL, THAT WOULD BE PRETTY BOLD.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH WITH EVERYONE HERE AND GET
STARTED WITH THE MASTER PLAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
ENERGY. APPRECIATE IT. MOVING ON
TO OUR THIRD PANEL PANELIST FROM
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. IT WAS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MEGAN LUEGO AND I AM A
SELF ADD WORKER AND I AM ALSO
MANAGER BUT COMMUNITY IN
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS PREVENT
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. I AM ENCOURAGED
BY THE POTENTIAL FOR MY MASTER
PLAN CRUCIATE, THE DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES SYSTEM, WHICH
CURRENTLY FAILS TO MANY
INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY PEOPLE.
HOWEVER I AM DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LACK OF DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE MASHUP PLANNING
COMMITTEE. DID THE LATINO SELF
ADVOCATE. I FEEL UNDER RUBBERS,
AND THERE'S ONLY ONE LATINO
MEMBER ON THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT LATINOS
MAKE UP THE LEGS, GIST GROUP
SHOWED BY REGIONAL CENTERS.
APPROXIMATELY 42. WHILE THE
LEADERS OF THE MASTER PLAN
PROCESS HAVE PLEDGED TO ENGAGE
PEOPLE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. THE
COMPOSITION OF A COMMITTEE
MATTER. CURRENTLY ONLY 17% OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE LATINOS,
AND MANY OF THEM ARE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD
RATHER THAN IN THE VIGILS
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY JUST
ABILITIES. PAGE. INTONATION IS
SCHOOLS. IT IS VITAL THAT THE
LEADERS OF THE MASSIVE PLAN DO
NOT TALKING. THAT'S SO BAD
ADVOCATES ON THE COMMUNITY
HISTORICALLY, VISUALS WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE BEEN MERGING
ALLIES OR DISREGARDED IN SEARCH
FOR YOU ASKED ME YOU ASKED FOR
MAY INPUT ONWARD, THE MASTER
PLAN SHOULD PRIORITIZE AND WE'RE
ASPECTS OF THE SYSTEM NEEDS
FIXING. WHAT BALLISTIC IS
EXTENSIVE, WILL HIGHLIGHT A FEW
KEY POINTS. BRUCE THE MASSIVE
PLAN MUST PRIORITIZE REBUILDING
TRUST AND REGIONAL CENTERED AND
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE. MANY OF
US HAVE FACED REJECTION OR
EXCLUSION FOR YEARS, MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO ENACT MEANINGFUL
CHANGE WITHOUT ADDRESSING THIS
PRESS ISSUES. SECONDLY, THERE IS
A CRITICAL FOR IMPROVED
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATION
SHARING WITH INDIVIDUAL OF THEM
FAMILIES. TO OFTEN FAMILIES OR
UNAWARE OF THE VALUABLES
SERVICES, LEAVING INDIVIDUALS
BUT DON'T NECESSARILY SUPPORT 30
LEÓN SHOULD PLAN SHOULD AGGRESS
THE PREVENTIVE FOCUS ON FITS IT.
DEFICIT TO WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD NOT FEEL
COMPELLED TO VILIFY THEMSELVES
TO ACCESS SERVICES AS I HAVE
OFTEN DONE MYSELF. THERE'S
PREPARED FOR ITS STIGMA
SURROUNDING DISABILITIES. MORE
CULTURAL HUMILITY MUST BE
INTEGRATED INTO A SYSTEM UNLIKE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY, WHICH
GENERAL ALEXIS EXPERIENCES BASED
ON RACE OR MESSAGES, CULTURAL
HUMILITY. KNOWLEDGE IS THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE EXPERTS ON
THEIR OWN LIVES. ADDITIONALLY
PERSON CENTERED, I'D BECOME A
BUDGET WORDS. IT'S
IMPLEMENTATION REMAINS LIKE IT
LACKING COOL POTION. CENTENE IS
MEANS OFFERING A RANGE OF
SERVICES PROVIDERS AND
RESPECTING INDIVIDUALS. CURSES
INCLUDING PARTICIPATION HIM
PROGRAMS LIKE THE SELF DID COME
IN NATION PROGRAM. LASTLY IN
DIVISION IN AND I DO SYSTEM.
PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE UNTIL
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO ACCEPT
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. IT'S MY
ROOM POWERS INDIVIDUALS TO LEAD
DIRECTED LIVES. THREE FROM THE
STRANGE OF INSTITUTIONAL CONTROL
IN CONCLUSION MATTER PLAN
PRESENTING UPPER TO NITTY FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE, BUT BUT
IT MUST PAY AUTHORITIES. TÌM
CITY, CHRIS BUILDING EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION, CULTURE,
HUMIDITY. AND GENUINE PERSONS
AND REDNESS TO TRULY ALL ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
IN TUNE TO SHARE MY REACTION,
DID HE THANK YOU, MR. LOOK, I
APPRECIATE THAT QUICKLY, VICTOR.
MAYBE I'M JUST ASSUMING I WAS
LOOKING AT THE LIST OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. I GUESS I DON'T
WANT TO ASSUME BASED ON THE LAST
NAME, DO WE HAVE A DEMOGRAPHIC
BREAKDOWN? THERE WE GO, NANCY
BARGMANN, SO WE DO HAVE A
DEMOGRAPHIC BREAKDOWN. HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT TO YOU? UM AND ALSO
REPRESENTATION FROM SELF
ADVOCATES. SO I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT, UM, WHILE ATTEMPTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
REPRESENTING THE DIVERSITY OF
THE ENTIRE KIND OF POPULATION IT
WAS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE, YOU
KNOW, MAKING SURE THAT
REPRESENTATION ALSO INCLUDED
SOME POPULATIONS THAT ARE VERY
SMALL IN THE PERCENTAGE OF
REPRESENTATION, AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S SO CRITICAL. THE FOCUS
GROUPS AND THE ROUNDTABLES AND
GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES, BUT I
THINK THAT THE VOICE THAT YOU
SHARED IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE TO MAKE SURE THOSE
VOICES ARE LIFTED. DIRECTOR IS A
CORRECTED AND THERE IS ONLY ONE
LATINO INDIVIDUAL BELIEVE THAT'S
REFERRING TO A SELF ADVOCATE.
AND SO OF THE SELF ADVOCATES. I
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS CORRECT.
OKAY IS THIS A SENTENCE? STONE I
KNOW. WE ANNOUNCED. IT'S ALREADY
IT'S ALREADY A BIG GROUP IS THE
GROUP THAT WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD. OFFICIALLY IT IS THE
GROUP THAT'S MOVING FORWARD, BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
LISTEN TO BECAUSE I'VE HEARD
FROM OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT FEEL
THAT THAT'S NOT BEEN REPRESENTED
BASED ON GEOGRAPHICS, BASED ON
OTHER AREAS, AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT. UM
IF IT'S NOT WITHIN THE COMMITTEE
ITSELF. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
NOBODY HAS BEEN LEFT BEHIND? WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THOSE
VOICES ARE HEARD, AND IT HAS TO
BE DONE IN A VERY MEANINGFUL AND
PURPOSEFUL WAY. HELPFUL. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST
FROM SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER.
TÌM. THERE WE GO. NOW IT'S ON
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF. MY
NAME IS MARK KLAUS. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER. SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTER SERVES TWO
COUNTIES. WE SERVED SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT JUST SHY OF 42,000
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN OUR CATCHMENT AREA. UM I'M
HONORED AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING AS A MEMBER OF THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE. I SEE
THIS AS AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
TO BE FORWARD THINKING. AND
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMS AND SUPPORTS
THAT IT'S CHANGING IN OUR SYSTEM
AND CHANGING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
A DAILY BASIS. SOME SAY BY THE
MINUTE, NOT JUST THE DAY, UM,
BUT TO DEVELOP A SYSTEM THAT IS
PERSON CENTERED, EQUITY FOCUSED,
DATA DRIVEN. AND THAT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
RECEIVING SERVICES. THE MASTER
PLAN, IN MY OPINION, SHOULD SEEK
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION OR THE
QUESTIONS. TO WHAT OUR
COLLECTIVE VISION FOR THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA DDS, I'D SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE AND
WORKING TOGETHER IS JUDY
MENTIONED. YOU KNOW, THIS IS
WORKING WITH ARE VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY, SELF ADVOCATES,
FAMILIES, COMMUNITY AND ALL OF
OUR STAKEHOLDERS. I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
FAMILIES, INDIVIDUALS EVERY DAY
ABOUT THE GREAT THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING, UM AND THERE ARE
GREAT THINGS HAPPENING IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY.
BUT WE CAN DO BETTER, AND WE
NEED TO DO BETTER. IN BETTER IS
COMMUNITY INCLUSION, YOU KNOW,
SUPPORTING INCLUSION AND ACTIVE
PARTICIPATION IS SOMETHING THAT
THE COMMITTEE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT EQUITY, ENSURING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO EVERYBODY.
WHEN I LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
FOR SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER,
WE HAVE 73% OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE SUPPORT OUR NON WHITE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING UNDER HAVE
A HEARING LOSS 73% OF THE
ROUGHLY 42,000 INDIVIDUALS SO
WHAT IS THAT EQUITY LOOK LIKE
THERE'S ACCESS CHOICE OF
PROVIDERS. CHOICE OF QUALITY
SERVICES. UM, ARE NEEDED. IT'S
EASIER TO FIND A OPTIONS IF
YOU'RE IN THE GREATER SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY, BUT IF YOU'RE IN
WINTER HAVEN, WHICH BORDERS THE
ARIZONA BORDER? UM HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT SERVICES ARE OFFERED
TO THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE AND RESIDENTS OF THAT
COMMUNITY? CONSISTENCY. UM THERE
HAS TO BE GREATER CONSISTENCY
AMONGST REGIONAL CENTERS. HOW WE
PROVIDE SERVICES. HOW WE ACCESS
SERVICES, HOW WE'RE OPEN TO OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES. I
HAVE HAD THE HONOR OF BEING THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ABOUT 2.5
YEARS. UM AND WHAT I HEARD FROM
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS, AND I STILL
HEAR FROM MANY FAMILY MEMBERS.
YOU'RE THE BEST AT SECRET IN
TOWN. WE SHOULDN'T BE THE BEST
KEPT SECRET IN TOWN. WE SHOULD
BE CONTINUING OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I ALSO WOULD SEE
THE BETTER IN TERMS OF THE
MASTER PLAN AS BEING ACTIONABLE.
A LIVING DOCUMENT THAT IS NOT
JUST DEVELOPED AND PUT ON A
SHELF, BUT SOMETHING THAT IS
REVIEWED. ON A REGULAR AND
ONGOING BASIS TO ADAPT TO THE
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING. 2024
YOU KNOW, WE'RE SITTING HERE IN
MARCH OF 2024 LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN MARCH OF 2020. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT 2026 IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE, UM BUT WE HAVE TO BE
FORWARD THINKING, LOOK AT THOSE
ACTIONABLE ITEMS AND THEN
FINALLY, SENATOR FIRMANDO
ARGUMENTS AND, YOU KNOW, A
CABINET WORKING GROUP. I REALLY
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
POLL ALL AGENCIES AND SYSTEMS
THAT SERVE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TOGETHER. TO IMPROVE
THOSE SERVICES AND IN TO IMPROVE
THOSE COMMUNICATIONS. THE SYSTEM
IN WHICH WE OPERATE SYSTEMS THAT
FAMILIES TRY TO NAVIGATE. UH CAN
BE WELL, ACTUALLY, IT IS
DIFFICULT AND CONFUSING. UM SO I
THINK WE HAVE SO MANY PLAYERS,
INCLUDING REGIONAL CENTERS. WE
HAVE SCHOOLS WE HAVE HSS. WE
HAVE HOUSING. WE HAVE EMPLOYMENT
AND WHAT WE HEAR FROM MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS IS OH,
THERE ARE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENT. THEY'RE YOURS. AND
THAT'S NOT THE BEST COORDINATION
OF SERVICES IN THAT THAT
COORDINATION OF MANY TIMES MOST
OF THE TIMES FALLS AS A BURDEN
TO FAMILIES. SO REALLY GETTING
EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. HOW THAT WORKS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
CRITICAL. UM AS I SAID, YOU
KNOW, WE HEAR THEY'RE YOURS. NO
THEY'RE OURS. WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND HOW WE CAN WORK
BETTER TOGETHER. I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF GREAT EXAMPLES THAT
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN SAN
DIEGO, UM IN DIFFERENT
WORKGROUPS AND MEET FOR REACHING
OUT TO OUR COUNTY COUNTY
PARTNERS. BUT IT STARTS TO TOP
IT STARTS IT, YOU KNOW THE STATE
LEVEL IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS, UM HOW DO WE BECOME
MORE EFFECTIVE? HOW DO WE BECOME
MORE EFFICIENT? HOW DO WE CAN
BECOME MORE USER FRIENDLY? WE'LL
HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS, SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TODAY. AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH VICTOR FIRST
MEETING ON APRIL 10TH. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH DIRECT
DIRECTORS. I WANT TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON THAT, ACTUALLY, BECAUSE I
THINK YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE HEAR BACK IS
THAT THESE AREAS WORK IN SILOS,
AND I THINK YOU HIT A RUN ON THE
NAIL THAT. OH WELL, THEY'RE IN
THE SCHOOL AGE NOW, SO SCHOOLS
ARE SCHOOLS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT. SO IF WE COULD CONTINUE
LOOKING AT HOW WE REPLICATE WHAT
WE DID FOR THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING THAT WORKED. IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL PLAN, RIGHT? I THINK
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT THAT WE
INCLUDE ALL THE DEPARTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE EVERY SERVICE THAT
THIS INDIVIDUAL TOUCHES OR
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING, UM
SMOOTHLY TOGETHER. SENATOR
EDMUND DIRECTOR MARGARINE, SO
I'M JUST SO FAR FROM WHAT WE'VE
HEARD, RIGHT IS THERE THERE IS
HISTORY, RIGHT PEOPLE NOT
FEELING HEARD OF NOT FEELING
SERVED, IF YOU WILL, UNTIL WE'VE
ALREADY BEGUN TO HEAR THAT IN
THE ISSUE OF SILOS AND THEN
GOING BACK TO THE LAST TOPIC WE
COVERED WHEN FOLKS ARE GETTING
IN LINE, AND SO THEN WE START
WITH A SERIES OF, UM REPRIMANDS
OR CONSEQUENCES. HOW I MEAN, HOW
DO YOU DO THOSE THINGS TOGETHER,
RIGHT? I MEAN, YOU ARE DEPENDENT
UPON MULTIPLE SERVICES THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
DIRECT CONTROL OVER WITH A
POPULATION THAT HAS OFTEN BEEN
OVERLOOKED, AND UNLESS THEY HAVE
PARENTS IN REAL ADVOCATES UM,
OFTENTIMES, YOU KNOW, GET LEFT
BEHIND. EVERYONE CAN SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES AS WELL AS OUR
PANELISTS TODAY. SO HOW DO YOU
DO THOSE TWO THINGS AT THE SAME
TIME I TRY TO BRING EVERYBODY ON
BUT TRY TO MAKE EVERYBODY FEEL
HEARD AT THE SAME TIME. IT SEEMS
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX. AND WHAT ARE
YOUR STRATEGIES FOR MAKING SURE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THIS? VICTOR NO,
NO, IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE, BUT
I'D LIKE TO ALSO HAVE VICTOR
HAVE A MOMENT TO SAY. I THINK
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION. WHEN WE YOU KNOW, I
HAVE I HAVE HEARD FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. WAY TOO MANY TIMES
ABOUT HOW HARD IT IS TO NAVIGATE
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS. YOU KNOW, IT'S
YOU KNOW, I'VE I'VE SAID, YOU
KNOW WHEN I AM WORKING WITH
FAMILIES AND LISTENING TO
FAMILIES, AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
HOW FAMILIES ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE HAVING TO NAVIGATE KIND OF
THESE COMPLEX SYSTEMS. IT'S
DIFFICULT SO HOW DO WE THEN
BRING THROUGH THIS MASTER PLAN,
WORK OF THE SILOS AND CONNECTING
THOSE DOTS. UM, THAT'S THE
BEAUTY OF IT BEING HOUSED AT
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AND WE HAVE A
SECRETARY THAT HAS JUST REALLY
DOUBLED DOWN ON BREAKING DOWN
SILOS, AND THAT'S THE WORK WE DO
WITH OUR SISTER DEPARTMENTS. YOU
KNOW, WE ALREADY HAVE A NUMBER
OF INITIATIVES THAT ARE REALLY
INCREDIBLE EXAMPLES. UM A
LOOKING AT THE 2083 WORKS SYSTEM
OF CARE WORK FOR CHILDREN WITH
IN FOSTER CARE, LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS THAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING
CONNECTIONS AND SERVICES IN IN
IN IN THE WORK, WE WORK
INCREDIBLY CLOSE WITH DEPARTMENT
OF REHAB ON MAKING SURE WE'RE
LOOKING IN ADVANCING EMPLOYMENT,
SO WE KNOW THAT THERE IS STILL
WORK TO BE DONE. AND THAT'S THE
BEAUTY OF HAVING THIS MASTER
PLAN AND BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT
HOW DO WE COLLABORATE AND NOT
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WITH I'D BE
LEFT BEHIND. SO HOW DO WE, YOU
KNOW, BUILD ON THOSE INCREDIBLE
EFFORTS FROM OTHER SYSTEMS AND
KIND OF BRING THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER. THAT'S THE WORK THAT
THE MASTER PLAN HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO AND SEE IF
VICTOR HAS ANYTHING MORE THAT HE
CAN ADD TO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO I THINK TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, IT STARTS WITH
BEGINNING FROM A PLACE OF
HUMILITY. RIGHT SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE EVERYONE
AT THE TABLE TO FIGURE OUT THE
ANSWER AS WELL? BEGINS BY
RECOGNIZING THAT NOT ONLY DO WE
NOT HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS, WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ALL THE
QUESTIONS YET RIGHT AND SO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
ROBUST PROCESS THAT NOT ONLY
INCLUDES THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE, BUT AS I SHARED, WE
WILL BE LOOKING AT A WIDE
VARIETY OF ROUNDTABLES TO ENGAGE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC RANGE OF FOCUS
GROUPS. I HAVE A RUNNING LIST OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THAT WE
WANT TO INVITE TWO DIFFERENT
FOCUS GROUPS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE SPACES ARE HELD AND
FACILITATED IN A WAY THAT IS
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE,
LINGUISTICALLY ACCESSIBLE AND
THROUGH THEIR LIFTING UP THOSE
VOICES, THOSE ISSUES THAT MAY
NOT EVEN BE ON OUR RADAR. I'VE
WORKED IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS AND BOTH IN AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE AND HAVING
BEGUN MY CAREER AS A FRONTLINE
SERVICE DELIVERY STAFF, AND WHAT
I OFTEN FIND IS THAT REGARDLESS
OF WHICH SYSTEM YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES, EMPLOYMENT SERVICES,
HOUSING NUTRITION WHEN YOU ARE
SOMEBODY WHO DOES DIRECT
SERVICES AND AN INDIVIDUAL COMES
TO YOU WANT TO SOLVE THE WHOLE
CONSTELLATION OF ISSUES THAT
THAT PERSON HAS BECAUSE THEY
COME WITH THEIR WHOLE SELVES.
THEY DON'T LEAVE THE PARTS OF
THEIR IDENTITY THAT AREN'T
RELEVANT TO YOUR PROGRAM AT THE
DOOR. AND OFTENTIMES THAT'S
WHERE THAT FEELING OF STRAIN.
GOSH, THIS SYSTEM JUST DOESN'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING. AND SO THE BEAUTY OF
A MASTER PLAN IS THAT IT HELPS
BRIDGE THOSE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
AND HELP PEOPLE SAY IT'S NOT
ABOUT YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
BURDEN OTHER SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO LIFT THE
BURDEN BY SAYING NO ONE SYSTEM
HAS TO SOLVE IT ALONE, RIGHT?
HOW DO I IDENTIFY THOSE BEST
KEPT SECRETS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEST KEPT SECRET SO
THAT YOU KNOW THAT FRONT LINE
SERVICE DELIVERY STAFF IS
WORKING ACROSS SYSTEMS AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WHEN SOMEBODY
COMES TO THEM, AND THEY'RE WELL
POSITIONED TO ADDRESS THEIR
EMPLOYMENT NEEDS, BUT THEY SEE
THIS PERSON HAS HOUSING NEEDS
HEALTH NEEDS RECREATION NEEDS.
THERE IS THAT ALIGNMENT ACROSS
SYSTEMS THAT SUPPORTS THAT
SEAMLESS WHOLE PERSON APPROACH.
MR MARK, IF I COULD ASK YOU WHEN
YOU REFER TO THE SYSTEM ALLOWS
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE SYSTEM.
WHAT SYSTEM? ARE YOU TALKING TO?
YOU TALKING ABOUT THE WHOLE LIKE
EVERYBODY YOU INTERACT WITH ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT WHICH
SYSTEM IN THE SYSTEM. IN THIS
CONTEXT, TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM,
WHICH STARTS WITH DDS MOVES TO
THE 21 REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEN
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS. THEY ARE
THE SYSTEM TO US. WE ARE THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND THE
SYSTEM IS WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE SUPPORTING US. OKAY AND WHEN
YOU WENT THROUGH YOUR LIST OF IF
YOU IF YOU HAD A MAGIC WAND,
RIGHT HOW YOU WOULD DO THAT? SO
I WANT TO ASK. YOU DID HAVE THAT
MAGIC ONE YOU WOKE UP TOMORROW
AND THAT WAS REALIZED. HOW WOULD
YOU KNOW? REALLY GREAT QUESTION.
UM, YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL WE
PARENTS WOULD WAKE UP A LOT LESS
STRESSED OUT. WE OUR LIVES WOULD
BE JOYOUS AND OUR LIVES WOULD BE
SO HAPPY FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
WHAT THEY ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE IN
THEIR LIVES AND HAPPINESS IS
COMPLETELY UNDERRATED. IN THIS
WORLD. WE WE'VE GOT TO BE HAPPY
AND ARE KIDS. MY HAPPINESS IS
BASED ON WHETHER MY KIDS ARE
HAPPY. AND SO, UM, THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD BE HOW I WAKE UP IN
THE MORNING FOR SURE. THANK YOU.
VICTOR I THINK WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF THE QUESTIONS. I THINK WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS IN
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS. I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS PLAN BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS. I'M ALWAYS I'M
ACTUALLY I'M NOT A FAN OF ANY
MORE STUDY ON ANYTHING, AND WE
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION WE
NEED. NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
ACTION PART. YOU KNOW, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS INVESTING NOT IN COMING
UP WITH MORE QUESTIONS. IT'S
LIKE TO INVEST IN ANSWERS. OF
THE HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
QUESTIONS WE HAVE IN THIS SPACE
AND EVERY OTHER SPACE. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT AND THEN, DIRECTOR
I KNOW WE WORKED GREAT WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENTS WITHIN I
JUDGE H. H S, UM, INCLUDING HHS.
UM, BUT I THINK THE EDUCATION
PART IS THE BIG PART. I MEAN, I
THINK THAT'S JUST A ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THORN FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
OR OR ITSELF INDIVIDUALS AS WELL
. SO I THINK THAT SUPPORT THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALSO
GETS INCLUDED. IN THIS AS WELL.
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT? WE AGREE AND I JUST WILL
FLAG THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
FAIRLY CLOSELY, ESPECIALLY WITH
EARLY CHILDHOOD EFFORTS WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN SPECIAL ED AT C D. E
AND THESE ARE REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLES AND CONNECTIONS THAT
HAVE ALREADY STARTED BECAUSE IF
YOU RECALL SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS RECENTLY IS IDEA
SPECIALIST AT DDS AND THEN
INVESTMENTS AT EACH OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEN
WORKING WITH CD ON KIND OF THOSE
TRANSITIONS AND COLLABORATIVE.
SO ALSO CDS, PART OF THE 2083
WORK. BUT I THINK IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT AREA TO LIFT UP
BECAUSE IT'S TALKING ABOUT WHAT
ARE THOSE OTHER SYSTEMS WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE TOUCHING AND
CERTAINLY FOR A VERY LARGE
PORTION OF THEIR LIFE, YOU KNOW,
EDUCATION IS REALLY CRITICAL,
AND SO BUT IF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING THAT
DOOR OPEN FOR ALL THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE MASTER
PLAN. I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
QUESTION, EITHER YOU MARK OR
DIRECTOR CAN ANSWER ABOUT WHY
ONLY 21 REGIONAL CENTERS 42,000
PEOPLE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE. WHAT
I MEAN, WHO'S RESPONSIBLE IN UH,
LUCKY NUMBER THEY'RE LUCKY
NUMBER 21 LIKE WHY 21? WELL
ANOTHER HISTORIANS PROBABLY
GOING TO CORRECT ME, SO DON'T
DON'T WRITE THIS DOWN, BUT THE
LEGEND WOULD HAVE IT. UM IS THAT
THE 21 REGIONAL CENTERS GOING
BACK TO 1969. AND WHEN UPDATED
THE LANDERMAN ACT YOU KNOW IN
LOOKING AT BECAUSE IT STARTED
WITH A PILOT OF A COUPLE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS. AND THEN THERE
WAS A LOOK OF HOW DO WE HAVE
WITH THE CONCEPT OF COMMUNITY
KIND OF COMMUNITY, LOCAL BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND IT
WAS REALLY ESTABLISHED IN A
POPULATION COMMUNITY POPULATION
OF A MILLION, AND SO YOU HAVE 21
REGIONAL CENTERS. OUR COMMUNITY
POPULATIONS HAVE EVOLVED AND
CHANGE COULD SEE WHERE INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER NORTH REGIONAL
CENTER, OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE GROWN. THE FIRE DEPARTMENT.
THEY DO THESE STUDIES LOOK AT
THE FIRE STATIONS. AND THEY SAY,
HEY, THAT FIRE STATION IS DOING
A LOT OF CALLS. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR ANOTHER FIRE STATION IN
THAT SAME AREA. WHY DON'T WE
APPROACH THAT THE SAME WAY FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS? WELL, I THINK
THROUGH THE YEARS, YOU KNOW, THE
LETTERMAN ACT HAS BEEN KIND OF A
PILLAR TO HOW DO WE DELIVER
SERVICES AND ONE OF THE AREAS
WAS ESTABLISHING THE 21 REGIONAL
CENTERS FOR DECADES, I WOULD
SAY, AND THIS IS WHAT THAT DOOR
IS OPEN, YOU KNOW? CONVERSATIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE BROUGHT UP
FROM THE COMMITTEE TO WHAT MAKES
SENSE OF DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SUGGESTING I'M
NOT TAKING A POSITION WHETHER
IT'S RIGHT OR WRONG, BUT I THINK
THIS GIVES THAT SPACE FOR THAT
CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN OF, YOU
KNOW, HOW ARE WE DELIVERING IT?
YOU KNOW, COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
ASK A QUESTION LIKE YOU JUST
ASKED. WELL, WHY, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T HURT TO ASK
THE QUESTION. WHY IS X? YEAH,
OKAY. THANK YOU. UM MOVING ON TO
OUR NEXT PANELIST FROM
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS MARK MALLINSON, CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK. CCL N. A STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION AGENCIES
LARGE AND SMALL OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. UM ALSO HONORED TO
BE APPOINTED TO THE MASTER PLAN
STAKEHOLDER GROUP AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO THOSE MEETINGS
HAPPENING, EXCITED THAT THE
FIRST ROUND TABLE THAT WILL BE
CONDUCTING AS PART OF THEIR
COMMUNITY OUTREACH IS GOING TO
BE AT OUR CCN ANNUAL CONFERENCE
IN APRIL. I WOULD CONSIDER THIS
THE FIRST ROUND TABLE. SECOND
YAHOO! IN SAN DIEGO. THIS TYPE
OF LONG TERM SYSTEMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF QUALITY COMMUNITY
LIVING SERVICES PLANNING HAS
BEEN MISSING FROM THE
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
EXPERIENCE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN THE MASTER
PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
WAS FIRST ANNOUNCED, OUR
ATTENTION WAS IMMEDIATELY DRAWN
TO THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING,
MUCH LIKE JUDY, AND WHAT WE SAW
WAS HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY. I HOPE
THAT THE PLAN FOR THE FOR OUR
FUTURE SYSTEM CAN BE KANSEN
COMPREHENSIVE AND CAN BE ALL
INCLUSIVE PLAN THAT TOUCHES ON
ALL ASPECTS AND A FULL LIFE OF A
PERSON WITH AN INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ONE PLAN.
ONE PLAN THAT COULD INCLUDE THE
CRITICAL ISSUES OF TODAY AND
TOMORROW THAT OUR COMMUNITY
FACES HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
NEEDS. UH UH, BENEFITS, INCOME
AND POVERTY. HEALTHCARE
DISPARITIES AND DISCRIMINATION
AND HEALTH AND ACCESSING CARE.
WORKFORCE ISSUES, TRANSPORTATION
, INCLUSION AND EQUITY COMMUNITY
ACCESS AND INTEGRATION,
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS,
EMPLOYMENT AND VOLUNTEERISM.
PROTECTION FROM ABUSE, NEGLECT
AND EXPLOITATION, ENABLING AND
ASSISTING TECHNOLOGIES AND
POSSIBLY MORE. WOW SIGN US UP.
THIS MASTER PLAN MUST INCLUDE
INTER AGENCY REPRESENTATIVES,
COMMITMENT AND SUPPORT FOR THIS
EFFORT TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
RESULT IN A SYSTEM THAT MEETS
THE WHOLE PERSON NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH I D. D. IN
PREPARING FOR TODAY, I LEARNED
THAT THERE ARE 233 STATE
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA SO NOT
ALL OF THEM, BUT THE ONES THAT
INTIMATELY INTERACT AND
POTENTIALLY TOUCHED THE LIVES OF
ALL THE PEOPLE WITHIN THIS
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE INVITED TO
BE AT THAT TABLE AND ALL IN
APPROACH. MOST IMPORTANTLY,
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILY ADVOCATES
FROM THE SIDE COMMUNITY MUST
HAVE THE LOUDEST VOICE AT THE
TABLE AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN. WHILE PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE. THERE'S MUCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE. THIS PLANNING
MUST ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY PEOPLE. IN BREAKING
DOWN THE SILOS AND THE
DISPARITIES AND SERVICE EQUITY
AND ACCESS THAT CURRENTLY EXIST.
AND OUR SYSTEM, LIKE OTHERS
STRUGGLE WITH THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY PEOPLE WHEN ACCESSING
GENERIC RESOURCES AND OTHER
SERVICES, SERVICE PROVIDER RATES
AND PROVIDER CAPACITY. THE
RAPIDLY GROWING AND POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC DIRECT SORT, DIRECT
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. MEASURING
THE MEANINGFUL OUTCOMES THAT
MATTER, MOST TO PEOPLE RECEIVING
SERVICES, ENSURING COMPLIANCE
WITH HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES, SERVICES, SETTINGS,
RULES AND REQUIREMENTS, ENSURING
SERVICES ARE TRUE TO THE CENTER
FOR MEDICAID. CMS WAIVER
FEDERALLY APPROVED GUIDELINES
ALL TOPICS THAT THE MASTER PLAN
MUST CONFRONT HEAD ON. TO
DISCUSS THE WORK THROUGH TO
IDENTIFY. TO DISCUSS TO DISCUSS
AND WORK THROUGH AND IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES FOR IMPLEMENTING
SOLUTIONS AND THE MASTER PLAN.
STAKEHOLDER GROUP HAS TO BE A
SAFE PLACE FOR THESE ARE OPEN
AND HONEST DISCUSSIONS THAT C C
L N IS LEADING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ON THE
SERVICE QUALITY OUTCOMES PROJECT
PAVE PERSON CENTERED ADVOCACY,
VISION AND EDUCATION. AND THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
UNIVERSITY DSP YOU TRAINING IS
THE INVALUABLE WORK HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW THAT CAN HELP INFORM
THE WORK AHEAD IN THE MASTER
PLAN. THE DEPARTMENT'S CURRENT
WORK AND THE INITIATIVES ALREADY
UNDERWAY. THE FOUNDATION TO
BUILD UPON IN THE MASTER PLAN,
ENSURING THAT PERSON CENTERED
AND WHOLE PERSON APPROACHES ARE
THERE WHILE THIS PLAN IS NEEDED
IMMEDIATELY, ITS CONSTRUCTION
SHOULD NOT BE RUSHED. AND THE
OVERALL FISCAL NEEDS OF THE
SYSTEM. SUSTAINABILITY MUST BE
ACKNOWLEDGED. CLN LOOKS FORWARD
TO THE CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION, THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY ON THIS CRITICAL
INITIATIVE AND TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES COMMITTEE
AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S SAY OTHER PANELISTS HAVE
STAYED WITHIN THEIR TIME FRAMES
REALLY GOOD, LIKE THE FIRST TIME
EVER WELL, SO NO PRESSURE THAT
CLOSES OFF HERE, UH, HAVE BEFORE
WE TURN IT TURN OVER TO L A OR
FINAL PANELISTS FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERIFF AND
MEMBERS COMMON ATTORNEY WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA
AND MY NAME IS WILLIAM LINER AND
I'M ALSO AS SIBLING. I HAVE A
BROTHER WHO SERVED BY OUR SYSTEM
, AND THESE ARE THE PROFESSIONAL
AND PERSONAL LENSES THAT SHAPE
HOW I APPROACH THIS WORK. I'M
HONORED TO TALK ABOUT OUR VISION
FOR THE MASTER PLAN. AND I KNOW
THERE'S SKEPTICISM OUT THERE. I
KNOW THERE IS, UM, BUT I WOULD
NOT HAVE AGREED TO BE PART OF
THIS PROCESS. IF I LIKE OTHERS
AROUND THIS TABLE DIDN'T HAVE
HOPE. DIDN'T HAVE HOPE THAT THIS
PROCESS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BETTER THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
OBSERVED BY OUR SYSTEM, AND I
HAVE FOUR POINTS TO MAKE THAT I
HOPE WILL DO JUST THAT. FIRST WE
SHARE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES VISION FOR A TD
SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT OPERATE IN
SILOS AND FOR A MASTER PLAN THAT
BUILDS BRIDGES FROM THE TT
SYSTEM TO THOSE SYSTEMS AROUND
IT. IT'S A REALLY GOOD VISION,
BUT IT CAN'T BE REALIZED TODAY
WHILE OUR CURRENT STRUCTURES ARE
STILL PREMISED ON THIS BRIEF ON
THIS ISLAND'S MENTALITY THAT
SILO OWING IS SOMEHOW NECESSARY
TO COMPLY WITH WHAT WE SEE AS
PAYER OF LAST RESORT RULES,
THEIR RULES WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE IN PRACTICE, PEOPLE ARE
TOLD THAT THEY NEED TO CHASE
DOWN SERVICES FROM OTHER
AGENCIES BEFORE REGIONAL CENTER
WILL STEP IN AND HELP. IT'S LIKE
INSTEAD OF BUILDING BRIDGES WERE
POINTING PEOPLE TO DISTANT SHORE
AND TELLING THEM TO SWIM. NO
WONDER WHY PEOPLE SAY THEY'RE
DROWNING. AND RIGHT, MAYBE
UNLUCKY FEW. THEY GET A KAYAK,
OR THEY GET A GUIDE TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE THESE CHOPPY WATERS AND
A COMMON THREAD THAT WE'VE SEEN
ACROSS NEW INITIATIVES IN THE TD
SPACE HAS BEEN A FOCUS ON
SYSTEMS NAVIGATION NAVIGATORS
FUNDED BY DISPARITY GRANTS.
NAVIGATION IS A COMPONENT OF
COORDINATED FAMILY SUPPORTS.
THERE'S A NEW EMPLOYMENT
NAVIGATOR PILOT THAT'S NEW. THE
DDS AND AT ONE POINT WE NEED TO
ASK. I HOPE THROUGH THE MASTER
PLAN PROCESS. WHY IS ALL THIS
NAVIGATION NECESSARY? WHY DO OUR
SYSTEMS NEED TO BE THIS COMPLEX?
IT SHOULDN'T BE THIS WAY. SO
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THE MASTER
PLAN? WELL, IT MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO PLACE THE BURDEN, NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL NAVIGATORS, NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE, BUT ON
SYSTEMS AND SYSTEMS TO SOLVE
SYSTEMS PROBLEMS LIKE PAYER OF
LAST RESORT RULES. SO IN OTHER
WORDS, WE NEED MORE BRIDGES AND
FEWER KAYAKS. NO MORE BRIDGES
MEANS BETTER ACROSS SYSTEM.
COORDINATION SO OUR AGENCIES CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S IT? WHAT'S A
GENERIC RESOURCE? ANYWAY? ONE DO
PAIR OF LAST RESORT RULES EVEN
APPLY. THAT'S FIGURE OUT WHEN
THEY DO, BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
WHEN THEY DON'T UM, IT MEANS
CLOSING THE LOOP WHEN REFERRALS
ARE MADE ACROSS SYSTEMS, SO
PEOPLE KNOW THE OUTCOME RIGHT
NOW. WE HAVE NO WAY TO TRACK THE
OUTCOME WHEN REFERRALS ARE MADE,
AND IT MEANS EXPLORING AND
LOOKING AT NO WRONG DOOR FUNDING
MODELS THAT SUPPORT AND REFLECT
THE VALUES OF WHOLE PERSON CARE.
AND I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BY ONE UNDERSCORE THIS
POINT. WE NEED. OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS AT THE TABLE. AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS, WE NEED
EDUCATION, SOCIAL SERVICES,
HEALTHCARE SERVICES, AGING
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION OR
OUR SYSTEM CAN'T DO THIS ALONE.
MY SECOND POINT. IN ADDITION TO
LOOKING ACROSS SYSTEMS, WE HAVE
TO LOOK WE HAVE TO LOOK WITHIN.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT OUR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES. THE
STRUCTURES THAT GIVE RISE TO
WHAT WE SEE IS SWEEPING
DISCRETION FROM REGIONAL CENTERS
TO SET THEIR OWN POLICIES ABOUT
WHAT SERVICES THEY'RE GOING TO
FUND AND FOR WHOM, AND WE'VE
SEEN THESE POLICIES AND LIMIT
THAT ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO GET
SERVICES AND DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC
WAYS, INCLUDING IN WAYS THAT
IMPACT RACE IN GEOGRAPHY.
SENATOR ROTH. IT'S THE COMMAND
AND CONTROL PROBLEM THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WHO'S IN
CHARGE WHO'S KEEPING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. UM AND YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE STILL SAY THEY STILL SAY
WITH A SHRUG OF RESIGNATION, 21
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS 21
DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING THINGS,
BUT I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT. I THINK PEOPLE
DESERVE STANDARDS THAT ARE
CLEAR. THAT ARE TRANSPARENT THAT
ARE EQUITABLE AND SHOULDN'T
MATTER WHETHER SOMEONE LIVES IN
THE REDWOOD COAST OR THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY OR ANYWHERE IN
BETWEEN. AND YOU KNOW, WHILE
WE'RE AT IT, MAYBE IT SHOULD BE
33 REGIONAL CENTERS THAT ARE ALL
DOING SIMILAR THINGS TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE. CHILDREN
WAY OF LIVES. WHY CAN'T WE HAVE
THAT LEVEL OF CONSISTENCY? MY
THIRD POINT. WE APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE RECENT INVESTMENTS AIMED
AT PAYING FOR QUALITY, RIGHT FOR
TOO LONG. OUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN
DRIVEN BY METRICS THAT SEEM TO
CARE MORE ABOUT THE VOLUME OF
SERVICES PROVIDED RATHER THAN
THE OUTCOMES THAT MATTER TO
PEOPLE. BUT WITH THESE
INVESTMENTS HAVE COMMON LOT OF
INITIATIVES, AND THEY'RE
STARTING TO FEEL KIND OF
FRAGMENTED. WE HAVE THE PROVIDER
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT
WAS PART OF RATE REFORM. WE HAVE
THE REGIONAL CENTER PERFORMANCE
MEASURES PROGRAM. WE HAVE OTHER
TYPES OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
ABOUT PAID INTERNSHIPS,
EMPLOYMENT. COORDINATED FAMILY
SUPPORTS. SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
ALL THESE THINGS DURING THE
MASTER PLAN. AND WE SHOULD BUILD
ON AND ONLINE ALL OF THOSE
FUNDING MODELS FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM FROM STATE TO REGIONAL
CENTER TO PROVIDE HER WRAP UP.
WELL OKAY. I DID NOT STICK WITH
THE FIVE MINUTES, BUT I'LL START
RAPPING BROKE THE STREAK. OKAY
COME MAKE MY FINAL POINT QUICKLY
. IT'S ABOUT TRUST RIGHT FOR
PEOPLE IF WE'RE GOING TO TRUST
THE THAT THE OUTCOMES THAT ARISE
FROM THE MASTER PLANNED PROCESS
WHEN PEOPLE NEED TO TRUST THAT
PROCESS THAT NOT TO THOSE
OUTCOMES, WE NEED A GOOD
FACILITATOR. WE NEED A
TRANSPARENT DECISION MAKING
STRUCTURE. WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
RELY ON EXPERTS FROM WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE THE DEPARTMENT THAT CAN
INFORM THE WORK GROUP MEMBERS
ABOUT DATA GAPS IN DATA. ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES FOR THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT POINT WE TALKED
ABOUT INVOLVING PEOPLE WITH I D
D. YES BUT IT'S GOT TO BE MORE
THAN CONSULTANTS. IT'S GOT TO BE
MORE THAN FOCUS GROUPS. THEY
NEED TO BE PARTNERS IN DECISION
MAKING IN THIS PROCESS THROUGH
PARTNERS. REAL PARTNERS. THANK
YOU. I APOLOGIZE FOR GOING OVER
MY TIME. I APPRECIATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. JUST
PASSIONATE. DEFINITELY. OKAY I
JUST WANT SOME CLARIFICATION.
YOU MEANT YOU SPOKE ABOUT
OUTCOMES WHEN REFERRALS ARE MADE
. WHAT KIND OF REFERRALS ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT? SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT
PAIR OF LAST RESORT SO ORIGINAL,
SARAH SAYS. SOMEONE SAYS WE NEED
HELP. WE NEED HELP IN THE FAMILY
HOME REGIONAL CENTER SAYS. HAVE
YOU EXPORT FIRST? HAVE YOU GONE
TO THE COUNTY? HAVE YOU GOT IN
YOUR HOURS, AND THEY SEND THE
FAMILY OFF TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO THAT. NOW THERE IS NO DATA.
THERE'S NO DATA SHARED ACROSS
SYSTEMS. THERE'S NO EASY WAY FOR
REGIONAL CENTER TO SAY. OH, THAT
WORKED. WE CLOSED THAT WE CLOSE
THAT GROUP FOR THE REFERRAL, SO
WE KNOW YOUR NEEDS ARE BEING
MET. THAT THAT IS NOT TRACKED
ACROSS SYSTEMS. AND THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE HSS SIDE. BUT
THERE ARE MANY MORE AS WELL LIKE
AROUND CLOSING THE LOOP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MOVING ONTO ELIO. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS KARINA HENDREN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE FIRST POINT THAT WE WANT TO
STRESSES THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT IN THE
MASTER PLAN. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
INTRODUCING LEGISLATION TO
ENSURE THAT THE VISION FOR THE
MASTER PLAN AS WELL AS ITS
ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION REFLECTS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND THAT
THERE IS A ROLE FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. UM THE SECOND POINT
RELATES TO FUNDING WHILE DDS.
THEY HAVE NOT REQUESTED ANY
FUNDING IN 2425 TO DEVELOP THE
MASTER PLAN, AND THE DEPARTMENT
EARLIER SPOKE ABOUT THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORTS ONGOING
WITH THEIR STRATEGIC PLAN. WE
WANT TO STRESS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER, UM,
POTENTIAL COST PRESSURES OF THE
PLANS ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION IN
FUTURE YEARS. AND GIVEN LIKELY
BUDGET DEFICITS THROUGH 2027 28
UNDERSTANDING THE POTENTIAL
FUTURE FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE
MASTER PLANS. IMPLEMENTATION
WILL BE CRITICAL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I ACTUALLY ONE OF MY NEXT
QUESTIONS DIRECTOR WAS REGARDING
. HOW MUCH ARE WE GOING TO MATCH
THE PROCESS IN WHICH WE DID
MASTER PLAN ON AGING TO THIS IN
REGARDS SPECIFICALLY TO THE ANT
TO THE REPORTS THAT CAME TO US
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION SIDE OF
IT. CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT
DISCUSSION, SO ASKING WE HOW ARE
WE GOING TO BE REPORTING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE? UM ONE OF THE
GREATEST WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMED ON MANY OF THE
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES AND
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN OUR
QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS WITH BROAD
REPRESENTATION OF LEGISLATIVE
STAFF. BUT THERE'S ALSO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
DID. AND SO WE'D CERTAINLY BE,
UM OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT
WOULD BE INFORMATIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THIS COMMITTEE IS
HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, AND I KNOW I ASKED THIS
QUESTION EARLIER. UM AND YOU
KNOW, YOU DIDN'T MENTION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABSORBABLE THIS YEAR. WHAT ABOUT
FOR WHAT LAO JUST MENTIONED THE
NEXT UPCOMING YEARS. SEEING THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE WE ARE
ANTICIPATING ANTICIPATING
DEFICITS FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS WITHOUT KNOWING THE WORK
THAT THE MASTER PLANS DONE YET.
YOU KNOW, THE INTENT IS NOT TO
KIND OF BUILD, YOU KNOW,
PRESSURE COST, YOU KNOW, LOOKING
AT THE NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY HAD OVER THE
LAST MANY YEARS. WE CAN
CERTAINLY IDENTIFY AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS. IT'S WORKING WITHIN
THOSE INVESTMENTS IS THE INTENT
OF BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE INTENDED TO DO OR TAKING
A LOOK AT HOW WE CAN MAXIMIZE
THOSE INVESTMENTS TO THE BENEFIT
OF INDIVIDUALS. AND THEN ONE OF
MY FINAL THOUGHTS ON THIS IS
THIS IS NEITHER. IT'S GOOD. IT
HOLDS US ACCOUNTABLE, RIGHT? BUT
WHEN I LOOK AT THE MASTER PLAN
ON AGING IT'S KINDA I DON'T KNOW
IF THE CORRECT WORD IS WEAPONIZE
BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE. I FEEL
LIKE IT SHOULD BE REALLY HOSES
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT ALSO SHOWS ARE
FAILURES BECAUSE IT'S WRITTEN IN
THAT DOCUMENT, AND I KNOW THE
BUDGET IS OUT OF OUR CONTROL,
RIGHT? AND BUT AT TIMES DURING
THE LEAST IN THE SITUATIONS,
CONVERSATIONS ARE HIGH FAT IS WE
HAVE THIS MASTER PLAN ON AGING
BUDGET DOESN'T REFLECT WHAT WE
PUT IN THAT PLAN. IT'S NOT
PRIORITIZING OUR INVESTMENTS. AS
WE SAID WE WERE GOING TO DO IN
THE PLAN. I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THAT KIND OF SENTIMENT FOR THIS
MASTER PLAN RIGHT FOR US TO BE
MINDFUL THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THIS ON PAPER, THAT MEANS
THAT I OR YES, I BECAUSE THIS
WILL BE DONE DURING MY TIME.
DON'T HAVE ADVOCATES COMING TO
ME. SO YOU PUT THIS ON PAPER,
BUT IT'S NOT BEING SHOWN IN OUR
BUDGET INVESTMENTS. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE IF THIS IS PRINT
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO COMMIT TO
THIS. FOR THE NEXT YEARS AND
REALLY ACHIEVE OUR GOALS. THAT
WOULD BE MY FINAL THOUGHTS ON
THIS. SENATOR OFF WELL, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW, I
WAS BEEN LISTENING TO THE
CONVERSATION AND THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS. I THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FUNDING
BENEFITS AND FUNDING. WHAT I'VE
DESCRIBED AND I THINK IS TRUE AS
A CORE GOVERNMENT FUNCTION. SO
THAT IT'S COORDINATED AT
WHATEVER BENEFIT LEVEL WE'RE
ABLE TO FUND AS A RESULT OF THE
BUDGET. UM DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THAT AND FUNDING IT TO ENSURE
THROUGH COORDINATION. UM THAT
OUR CLIENTS AREN'T SENT. YOUR
CLIENTS AREN'T SENT BOUNCING
AROUND THE SYSTEM LIKE A
BILLIARD BALL. AND I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT TO DO.
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE
BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS IN THE
STATE, AND THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO FUND IN THE
WAY OF BENEFITS TO GO UP AND
DOWN. UNFORTUNATELY HOPEFULLY WE
PRIORITIZE THOSE THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT AS THESE BUT ONE THING
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE FUND
THIS THAT WE FUND A COORDINATED
PROCESS AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND I KNOW MY CHAIR. I
KNOW MY CHURCH AGREES WITH ME
AND MY COLLEAGUE BOTH BOTH
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS AREA. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
YOUR MASTER PLAN COMES UP WITH.
AND THEN WE GET AN IMPLEMENTED
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. YOU
KNOW, IN THE MILITARY WE DO
PLANNING, BUT WE DON'T TAKE A
LONG TIME TO DO IT AND WE'RE
MORE ACTION THAN PLAN AND IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE'RE GETTING
THERE. THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU
DO. THANK YOU, MADAM. SURE.
THAT'S I THINK THE FRUSTRATING
PART. YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE THESE
THREE VETERANS HERE AND IT'S IT
WAS SENATOR GROVER'S FOR
EVERYONE. IT'S JUST THE
HEADLINES LIKE THAT'S NOT WHERE
WE'RE HERE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION PART IS KEY,
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
GET ALL THIS CREDIT LIKE, LOOK,
WE DID THIS FIRST EVER MASTER
PLAN AGING ON DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. BUT THEN THEN THERE'S
NO MEAT TO IT. LIKE AT LEAST I'M
SO TIRED OF THE HEADLINES SO
TIRED OF THEM. SO I'D RATHER
HAVE NO PRESS OR ANYTHING ON
THIS. AND THEN IN TWO YEARS WERE
LIKE, LOOK HOW MUCH WE'VE
ADVANCED. RIGHT IT'S THE MEAT
PART THAT'S GIVEN THAT BRINGS
THE ATTENTION OF THE MEDIA AND
SO FORTH. THAT'S WHAT I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN. SO I DIDN'T HAVE
THOSE WEREN'T MY FINAL THOUGHTS
THAT I HAVE A LITTLE MORE FINAL
FINAL THOUGHTS. I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION DIRECTOR JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE IN THE
NEXT PANEL. ARE WE GONNA BECAUSE
THE NEXT PANEL IS OUR REGARDING
OVERSIGHT. WHAT WE LOOK TO WHAT
WE INCLUDE IN OUR TRAILER BILL,
LANGUAGE AND SO FORTH. IS THIS
MASTER PLAN ITS INTENTION TO
ABSORB THOSE EFFORTS. ARE THEY
GOING TO BE WORKING SIDE BY SIDE
OR HOW DO YOU SEE OUR OVERSIGHT
WITH EQUITY AND DIVERSITY AND
STANDARDIZATION? WE DID IT WITH
OUR TBL ON REGIONAL CENTERS
COINCIDE WITH THE WORK ON THE
MASTER PLAN. MORE CONVERSATIONS
CAN BE HAD AROUND THAT, UM SO
THAT THE EQUITY SIDE BECAUSE
WE'RE THE MASTER PLANS REALLY
FORWARD THINKING THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE EQUITY AND
THE OVERSIGHT THAT WAS
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR. THAT'S A
HERE AND NOW THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON IMPLEMENTING, YOU
KNOW, IN THE GENDER CORRECTLY,
KIND OF OUTLINES WHAT THOSE
DELIVERABLES ARE AND KIND OF
WHERE WE ARE WHERE WE ARE ON
THOSE GET SOME UPDATES FROM MY
DDS COLLEAGUES ON IT, SO WE
CAN'T INTERRUPT OUR CURRENT WORK
. UM WHILE WE'RE WORKING ON THE
MASTER PLAN, BUT I THINK OUR
CURRENT WORK CAN INFORM THE
MASTER PLAN, SO WE JUST HAVE TO
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW,
I LOVE THAT YOU SAID YOU KNOW
THIS. THIS IS KIND OF ONE OF THE
FIRST ROUND TABLES. UM AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE MORE OF
THOSE, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY INITIATIVES RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE INCREDIBLE. UM, AND
THE WORK OF THE MASTER PLAN IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE A DISTANCE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
BE LISTENING. IT'S GOING TO BE
AUTHENTIC IN IN IN SEEING WHAT
THE VISION IS, UM AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MARRY THOSE TWO
AND THAT'S JUST GOING TO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, AND I JUST WANT TO ASK W
DIRECTOR. IS THIS YOUR ONLY JOB
NOW? THE VICTOR. I TOOK YOU OUT
THERE IS THIS ANOTHER DUTIES AS
ASSIGNED THE THIS IS MY TOP
PRIORITY. CRAFTY WAY OF ENTERING
IT. GOT IT. OKAY MAKE IT A
PRIORITY. DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I THINK
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THE
SENTENCE PANELS MINDSET. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PANELISTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
OUT. I APPRECIATE IT. YOU ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. THE NEXT
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO BE
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR LEGISLATIVE EQUITY AND
OVERSIGHT MEASURES AS IT RELATES
TO WHAT WE INCLUDED IN THE 2023
BUDGET ACT. BEFORE YET.
MUCH.
WE HAD PEOPLE ARE WE ALL HERE?
WHAT I BELIEVE WE'RE ALL HERE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GET KICKED OFF
BY LAO THANKS, MADAM CHAIR. WE
HAD PREPARED A SUMMARY JUST THE
PROVISIONS IN SP 138, BUT JUST
WANTED TO DO A QUICK TIME CHECK.
DID YOU WANT US TO READ THE
SUMMARY OR JUST DIVE RIGHT IN TO
THE OTHER PANELISTS? READ IT.
JUST CHECKING. UM SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS AGENDA
ITEM. BUT AS I NOTED, WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE A SUMMARY JUST
FOR EVERYONE'S ON THE SAME PAGE.
UM SO SB 138 IS TRAILER
LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THAT ALONG WITH OTHER
STATUTORY CHANGES IN HUMAN
SERVICES, SETS REQUIREMENTS FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, EQUITY
AND OVERSIGHT. THE LEGISLATION
WAS PROMPTED BY DATA SHOWING
DISPARITIES AND THE AMOUNT SPENT
PER PERSON ON SERVICES WHEN
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY. AND ALTHOUGH THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
EQUITY GRANTS SINCE 2016 TO
ADDRESS THIS GAP, THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC SPENDING DISPARITY STILL
PERSIST. SB 138 ESTABLISHES
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE PROVISION SHOULD
BE MORE UNIFORM AND EQUITABLE
BUDGET ACT OF 2023 ALLOCATED
ABOUT 8 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THESE PURPOSES. HELP ACHIEVE
UNIFORM AND EQUITABLE SERVICE
PROVISION. STATEWIDE LEGISLATION
DEFINES SEVERAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT DDS AND REGIONAL CENTERS
MUST SATISFY BETWEEN JUNE 2024
IN JANUARY, 2026. THE DEPARTMENT
MUST SOLICIT INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AS PART OF THESE
EFFORTS. FIRST THE LEGISLATION
INCLUDES PROVISIONS ON DATA
COLLECTION, DDS MUST ESTABLISH
COMMON DATA DEFINITIONS FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS TO PROMOTE SERVICE,
ACCESS AND EQUITY REGIONAL
CENTERS MUST BEGIN RECORDING THE
RACE, ETHNICITY AND PREFERRED
LANGUAGE OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
SERVED AND REGIONAL CENTERS MUST
ALSO BEGIN SUBMITTING QUARTERLY
REPORTS TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
NUMBER OF ASSESSMENTS COMPLETED.
AND THE AMOUNT OF TIME SPENT
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY. THE
SECOND. THE LEGISLATION AIMS TO
STANDARDIZE PROCESSES THAT
DETERMINE ACCESS TO SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT MUST DEVELOP A
STANDARDIZED APPROACH TO
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN OR I PP
TEMPLATES. INTAKE PROCESSES,
RESPITE ASSESSMENTS AND VENDOR
IZATION PROCEDURES AND REGIONAL
CENTERS MUST THEN IMPLEMENT
THESE STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES.
THIRD THE LEGISLATION DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY AND
MITIGATE POTENTIAL BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING SERVICES. THE
DEPARTMENT MUST ORGANIZE AN
EFFORT TO IDENTIFY BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING SERVICES PROVIDED BY
OTHER ENTITIES AND RECOMMEND
OPTIONS TO IMPROVE COORDINATION
OF THESE SERVICES. THE
DEPARTMENT MUST ALSO ASSESS
WHETHER COMMON SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE CONSISTENTLY
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE DD
SYSTEM BY GEOGRAPHY AND
LANGUAGE. AND IF THEY'RE NOT
RECOMMEND WAYS TO ADDRESS ANY
INCONSISTENCIES, AND FINALLY,
THE LEGISLATION ALSO AIMS TO
IMPROVE COMMUNICATION WITH
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES SERVED.
TO THIS END, REGIONAL CENTERS
MUST INFORM INDIVIDUALS ON THE
OUTCOME OF AN ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION WITHIN 15 DAYS OF
AN INITIAL INTAKE AND CONSUMERS
PREFERRED LANGUAGE. ADDITIONALLY
REGIONAL CENTERS MUST CREATE AND
DISTRIBUTE STANDARDIZED
INFORMATION PACKETS THAT ARE
ACCESSIBLE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
AND FORMATS AND JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT PAGES 24 TO 25 OF THE
AGENDA INCLUDED TABLE WITH MORE
DETAILS ON THE REQUIREMENTS AND
DEADLINES AND IMPLEMENTATION.
UPDATES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MOVING ON TO OUR DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVE. GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IS SORRY.
IT'S RIGHT. THERE WE GO. THANK
YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS, P
CHAIR OF INCOME, THE CHIEF OF
DATA ANALYTICS AND STRATEGY AT
THE DEPARTMENT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY. MY
COLLEAGUE TO MY RIGHT JUST ON A
NUMBER OF THE DESCRIPTIVE
COMMENTS THAT I WAS PLANNING TO
MAKE, SO I APPRECIATE THAT. UM,
I THINK WE'VE HAD ALREADY THIS
MORNING AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
PANELS. A ROBUST CONVERSATION
ABOUT STANDARDIZATION IN THE
SYSTEM. THIS IS IMPORTANT,
OBVIOUSLY NOT JUST FOR EQUITY,
BUT ALSO EXPERIENCE THAT THAT
FAMILIES HAVE AS THEY NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM. AND SO WHAT YOU
HEARD SUMMARIZED HERE, AND IT'S
IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE 22. YOU
KNOW THE FRONT DOOR? WHAT IS
INTAKE LOOK LIKE WHAT IS THE
ASSESSMENT FOR CRITICAL SERVICES
THAT MANY PEOPLE GET LOOK LIKE?
WHAT IS THE VENDOR EXPERIENCE AS
THEY APPLY TO PROVIDE SERVICES
IN OUR SYSTEM? THESE ARE THE
PLACES WHERE WE HAVE DECIDED TO
START. I'VE SAID, YOU KNOW, PART
OF MY TITLE INCLUDES DATA
ANALYTICS, SO OF COURSE DATA IS
IMPORTANT AND ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT ENABLE EVERYTHING
ELSE TO HAPPEN IN THE SYSTEM IN
MEASURING, HOW ARE WE DOING IS
GOOD DATA. AND THIS IS THE
REASON THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR IN
SP 138 PRIORITIZED DEFINITIONS
THAT SHOULD BE STANDARDIZED FOR
RACE, ETHNICITY AND PREFERRED
LANGUAGE THAT PEOPLE USE. I'M
GOING TO FORECAST FOR YOU THAT
NEXT WEEK WILL BE OPENING A
PUBLIC COMMENT OPPORTUNITY ON
THOSE THREE TOPICS AS WELL AS
THE RESIDENTS CODES THAT PEOPLE
USE AS WELL AS SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY.
AND ALSO ON WHAT WE CALL STATUS
CODES IN OUR SYSTEM, WHICH
IDENTIFY WHICH PROGRAMS PEOPLE
ARE PARTICIPATING IN SO REALLY
EXCITED FOR THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE COLLECTING DATA ON SOLDIER
DATA. WE CURRENTLY IN OUR SYSTEM
. WE ONLY ASK, ARE YOU CONSIDER
YOURSELF TO BE MALE OR FEMALE?
OKAY AND SO WE PLAN TO AUGMENT
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE ARE
SEEKING PUBLIC INPUT ON WHAT WE
SHOULD BE ASKING. WE HOPE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT NEXT WEEK WHAT
I'VE JUST DESCRIBED FOR YOU AS
BOX ONE ON PAGE 24, WHICH WHICH
TALKS ABOUT THE STATUS OF OUR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
INITIATIVES. THAT'S THE VERY
FIRST ONE OUT THE GATE. THE
SECOND ONE, WHICH WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BOX TWO ON PAGE
24 ABOUT THE PROCESS, THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN. THERE
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING SERIES OF
MEETINGS THAT WERE EIGHT
MEETINGS HELD TO BEGIN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WHAT A
STANDARDIZED TEMPLATE WOULD LOOK
LIKE. THOSE MEETINGS HAPPENED IN
MAY, JUNE AND JULY OF 2023, AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ONGOING
WORK INSIDE THE DEPARTMENT ON
THAT, AND WE PLAN TO TAKE A
DRAFT BACK OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND SO THOSE TWO ITEMS
THAT HAVE DESCRIBED BOTH NEED TO
BE COMPLETED BY JUNE. 30 OF THIS
YEAR PERSON WENT TO SENATE BILL
138 AS IT WAS ENACTED AND BOTH
NEED TO BEGIN TO BE USED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS. JULY GENUINE
ERI FIRST USE MY DATES CORRECTLY
, SORRY. BOTH NEED TO BEGIN TO
BE USED JANUARY 1ST OF 25 6
MONTHS LATER. SO EXCITED TO
ANNOUNCE PROGRESS ON THOSE THE
OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED OR OBVIOUSLY BEEN
GIVEN THOUGHT THERE ABOUT SIX
MONTHS BEHIND THE OTHERS IN
TERMS OF STATUTORY DEADLINES AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANKS. QUICK YOU ACTUALLY
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA. YEAH ABSOLUTELY. THE
FIRST ONE IS HOW YOU HOW ARE YOU
COLLABORATING WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES SERVED? YEAH HAPPY TO
DO SO. SO I GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE COLLABORATION THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENED AND WHAT'S UP COMING?
YOU KNOW THOSE MEETINGS INCLUDED
OUR CONSUMER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
ARE FOCUS GROUPS WITH SOUTH
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
POPULATIONS, HISPANIC AND LATINO
LATINA. LATIN X POPULATIONS. WE
MET WITH THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE A FOCUS GROUP WITH
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND BLACK
REPRESENTATIVES. AND THERE WERE
THREE MEETINGS WITH OUR REGIONAL
CENTER PERFORMANCE MEASURES
GROUP. AS OUR OPERATING PARTNERS
DOING THOSE THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT. AS I MENTIONED THE
DRAFT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM
PLAN, OR IP P WILL BE COMING
BACK OUT FOR ADDITIONAL ROUNDS
OF INPUT. AND AS YOU HEARD MR
LUEGO STATE ON A PRIOR PANEL
TODAY, IMPLEMENTATION IS REALLY
KEY AND PERSON CENTERED. NOUS
NEEDS TO BE A FOCUS OF THAT VERY
CENTRAL DOCUMENT FOR OUR SYSTEM.
UM IN TERMS OF NUMBER TWO. THE
DEPARTMENT CONTRACT ID FOR AN
ANALYSIS OF OUR $11 MILLION
SERVICE, ACCESS AND EQUITY GRANT
. WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
TOWARDS RELEASE OF THAT. WE
TESTIFIED LAST YEAR. IT'S ABOUT
SOME OF THE PRELIMINARY FINDINGS
FOR THAT, AND I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
THOSE WITH YOU TODAY. CONTINUING
THE GRANT PROGRAM WAS ONE OF
THEM. THEY WANT US TO THE
RECOMMENDED AH, THAT CLEARER
LOGIC MODEL FOR THOSE GRANTS.
KIND OF WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH? WHAT ARE WE TRYING
TO MEASURE BE APPLIED TO THOSE
GRANT PROGRAMS, THEY SUGGESTED
PLAINER LANGUAGE BE USED IN IN
TERMS OF DESCRIBING WHAT WE WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH TO MAKE IT EASIER
BOTH FOR THE PEOPLE RECEIVING
THOSE GRANTS TO KNOW WHAT'S
EXPECTED OF THEM AND ALSO ON THE
BACK END, MORE STANDARD
COLLECTION OF INFORMATION ON THE
BACK END. AND THEY WANT THEY
RECOMMENDED. ALSO CLEAR PRE AND
POST SURVEY INFORMATION. SO
DOING A BETTER JOB UP FRONT OF
COLLECTING INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND AT THE END
OF THE GRANT, WHERE WE WILL GO.
THEY SUGGESTED TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT, THROUGH A NUMBER OF
CHANGES. ONE OF THEM HAS ALREADY
BEEN IMPLEMENTED. WE MOVED FROM
ONE YEAR GRANT CYCLE TO A TWO
YEAR GRANT CYCLE THAT THAT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT RECOMMENDATION. THEY
ALSO SUGGESTED THAT WE FOCUS
MORE ON THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THOSE GRANTS AND
BE MORE TARGETED AND HAVING SAID
TARGETED, I'LL USE THAT TO SAY
THAT THEY SUGGESTED WE STOP
USING THE WORD TARGET TO USE.
IDENTIFY WHICH POPULATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES WE WANT. THOSE
GRANTS FOCUSED ON UM
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEMS THAT WE USE
MORE APPLICANT ID THE
SOLICITATION OF MORE
APPLICATIONS FROM POTENTIAL
GRANTEES WHO CAN WORK WITH
PEOPLE IN NONTRADITIONAL WORK
HOURS. UM AND, UM DOING A BETTER
JOB WHEN WE REACH OUT TO NEW
POPULATIONS OF MEASURING THE
IMPACT OF THOSE OUTREACH EFFORTS
, SO THAT'S A KIND OF A SUMMARY
OF RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SUGGESTIONS THAT THAT THAT
REPORT HAS MADE AGAIN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. SO MUCH
MHM GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANELISTS FROM OUR ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES.
WELCOME BACK, AMY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MADAM.
CHAIR MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE. MY NAME IS AMY WESTLING,
AND I'M, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES, ALSO KNOWN AS
ARCA. SUPPORTS AND WORKS
ALONGSIDE THE 21 REGIONAL
CENTERS, WHICH TODAY SERVES MORE
THAN 430,000 CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY AND TO SHARE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW TO CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE UPON
THE EQUITY EFFORTS IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
SIMILAR TO OTHER EDUCATIONAL,
SOCIAL SERVICE AND HEALTH CARE
ORGANIZATIONS. CALIFORNIANS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
HAS IDENTIFIED CHALLENGES WITH
EQUITABLY SERVING PEOPLE ACROSS
RACIAL, ETHNIC, LINGUISTIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC LINES. WHAT SETS US
APART IS THAT AS WE HAVE HEARD
SINCE 2016, THERE HAVE BEEN
CONCERTED EFFORTS AND DEDICATED
FUNDING. TO IMPROVE OUR
PERFORMANCE IN THIS AREA WERE
INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE THAT
IMPROVING EQUITY IS NOW A
CENTRAL TENANT OF ALL OF THE
POLICIES AND ALL OF THE
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, EVEN IF THEY ARE
NOT AT THEIR CORE AND EQUITY
INITIATIVE. WHAT IS ASKED AS
IMPLEMENTATION IS ROLLED OUT IS
ALWAYS HOW IS THIS GOING TO
IMPACT? VARIOUS COMMUNITIES. HOW
IS THIS GOING TO IMPACT PEOPLE
WHO SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH? AND HOW IS THIS GOING
TO IMPACT PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE? WE KNOW THAT THE ULTIMATE
QUESTION TO BE ANSWERED IS
WHETHER EACH PERSON'S NEEDS ARE
BEING MET AND WHETHER THE
QUALITY OF OUTCOMES DIFFER
ACROSS RACIAL, ETHNIC,
LINGUISTIC OR GEOGRAPHIC LINES.
WHILE THERE IS IMPORTANT WORK
GOING ON THROUGH EFFORTS, SUCH
AS THE PAVED PROGRAM AND OTHER
EFFORTS TO HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND TRUE INDIVIDUAL
OUTCOMES. TODAY WE HAVE TO USE
THE DATA. WE HAVE TO DEFINE
SUCCESS IN THIS AREA, AND WE
HAVE NOT YET CLEARLY SAID HERE
ARE THOSE SET OF MEASURES THAT
WILL TELL US WHEN WE HAVE AN
EQUITABLE SYSTEM. WE TEND TO
FOCUS JUST ON WHAT WE'RE
PURCHASING FOR PEOPLE, THE
QUANTITY AND THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICE THAT PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING. BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
TO THIS STORY. THERE IS SO MUCH
MORE AS MR TREBEK Ó SPOKE ABOUT
. THERE IS THE QUESTION OF
INTAKE AND PEOPLE'S EXPERIENCE
WITH THE SYSTEM SO ARCA WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THERE BE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE DEFINITION OF WHAT
EQUITY IS AND THAT THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES WOULD BE A GOOD JUMPING
OFF POINT. FOR HELPING US BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND BETTER TRACK OVER
TIME, HOW WE ARE DOING AND IF WE
BETTER UNDERSTAND, AND WE'RE
BETTER ABLE TO TRACK OVER TIME
SUCCESS IN KEY AREAS THAT CAN
ALSO DRIVE INTERVENTION. IT WILL
TELL US WHERE WE'RE STRONG, BUT
ALSO IT WILL TELL US WHERE WE'RE
WEAK AND WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
WE RECOMMEND THE FOLLOWING
PURCHASE OF SERVICE, PRIMARILY
FOR PEOPLE LIVING AT HOME. THIS
IS ONE OF THE THINGS IN OUR
SYSTEM THAT WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH
ABOUT, WHICH IS THAT THE COST OF
SERVING SOMEONE WHEN THEY LIVE
AT HOME IS SIGNIFICANTLY LESS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ARE WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO MAINTAIN THEM IN
THE HOME ENVIRONMENT. AND WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD WAY TO ACCOUNT
FOR THAT ON A FISCAL FROM A
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE, SO IT REALLY
BENDS THE CURVE IN SOME VERY
INTERESTING WAYS WHEN WE DON'T
CONTROL FOR WHERE SOMEONE LIVES
OR HOW OLD THEY ARE, BECAUSE AS
PEOPLE AGE IN OUR SYSTEM, THE
REALITY IS THERE NEEDS GET MORE
EXPENSIVE. SO LOOKING ACROSS
RACIAL, ETHNIC, LINGUISTIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC LINES THAT PURCHASE
OF SERVICE FOR PEOPLE LIVING AT
HOME FROM BIRTH TO THREE FROM 3
TO 21 AND THOSE OVER AGE 22. AND
AGAIN, THE INTENT IS TO
HIGHLIGHT WHERE THERE ARE
POCKETS OF EXCELLENCE AND WHERE
WE NEED TO DO BETTER. FOR
INSTANCE, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DATA FOR THOSE BIRTH THROUGH
THREE, WE SEE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
SERVED IN OUR SYSTEM. THERE ARE
VERY FEW DIFFERENCES AMONG YOUNG
CHILDREN IN THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICE THAT'S PURCHASED. SO
WHAT CAN WE LEARN ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING WELL THERE AND APPLY
TO OTHER POPULATIONS. WE ALSO
HAVE HEARD FROM FAMILIES THAT
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES ARE
IMPORTANT. SO AN ANALYSIS OF
RESPITE AND PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
ALSO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN OUR SERVICE SYSTEM WHO
DO NOT RECEIVE PURCHASE SERVICES
, SO LOOKING TO SEE ARE THEIR
DEMOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES IN THAT
POPULATION. AS MR TREVECCA
SUGGESTED ELIGIBILITY TIMELINES
AND DIFFERENCES THERE. THE
PERCENT OF TOTAL POPULATION
SERVED. THE EMPLOYMENT RATE
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE
MEASURES OF HOW WE'RE DOING AT
HELPING ADULTS TO ACHIEVE
INDEPENDENCE. WORST SERVICES
BENEFICIAL. OUR FAMILIES
SATISFIED ARE INDIVIDUALS WE
SERVE SATISFIED WITH THOSE
SERVICES. WE NEED TO COLLECT
THAT INFORMATION. WE COLLECT IT
NOW THROUGH THE NATIONAL COURT
INDICATORS, BUT WE'RE MISSING
THE POPULATION OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T RECEIVE PURCHASE SERVICES
AND SO FINDING A WAY TO MEASURE
THAT AS WELL. ASKING PEOPLE WAS
YOUR SERVICE COORDINATOR
RESPECTFUL OF YOUR CULTURE,
BECAUSE THAT'S AT THE HEART OF
THIS WORK. AND ASSESSING WHETHER
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THE SERVICE
COORDINATORS ARE RESPONSIVE AND
TIMELY WITH GETTING BACK TO
THEM. AND WHETHER PEOPLE
ULTIMATELY HAVE A CHOICE OF
PROVIDERS WHO SPEAK THEIR
LANGUAGE. WE KNOW THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE THE BILINGUAL STIPEND
PROGRAM WILL HELP TO ENHANCE
THAT. BUT I IMAGINE IF YOU WERE
TO ASK PEOPLE TODAY THOSE WHO
SPEAK ENGLISH HAVE BROADER
CHOICE AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO TACKLE
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
ROLLING THAT PROGRAM OUT. SO
WHILE DATA ALONE CANNOT TELL
ANYONE PERSON'S STORY, IT CAN
HELP US UNDERSTAND WAYS ON A
SYSTEMIC LEVEL THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE SYSTEMS, MANY OF THE
CONSISTENCY EFFORTS UNDERWAY AS
A RESULT OF SP 138 ARE PART OF
THAT OVERALL SOLUTION. ALONE
CONSISTENCY IS NOT GOING TO FIX
DISPARITY, BUT CONSISTENCY AND
BETTER DATA WILL HELP US TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE WE NEED TO
TARGET INTERVENTIONS NEXT. AS MR
TREVECCA MENTIONED, THERE HAS
BEEN WORK GOING ON AT THE
DEPARTMENT LEVEL RELATED TO
IMPROVING DATA DEFINITIONS,
WHICH WILL HELP US AS REGIONAL
CENTERS TO COLLECT MORE
CONSISTENT DATA, BUT IT WILL
ALSO ALLOW OUR DATA TO BE USED
TO COMPARE US TO OTHER SYSTEMS
WHO ARE USING SIMILAR
DEFINITIONS. UM THE TEMPLATE AND
PROCEDURES. I STARTED IN THIS
FIELD AS AN ADVOCATE AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I KNOW IS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE GREATER
CONSISTENCY IN THE CENTRAL
PROCESSES, IT MAKES IT EASIER
FOR ADVOCATES TO HELP PEOPLE
NAVIGATE SYSTEMS. SO WHILE IT
MAY NOT SEEM DIRECTLY TIED TO
EQUITY, IT IS IN THAT WAY
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS FOR MORE
CONSISTENT EDUCATION OF PEOPLE
ABOUT THE PROCESS. AND ABOUT THE
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT THEY CAN
EXPECT TO SEE IN THE DOCUMENTS
THEY RECEIVE. BUT IT ALSO THE
EMPTY IS THE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
REALLY GET TO SURFACE, THEIR OWN
INTERESTS, THEIR OWN HOPES AND
THE AND THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT LINKED TO THOSE,
SO THE MORE CONSISTENT PROCESS
WE HAVE. THE MORE LIKELY WE ARE
TO SURFACE THOSE NEEDS IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL'S CASE. INTAKE
PROCESS IS GETTING IN THE DOOR
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER SHOULD BE
CLEAR, CONSISTENT AND AS
PREDICTABLE AS POSSIBLE. WHEN
YOU HAVE A CHILD BEING
CONSIDERED FOR REGIONAL CENTER
ELIGIBILITY, THERE ARE RANGE OF
EMOTIONS GOING ON WITHIN A
FAMILY, AND WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PROCESS IS NOT
COMPLICATING THINGS. AND MAKING
THOSE ALREADY DIFFICULT
REFERRALS HARDER. GENERIC
SERVICES EVALUATION. ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE SAID THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER IS THAT EVERYBODY WHO
WORKS IN THE SYSTEM AND I'VE
WORKED WITH PEOPLE WHO CLOSELY
WITH PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN OUR
STATE'S DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
HAVE WORKED IN THE ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY HAVE WORKED FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. TWO OF THEM
AND I HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING FOR OUR GOOD FOR 12
YEARS, BUT I'VE ALWAYS SAID
PEOPLE ARE WHO WORK IN THIS
FIELD ARE INCREDIBLY GOOD PEOPLE
, BUT THEY'RE OFTEN WORKING
WITHIN IMPERFECT SYSTEMS. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
THE REPORT ON GENERIC SERVICES
WILL SURFACE AND CERTAINLY THERE
WILL BE A LOT OF CROSSOVER WITH
THE MASTER PLAN IS HOW WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY FIX SOME OF THESE
IMPERFECTIONS AND ONE OF THE
IMPERFECTIONS. WE'VE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR, AND I'VE SAID IT
SINCE THE DAYS I WAS AN
ADVOCATE. IS AROUND GENERIC
SERVICES AND HOW WE CAN HELP
PEOPLE TO BETTER NAVIGATE THAT
PROCESS SO THAT IT IN ITSELF
DOESN'T BECOME A FULL TIME JOB.
CAN YOU START WRAPPING UP? YES.
UM RESPITE ASSESSMENT PROCESS
FAMILY NEEDS ARE NOT TIED TO
GEOGRAPHY AND VENDOR IZATION
PROCEDURES IS SOMETHING ARCA WAS
WORKING ON PRIOR TO SP 138, AND
WE HAVE PROVIDED OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. ADDITIONALLY ARCA IS
WORKING ON SOME CONSISTENCY
MEASURES OF ITS OWN. WE ARE
WORKING ON A UNIFORM DAYCARE
ASSESSMENT AND HOPE TO ALSO
BRING CONSISTENCY TO REGIONAL
CENTER POLICIES IN THIS AREA.
AND A LOT OF THIS WORK WILL BE
INFORMED BY STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
THAT WILL BEGIN NEXT MONTH AND
WILL ANSWER CRITICAL QUESTIONS
AROUND DEFINITIONS OF THINGS
LIKE WHAT ARE NATURAL SERVICES
OR NATURAL SUPPORTS AND GENERIC
SERVICES. AND ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE DONE WORK TO ENSURE THAT
EACH REGIONAL CENTERS WEBSITE
NOW HAS A CONSISTENT BUTTON THAT
WHEN YOU CLICK IT, IT TAKES YOU
TO THAT REGIONAL CENTERS.
TRANSPARENCY PORTAL WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR COMMUNITY THAT THESE
THINGS WILL MATTER AND JUST
TODAY, THE REGIONAL CENTER
DIRECTORS MET AND APPROVED A
PROCESS. THAT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
TRANSFER OF CASES IN THE INTAKE
PROCESS IN A CONSISTENT WAY, SO
THAT IF PEOPLE MOVE, WHICH TENDS
TO HAPPEN MORE IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
INTAKE PROCESS, THOSE TIMELINES
WON'T RESTART SO THAT WE CAN GET
TO THOSE CHILDREN MORE SPEEDILY
AND GET THOSE INTERVENTIONS TO
THEM AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. SO
AGAIN COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
WE'RE ALL WORKING TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE EQUITY AND TO
IDENTIFYING ADDITIONAL CONCRETE
STRATEGIES TO HELP US ALONG OUR
WAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, UM,
CAN YOU JUST FROM MY KNOWLEDGE
WHEN YOU SPEAK ABOUT CONTROLLING
FOR WHERE SOMEONE LIVES? I THINK
YOU MENTIONED OTHER THINGS. JUST
THE COST SERVICING. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN HOW THAT WORKS? IS IT
THAT THERE IS A COST? FOR EVERY
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL AND OVERALL
COSTS FOR ALL THE SERVICES FOR
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS SERVED, AND
IT'S NOT ALIGNED WITH THE TOP
SERVICE THAT IS GIVEN SO WHEN I
SAY CONTROLLING FOR THOSE COSTS
WHAT I'M REALLY GETTING AT HIS
COUNTRY, COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES, SO WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE,
FOR INSTANCE, WHO LIVE IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE, THOSE SETTINGS
ARE VERY EXPENSIVE, AND WE KNOW
THAT, UM INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
FAMILIES OR CAREGIVERS THAT
THEIR COSTS ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE LOWER IN OUR SYSTEM, UM, IN
PART BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT PAYING
FOR AROUND THE CLOCK SUPPORTS
AND IN PART BECAUSE PEOPLE
LIVING IN HOME MAYBE GETTING
SOME OF THEIR SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FROM OUTSIDE OUR SYSTEM
LIKE I H S S WHERE THAT'S NOT
THE CASE FOR PEOPLE LIVING IN
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL CARE. SO
WHEN YOU BEGIN TO PEEL APART THE
DATA AND TO LOOK AT WHAT IS THE
REGIONAL CENTER SPENDING ON AN
AVERAGE PERSON OF SCHOOL AGE WHO
LIVES AT HOME WHO'S WHITE, AND
ONE WHO'S HISPANIC LATINO WHEN
YOU CAN WHEN YOU SAY LOOK AT THE
AGE GROUPING AND YOU LOOK AT THE
RESIDENTIAL SETTING. THEN IT
TELLS US THAT THERE IS ABOUT A
12% GAP IN SPENDING THERE.
INSTEAD OF THE NUMBER THAT'S
OFTEN USED IS A 50% DIFFERENCE
IN JUST THE AVERAGE PERSON WHO'S
WHITE VERSUS THE AVERAGE PERSON
WHO'S LATINO. WE KNOW THAT AGE
AND RESIDENTIAL SETTING PLAY A
TREMENDOUS ROLE IN SOME OF THOSE
ADDITIONAL COSTS. OKAY I
UNDERSTAND. NOW YOU GIVE A LOT
OF SUGGESTIONS ON SOME OF THE
THINGS WE SHOULD BE STRIVING
TOWARDS THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE EQUITABLE AND SO
FORTH. DO YOU ANTICIPATE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THE MASTER PLAN IS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING THAT I
CERTAINLY HOPE SO. I MEAN, IF
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING ISSUES OF
EQUITY THAN WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE KNOW THAT ONE OF THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF THE MASTER PLAN IS
TO HELP US FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SERVE PEOPLE WELL AND SERVE
PEOPLE EQUITABLY. AND I ALSO
ANTICIPATE AND HER DIRECTOR
BARTMAN SPEAKING THIS MORNING
THAT ONE OF THE GOALS IS ALSO TO
ADDRESS THE GENERIC SERVICES
ISSUE. SO THERE IS A LOT OF
OVERLAP BETWEEN THIS PANEL AND
THAT AND THEN PERHAPS FOR EITHER
OF YOU THE DEPARTMENT AND, UM,
YOU THE COLLABORATION. WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE? WHEN WE HAVE ONE
REGIONAL CENTER? PERHAPS FUNNY
LITTLE BEHIND IN MEETING X Y Z
LIKE HOW IS IT? JUST THE
DEPARTMENT COME INTO THAT
REGIONAL CENTER IS IN A SURE, I
THINK AT THE SIMPLISTIC LEVEL,
THE DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN THE
OPERATION OF REGIONAL CENTERS
OVER TIME, AND WHEN WE SEE
THINGS THAT MERIT ATTENTION
EITHER SUNSHINE THROUGH
OBSERVATIONS THAT BOARD MEETINGS
LOOKING AT PURCHASE OF SERVICE
DATA, WHICH WE GIVE THEM
ANNUALLY OR WHETHER WE'RE
LISTENING TO WHAT WE SEE COME
THROUGH A COMPLAINT OR DUE
PROCESS SYSTEM. THE FIRST STEP
IS ALWAYS A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT ELSE MIGHT BE GOING ON AND
THEN TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THAT REGIONAL CENTER. AND THAT
CAN TAKE DIFFERENT FORMS,
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE ISSUE IS
WHERE THAT COORDINATION NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. WE HAVE FAIRLY ROBUST
ALLOCATION OF STAFF TO LOOKING
AT REGIONAL CENTER OVERSIGHT
THAT WE CALL THEM. OUR REGIONAL
CENTER LIAISONS. AND THAT'S
GENERALLY THE INTERACTION THAT
THIS ASSOCIATION PLAY A PART IN
PREVENTING TA THERE. YES SO, UM,
WHAT I WANTED TO ADD? IS THAT AS
AN ASSOCIATION, WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF A SIGNIFICANT
CULTURAL TRANSFORMATION AND ONE
OF THE PIECES THAT WE ARE
UNDERGOING, IS BUILDING IN A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE STRUCTURE
SO THAT IT IS SO THAT CENTERS
ARE ENCOURAGED TO ACCESS IT IF
THEY ARE FOLLOWING BEHIND IN
CERTAIN AREAS, SO WE HAVE A
GROUP THAT IS WORKING TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR BOARD
ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME STANDARDS
THAT GO BEYOND STATUTE AND
REGULATION AND REGIONAL CENTER
CONTRACT THAT WE EXPECT AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS WILL ADHERE TO, AND WILL
RISE TO AND IS IT MORE REACTIVE,
THOUGH, OR DOES ASSOCIATION
HELPED POLICE OAN. I WOULDN'T
CALL IT POLICING AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S REACTIVE. I THINK
THAT AS AN ASSOCIATION WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD A VERY OPEN CULTURE
IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING ONE
ANOTHER. WHEN REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE RAISED THEIR HANDS AND
SAID, I'M STRUGGLING IN THIS
AREA, BUT I THINK THE QUESTION
THAT THIS ALLOWS US TO ANSWER IS
HOW TO BEST RESPOND IF WE SEE
SOMEONE FOLLOWING BEHIND, OR WE
HAVE CONCERNS AS AN ASSOCIATION
IF THE OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS,
UM WANT TO HELP BRING SOMEONE
ALONG, AND SO IT'S NOT INTENDED
TO BE REACTIVE, AND I'VE GOT TO
BE HONEST. IN THE YEARS I'VE
WORKED WITH THE 21 REGIONAL
CENTERS. I CAN TELL YOU WITH ALL
HONESTY THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM HAS POCKETS OF EXCELLENCE
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM. UM
YOU IS NOT AS STRONG AS SOME OF
THEIR PEERS AND OTHER AREAS, SO
PART OF THE ROLE OF THE
ASSOCIATION IS TO LEVERAGE THE
STRENGTH TO BRING OTHERS ALONG
AND THEN TO WRAP THOSE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING IN PARTICULAR
PRIORITY AREAS IN SUPPORT TO
HELP THEM COME ALONG. WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY IN BOTH DIRECTOR AND E D
HERE IS OUR PLAN BECAUSE WE CAN
WE CAN PASS THESE MANAGEMENT CAN
BE ON BOARD ASSOCIATIONS ON
BOARD. BUT THE RANK AND FILE UM
EACH REGIONAL CENTERS. WHAT DOES
THAT CAMPAIGN LOOK LIKE? AS
WE'RE LOOKING TO THE FIRST
THINGS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY OF NEXT
YEAR, BUT IS THAT CAMPAIGN LOOK
LIKE TO GET EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYEE OF EACH REGIONAL
CENTERS, THE ONES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE WORKING WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS. TO BE 100%
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF WHAT EXISTS.
WHAT TEMPLATE EXISTS IN THE NEW
PATH MOVING FORWARD. I'M GOING
TO TRY NOT TO GIVE YOU A KIND OF
TEXTBOOK POLICY ANSWER. BUT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS REALLY
HOW ARE WE GOING ABOUT CHANGE
MANAGEMENT AND ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT? WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT, DEFINING
WHAT WE'RE INTENDING TO
ACCOMPLISH. WHAT THE END GOAL.
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GIVING TIME TO
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
UPDATING THE IT SYSTEMS THAT
ENABLE THAT TO DO THAT TO HAPPEN
. WE'RE GIVING THEM TRAINING ON
HOW TO USE THAT I T SYSTEM TO DO
IT. WE'RE REMINDING THEM THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ENCOUNTER
WILL COME WITH DIFFERENT
STRENGTHS AND APTITUDES AND THAT
WE NEED TO APPROACH THAT. IN A
WAY THAT PEOPLE WILL UNDERSTAND.
AND SO THERE'S A NON IT TRAINING
COMPONENT TO THAT ABOUT HOW TO
INTERACT WITH PEOPLE I MENTIONED
, FOR EXAMPLE, CURRENTLY IN OUR
SYSTEM, WE ONLY ASK ABOUT GENDER
BEING MALE AND FEMALE. BUT
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT AND OR FOR
MINORS IN FRONT OF THEIR
PARENTS, FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE HOW
WE ASKED THAT, AND PARTICULARLY
IN DIFFERENT CULTURES COULD BE
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE. SO A LOT OF
TRAINING FOR SERVICE
COORDINATORS ABOUT HOW TO ASK
THAT WHEN TO ASK THAT WHEN NOT
TO ASK THAT. HOW TO DO IT
PUBLICLY OR PRIVATELY IN THE
COURSE OF THE CONVERSATION. UM
YOU KNOW, THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE. SO A LOT OF TRAINING
AND YOU KNOW, TO ECHO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE, MS WESTLING SAID
EARLIER LIKE THERE'S NO POINT IN
DOING SOMETHING IF YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW WELL YOU'RE DOING IT.
WHAT'S THE OUTCOME OF IT? SO
KNOWING FROM THE GET GO WHAT IS
SUCCESS LOOK LIKE AND WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO BE MEASURING IN
ORDER FOR OURSELVES TO GET
THERE? IS IT JUST THE
COMPLETENESS OF THE DATA FIELD
IN THE SYSTEM? IS THAT A SURVEY
OF THE FAMILIES ABOUT HOW THEY
FEEL AFTER THEY JUST WENT
THROUGH THE NEW IP PROCESS? WHAT
IS IT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MEASURE OR WHAT COMBINATION OF
THINGS ARE WE GOING TO MEASURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK DOING WELL, AND
WHERE THOSE SUPPORTS ARE NEEDED
THAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT PANEL LIST. UM JOINING US
FROM INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE ALLEANZA HOMBRES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SENATORS FELLOW
PANELISTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. MY NAME IS OSCAR
MERCADO. 21 YEAR OLD MEXICAN
AMERICAN WITH AUTISM SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM AND
PARTICIPATING MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE EARLY HOMBRES, I'M HERE
TODAY TO GIVE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ON MY EXPERIENCE AND WHY IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR SERVICES. AND
DIAGNOSIS TO BE ACCESSIBLE AND
ADDRESSABLE FOR ALL SPECIAL
NEEDS INDIVIDUALS PROVIDED AT
THE EARLIEST POINT IN THEIR
LIVES. AS A SMALL CHILD, I WOULD
DEMONSTRATE CERTAIN BEHAVIORS
THAT GAVE AN INDICATION OF BEING
ON THE SPECTRUM. MY PARENTS
DISCOVERED THAT I HAD AUTISM.
HOWEVER. THEY WERE AT A LOSS AS
TO SEEK WHERE TO SEEK
ASSISTANCE. THE REGIONAL CENTER
DIDN'T PROVIDE ANY GUIDANCE OR
SUPPORT AT THE TIME, LEAVING MY
PARENTS FEELING OVERWHELMED AND
DEFEATED. FOR REGRETTABLY, THIS
IS A NERVE. IT'D WE OFTEN HEAR
FROM MANY FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AND FEEL INTIMIDATED BY
THE SYSTEM. GROWING UP. I
RECEIVED NO EARLY INTERVENTIONS
SERVICES FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTER. WHICH PLUNGED ME INTO
SOME CHALLENGING TIMES. BUT MY
REAL TROUBLES WOULDN'T BEGIN
UNTIL I WENT TO SCHOOL. STARTING
IN KINDERGARTEN, MY CONDITION
STARTED BECOME MORE APPARENT TO
THE PEOPLE AROUND ME. TO MY
PARENTS AND EVEN TO MYSELF. THE
MOST RECOGNIZABLE TRAIT WAS MY
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING SOCIAL
CUES, WHICH WOULD LATER WORSEN
IN CAUSE A DRIFT BETWEEN MYSELF
AND MY PEERS. THE SECOND ISSUE
WAS THE ACADEMIC PORTION
TEACHERS WOULD GIVE A LECTURE.
AND AFTER SCHOOL, I WOULD
COMPLETELY FORGET ABOUT IT. AH
FORGET ABOUT THE LESSONS AND IT
MADE IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO ASSIMILATE. THE
INFORMATION GIVEN THUS LEADING
TO ME. HAVING A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME COMPLETING ASSIGNMENTS AND
STUDYING FOR EXAMS. AS IT WOULD
TAKE THE ENTIRE PORTION OF MY
AFTERNOON AND SOMETIMES EARLY
EVENINGS TO COMPLETE. THE THIRD
ISSUE WAS SENSORY RELATED
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING NOISES, I
COULD NOT STAND RALLIES, PEOPLE
SCREAMING. AND ESPECIALLY THE
MONTHLY REQUIRED FIRE DRILLS.
WHENEVER THOSE ALARMS WOULD GO
OFF, I WOULD ALWAYS ENTER IN THE
STATE OF PANIC AND COMPLETELY
SHUT DOWN. I WOULD HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER THE SITUATION
WHATSOEVER. ALL THESE ATTRIBUTES
LED TO MY PARENTS AND THE SCHOOL
TO THINK THAT I COULD MOST
LIKELY BE ON THE SPECTRUM. YEP
LIKE MANY OTHERS SIMILAR TO MY
SITUATION. THESE WERE NOT ENOUGH
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER FOR ME TO PASS THE
RIGOROUS INTAKE PROCESS. IN
NOVEMBER, 2012 MY PARENTS AND I
WENT TO THE MRC SEARCHING FOR
SUPPORT AND SERVICES BY ONLY GOT
A QUICK SCREENING AND THEY
DEEMED ME INELIGIBLE FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES,
LEAVING ME VULNERABLE. UM DUE TO
NOT KNOWING THE LAWS AND RIGHTS
I WAS ENTITLED TO UNDER THE FROM
THE SCHOOL AS A STUDENT. AND
UNDER THE PROGRAM. MY PARENTS
AND I WERE VICTIMS OF THE
CONSTANT BUREAUCRACY THAT
CONFUSED US FURTHER. THE
OVERWHELMING AND COMPLEX SYSTEM
MADE ME FEEL LIKE A FAILURE DUE
TO THE LACK OF SERVICES
ALONGSIDE MY PERSONAL ISSUES,
AND I WAS TO FACE THE DARKEST
TIMES OF MY LIFE ALONE WITH ONLY
GOD AND MY PARENTS AS THE ONLY
SOUL AND TRUSTWORTHY FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT TO RELY ON UPON
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL. MY
NEED FOR ASSISTANCE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY. CONSEQUENTLY MY
PARENTS ONCE AGAIN ATTEMPTED TO
GAIN SERVICES FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTER, AND I FINALLY BECAME A
CLIENT AT V M. R C RIGHT AFTER
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL, LOSING
ALL OF THE PREVIOUS YEARS THAT I
NEEDED SUPPORT. AS A CLIENT OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER. IT PAVED
THE WAY FOR THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. I STARTED
AT THE BEGINNING OF LAST
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR. AND IN
THIS SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME I HAVE
LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT BEING
INDEPENDENT HOW TO ENGAGE IN THE
SOCIAL WORLD AND EVERYTHING
REQUIRED FOR BEING AN
INDEPENDENT ADULT. I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THIS PROGRAM AS IT HAS GIVEN
ME HOPE AND PURPOSE. IF APPLIED
AS IT WAS ORIGINALLY MEANT FOR
IT CAN AND WILL IMPROVE LIVES.
WHAT I REALLY LIKE ABOUT THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM WAS
THE FACT THAT I FELT THAT I WAS
CARED FOR BY PEOPLE WHO WERE NOT
JUST MY PARENTS, AND THIS WAS
SOMETHING I DIDN'T SEE ANYWHERE
ELSE. REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
LAST YEAR'S SB 138 LET ME
ADDRESS THE INTAKE PROCESS.
THERE IS A GROWING CONCERN ABOUT
A SURGEON ELIGIBILITY DENIALS.
BECOMING A REGIONAL CENTER.
CONSUMER IS EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING AND TIME CONSUMING.
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ME. LOSE
PRECIOUS YEARS OF MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT. THE LEGISLATURE AIMS TO
STANDARDIZE THE INTAKE PROCESS
FOR MORE EQUITABLE TREATMENT.
STATEWIDE. HOWEVER. TODAY WE ARE
NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANS AND HOW
IT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED.
FURTHERMORE DENIAL OF
ELIGIBILITY DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
THOSE FROM LOWER INCOME
BACKGROUNDS. SOME FAMILIES
RESORT TOO COSTLY INDEPENDENT
EVALUATIONS TO QUALIFY FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES, A
LUXURY THAT MANY PEOPLE CANNOT
AFFORD. THESE DISPARITIES
UNDERSCORE THE RACIAL BIASES
ENTRENCHED WITHIN OUR SYSTEM,
PERPETUATING THE INEQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF SERVICES,
PARTICULARLY AMONG BLACK AND
BROWN CHILDREN. I LIKE I ALSO
LIKE TO DISCUSS GENERIC SERVICES
. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
LATINO FAMILIES ARE UNAWARE OF
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES, LET
ALONE GENERIC ALTERNATIVES.
REQUIRING FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE
GENERIC SERVICES FIRST OFTEN
RESULTS IN THEIR CHILD RECEIVING
NO SUPPORT AT ALL. REGIONAL
CENTER REGIONAL CENTERS MANDATE
THE USE OF THESE SERVICES
WITHOUT FACILITATING ACCESS,
LEAVING FAMILIES FEELING
STRANDED AND UNSUPPORTED. IT'S A
FRUSTRATING CYCLE WHERE IT FEELS
LIKE NOBODY'S ADVOCATING FOR US,
LEADING MANY TO LOSE HOPE AND
DISENGAGE. THIS IS WHY I SAY
WITH A SINCERE HEART. AS A SELF
ADVOCATE. I IMPLORE YOU ALL TO
PONDER ON THE WORD STATED TODAY
IN THIS HEARING AND HELP PROMOTE
A STATE OF EQUITY AND EQUALITY
BASED ON RESPECT AND TRUST, SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN THE HEALING
PROCESS. MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS
THE JOURNEY OF LIBERATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND GOD BLESS
YOU. OSCAR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING UP AND SHARING YOUR STORY
WITH US. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. OUR FINAL PANELISTS IS
GOING TO BE FROM ALSO INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM SHIRK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE IN P
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION. MY
NAME IS FERNANDO GOMEZ AND THE
FATHER OF A 17 YEAR OLD WITH
DOWN CENTERS SERVED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM. AND ALSO
OF 14 YEAR OLD WHO WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF SIMILAR TO WHAT OSCAR
SHARED TRYING TO HAVE THEM
BECOME A CLIENT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM. AND AS SKILLED AS
WE ARE IN OUR ADVOCACY. IT IS
OVERWHELMING, AND IT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY CHALLENGE. UM, AND IN
MHM. THIS CONVERSATION TODAY, UM
, ALSO CO FOUNDER OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE, WHICH WERE
PARENTS AND SELF ADVOCATES, WHO
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO HELP
UNITE. IN ADVOCACY, UNITED
EMPLOYEES AND UNITED EFFORT TO
TRY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ARE THESE
CHALLENGES AND TO YOUR POINT
MADAM SHARED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
CAN WE DO TODAY? IN MY TESTIMONY
, I WAS GOING TO REITERATE WHAT
YOU PROBABLY ALREADY HEARD IN
PREVIOUS TESTIMONIES, AND YOU'VE
DEFINITELY READ IT. IN MANY OF
THE REPORTS ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT DESPITE THEIR CLASSES,
DISPARITIES AND THAT THEY WERE
WITH THE BARRIERS IN THE
ROADBLOCKS, UM EARLIER IN THE
EARLIER PANEL, UM SENATOR EDMUND
ASKED JUDY AND REALLY
INTERESTING QUESTION. GIVEN THE
ABILITY TO KNOW THAT EVERYTHING
GOT RESOLVED ITSELF FOURTH. WHEN
WOULD SHE KNOW THAT YOU'RE
THERE? AND IT WASN'T REALLY A
GREAT QUESTION AND REALLY,
PROBABLY THE ONLY TIME I'VE SEEN
JUDY TONGUE TIED, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT EASY TO DO SO KUDOS TO
SENATOR EDMUND. EVEN THOUGH HER
HER ANSWER WAS ON POINT. ENJOY
HAPPINESS. RELEASE. UM. THAT?
YES. THE ANSWER FOR SOMEONE LIKE
ME, DAD. HAD JUST THANK YOU. I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH TIME I HAVE.
I SEE OSCAR AND I LOOK BACK AND
LOOK AT OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS ROOM. YOU WE COUNT AFFORD
TO WAIT. FOR A MAGICAL MOMENT
WHEN MAYBE A MASTER PLAN MAY
BECOME A REALITY. WE'VE HEARD
THAT BEFORE. NOT TOO LONG AGO.
GEORGETOWN WAS SORRY, SHINING
STAR. TODAY IS THE MASTER PLAN
AND WE EMBRACE IT AND WE WERE
GOING TO GIVE IT EVERYTHING WE
HAVE TO TRY TO MAKE IT WORK. AND
WE PRAY TO GOD THAT IT DOES
WORK. BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
TIME WE HAVE, BECAUSE THE
REALITY IS TODAY. ASK YOU JUST
SHARED THAT IT TOOK HIM A WHOLE
LIFETIME. IT WAS UNTIL HIGH
SCHOOL. WHEN THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM STEPPED UP TO SUPPORT
WHAT HE NEEDED FROM THE GET GO,
AND HIS STORY IS NOT THE ONLY
ONE. TODAY WE SEE A ROOM FULL OF
INDIVIDUALS. MANY OF THEM DON'T
EVEN SPEAK ENGLISH. OKAY TO BE
HERE. THEY KNOW THAT WE TAKE
YOUR LIFE VIDEO FEED, PUT IT
INTO A ZOOM AND ARE DOING
SIMULTANEOUS TRANSLATION IN
SPANISH RIGHT NOW FOR SEVERAL
100 PEOPLE WHO WANT TO KNOW WHAT
CAN WE DO TODAY? HMM. THE
QUESTION IS, THERE'S A LOT I
JUST, YOU KNOW, AMY JUST SHARED
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
SOMEONE LIVING AT HOME. AS THEY
SHOULD BE WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND BEING SUPPORTED BY THE ONE
PEOPLE WHO CARE FOR THEM. HAVING
LESS SERVICES THAN THE ONES WHO
DON'T AND WE KNOW THAT OVER 42.
THE INDIVIDUAL SERVED FOR WITHIN
THAT AGE GROUP OF PEOPLE LIVING
AT HOME. BUT WHY ARE WE
PENALIZED? WHY DO WE HAVE TO
WORK HARDER AND BE MORE
CHALLENGED TO DO WHAT'S REALLY
THE RIGHT THING. SO MY TESTIMONY
TODAY I WANTED TO ALLUDE TO
SEVERAL THINGS IS THE REALITY OF
WHAT CAN HAPPEN TODAY. DARK
DIRECTOR. BARTMAN HAS EMBRACED
US FROM THE GET GO. SHE'S
EMPOWERED AT AN ORGANIZATION
LIKE THE SEC TO BECOME WHAT IT
IS TODAY. AND WE KNOW THAT OUR
HEARTS IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND
SHE USES DATA AND SHE USES
FEEDBACK. BUT IN REALITY THAT
THE RESOURCE IS WITHIN US.
WITHIN OSCAR WITHIN MYSELF
WITHIN THE OTHERS AND EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM. DON'T JUST RELY ON
DATA RELY ON THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S HERE TODAY, SAYING, I WANT
TO BE PART OF THE SYSTEM. I WANT
TO HELP. THE SYSTEM HELPED ME
BECAUSE IT IS OUR SYSTEM. AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHERE THE
BATTLEGROUND AS WE SEE THAT IT'S
AT THE SERVICE COORDINATION
LEVEL. WE WERE IN RECOGNIZE THE
IMMENSE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACED OR SERVICE COORDINATORS,
AND THEY HAVE TO NOT ONLY
NAVIGATE, YOU KNOW POLICIES, BUT
THEY HAVE TO ADHERE TO THE
SYSTEM DIRECTIVES AND THEY
MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE WHILE
STRIVING TO BEAT PERSON
CENTERED. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
REALLY CAUGHT BETWEEN A ROCK AND
A HARD PLACE SERVICE
COORDINATION IN THIS SYSTEM. IT
IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE. THERE'S
SOME AMAZING PEOPLE. UM BUT I DO
WANT TO SHARE A SITUATION THAT
JUST RECENTLY CAME CAME ABOUT,
UM IT'S IMPORTANT TO INCREASE
SERVICES SERVICE COORDINATION
NUMBERS, REDUCING THE CASE ROSE
RATIOS. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS CAN
BE BENEFICIAL. BUT IT'S EVIDENT
THAT THE SERVICE DELIVERY
PROCESS STILL FALLS SHORT OF
MEETING THE NEEDS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF THE COMMUNITY
THAT IT SERVES. THIS IS CONNECT
HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED ANY RECENT
REGIONAL CENTER BOARD MEETING
DOZENS OF SERVICE COORDINATORS
EXPRESSED THEIR UNHAPPINESS WITH
THEIR CASE LOST IN PAY. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, THEIR CRITICISM
DID NOT STOP THERE, AND MANY OF
THEM TURNED THEIR ANGER TO
CONSUMERS AND PARENTS. ONE
SERVICE COORDINATOR CANDIDLY
SHARED VIA THE CHAT, AND I QUOTE
I RECENTLY HAD TO GO ON
ANTIDEPRESSANTS DUE TO THE
CONSTANT STRESS AND INTIMIDATION
TACTICS THAT ARE USED BY PARENTS
AND ADVOCATES TO GET THEIR POINT
ACROSS AND WHY THEY NEED
SERVICES. WHO CARES ABOUT MY
NEEDS? WHO PROVIDES ME WITH
RESPITE? ATTENDANT CARE, DAY
CARE OR SOCIAL WRECK. QUOTE.
THIS STATEMENT WAS QUICKLY
FOLLOWED BY ANOTHER COMMENT THAT
WAS SAID SERVICE COORDINATED
LIFE'S MATTERS. WELL THESE
CANADA AND POLARIZING STATEMENTS
OFF A RARE INSIGHT INTO THE
MINDSET OF SOME. NOT ALL BUT
SOME SEVERAS COORDINATORS. AND
THE REALITY FACED BY FAMILIES.
THAT IS WHERE THE BATTLE IS.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO PUT
FOCUS AND ATTENTION. AND I CAN
SEE WHERE THE SERVICE
COORDINATORS ARE COMING FROM. I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY SEE WHERE
WE'RE COMING FROM. BUT THIS
ISN'T A LADDER MAN ACTORS
ENTITLEMENT SYSTEM. AND SOMEHOW
OR ANOTHER, WE GOT TO FIGURE IT
OUT. AND I CAN HONESTLY SAY AS A
FATHER. AND ONLY GOD KNOWS HOW
MUCH MORE TIME I HAVE. WE GOT TO
GET IT RIGHT? WE GOTTA GET IT
RIGHT. AND I DO APOLOGIZE IF I'M
GOING OVER TIME, BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON 138 IF I STILL HAVE
A COUPLE MORE MINUTES. UM THE
OTHER CATEGORY AND RAISE IT IN
THE CITY AND THE LANGUAGE DATA.
I KNOW THE DDS HAS STARTED THEIR
EFFORTS. UM AND BEING ONE OF THE
KEY CATALYSTS IN INTRODUCING
THIS LANGUAGE. WE WERE HOPING
THAT WERE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. WE HAVEN'T HAD
THAT YET, BUT WE'RE HOPING THAT
WE WILL BE BECAUSE THE OTHER
CATEGORY AT 14% IN MANY CASES,
IS THE THIRD LARGEST GROUP
SERVED BY A REGIONAL CENTER. BUT
I MEAN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
VERY FAR. YOU LOOK AT INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER. THAT'S THAT 29.
MR DIRECTOR CROSS WAS HERE
EARLIER FROM SAN DIEGO. HIS
OTHER CATEGORIES THAT 20% THE
REASON THAT THIS MATTERS IS
BECAUSE I'M THE FIRST FIRM
BELIEF THAT THE OTHER CATEGORY
IS COMPRESSED MOSTLY OF LATINOS,
AND THEY ARE EVEN RECEIVING LESS
SERVICES THAN THE LATINOS. AND
WE KNOW ALREADY HOW MANY HAVE
WHITE THAT THE GAP IS. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS THAT I
BELIEVE THAT ATTRIBUTED TO THAT,
UM IT'S CONFUSING. HOW DO YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF BECAUSE I'M
NOT REALLY WHITE. BUT I'M NOT
EITHER TIPS BECAUSE WE ARE VERY
DIVERSE. WE KNOW THAT FOR A FACT
BUT TO IDENTIFY MYSELF EITHER
WHITE OR BLACK AS A RACE AND
THEN DEFINING ETHNICITY IS VERY
HARD FOR MANY PEOPLE TO REALLY
TRULY UNDERSTAND IT, SO THEY
JUST KIND OF MANY CASES.
DEFERRED TO OTHER MR GOMEZ. JUST
FINAL THOUGHTS. YES, MY FINAL
THOUGHT IS, IS THAT, UM I WOULD
HOPE THAT IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
GOING PLACE THAT WAS VALUABLE
RESOURCE THAT THE SYSTEM HAS
AVAILABLE ARE THE VERY
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SERVED BY
THE SYSTEM AND THE PARENTS AND
THAT WE WOULD BE PART OF THAT.
ONLY THE ABILITY TO SIT AROUND
THE TABLE. BUT PEOPLE ARE THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH, HMM.
YOU KNOW THE SECOND YOU'RE DOING
THIS. LAST YEAR. I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW THIS MEETING WAS GOING TO GO
RIGHT LAST YEAR. UM IT WAS A BIG
SHOCK TO MY SYSTEM. THIS YEAR. I
KNEW COMING IN. I THINK I THINK
TODAY. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
NOTICE IT WAS LATER THAN USUAL
TO SHOW UP. UM, BECAUSE IT WAS
HONEST, SCARED. I WAS SCARED,
SCARED OF THE FEELINGS, HEARING
THE STORIES AND SO FORTH STORIES
THAT I KNEW FROM LAST YEAR,
RIGHT? I WILL SAY, THOUGH, SINCE
LAST YEAR, AT LEAST ON PAPER
WITH MOVED FORWARD ON PAPER.
SINCE LAST YEAR. YOU KNOW WE
COULD BE WE PASSED IN THE BUDGET
ACT THIS PORTION SINCE LAST YEAR
WE HAD THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN. UM WITH HOPE. LIKE
YOU SAID, MR GÓMEZ WITH HOPE. UM
SO I CAN SAY THAT. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD, BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
FORGOT IF IT WAS YOU, UM OSCAR
MR GOMEZ, WHO SAID IT IS UNTIL I
NO LONGER HEAR STORIES FROM SELF
ADVOCATES OR FAMILY MEMBERS.
FIRST IN THIS CASE THAT IS NOT
GOING TO DO IT. I THINK WE CAN
HAVE ALL THE DATA IN THE WORLD.
BUT IF WE CONTINUE TO HEAR
STORIES FROM UM, CLIENTS OR
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SO FORTH
THAT THIS IS STILL HAPPENING,
THEN IT'S STILL HAPPENING
BECAUSE THAT I CAN ALWAYS BE
SKEWED SOMETIMES, AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO CAPTURE EVERY SINGLE
PERSON, RIGHT. UM, I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN THAT'S GOING TO. WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO THAT POINT.
OKAY, UM GRINDING MY TEETH OVER
HERE. MR GOMEZ AND I GET SUPER
EMOTIONAL DURING YOUR STORING IN
YOU, TOO, AS WELL. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, I SHARED MY NIECE NEXT
WEEK, TURNS FOUR AND THEY JUST
STARTED THEIR SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM FOR THE FIRST TIME. AND
THEY ARE SO LOST. THEY'RE SO
CONFUSED IN THAT PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW, AND I HAVE A BILL ON THIS
PROGRAM THIS YEAR AND I WHAT DO
I CAN'T EVEN OFFER ANY SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW YOU SURE THAT EVEN AS
AN ADVOCATE, YOU'RE NAVIGATING
THAT WITH YOUR 14, YEAR OLD AND
STILL HITTING BARRIERS, THE
SENATOR AND I'M STILL HITTING
BARRIERS WITH MY NIECE AND MY
SISTER IN NAVIGATING THIS
PROCESS AS WELL. UM THIS IS SO
PERSONAL, AND IT'S SO
FRUSTRATING TO HEAR AND I KNOW
NO ONE HERE IS UP HERE TO CREATE
BARRIERS. YOU KNOW, WE MY HOPE.
LOOKING TO COLLABORATE AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OSCAR DOESN'T HAVE TO COME UP
HERE ANYMORE. INSURE HIS STORY
REGARD REGARDING YOUR
EXPERIENCE, RIGHT? THAT IS THE
END GOAL. BUT WHEN I HEAR
STORIES ABOUT WHAT SOMEBODY WHEN
SOMEBODY SHARES THEIR INTERNAL
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT THAT POPULATION
IS WHY I ASKED YOU IS WHAT
CAMPAIGN ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO
REALLY TRAIN THEIR INK AND FIVE
OF THESE REGIONAL CENTERS?
BECAUSE AMY CAN BE THE MOST
PERFECT E D OF THIS ASSOCIATION?
BUT HOW IS THAT GOING TO TRICKLE
DOWN TO EVERY SINGLE PERSON,
RIGHT? DOESN'T MATTER. IF WE
TRAIN OUR MANAGEMENT LEVEL. IT'S
EVERY SINGLE CASE WORKERS. EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IS GOING TO BE AT
THE FRONT LINE. I THINK MORE
IMPORTANT THAN TRAINING R E. D S
TALKING TO OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND
SO FORTH. THAT'S THE PART OF
THEM WORRIED ABOUT IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOW THAT
PERSON SO I THINK ABOUT
EMPLOYEES AND OUR RIGHTS.
THEY'RE PLASTERED AGAINST THE
WALLS, RIGHT? WHAT DO WE LOOKING
AT? AND WHEN SOMEONE WALKS INTO
A REGIONAL CENTER THAT SHOWS
OTHER RIGHTS? THIS IS HOW YOU'RE
INTO. YOU KNOW ME THAT PROBABLY
BE WHOLE. SLEW OF SHEETS, BUT
JUST HOW VISIBLE ARE WE ABOUT
WHAT THE RIGHTS ARE OF EVERYBODY
THAT GOES INTO A REGIONAL
CENTER. THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
UTILIZE ANY OTHER SERVICE TO GET
SOCIAL WRECK THAT'S ON TOP OF
WHATEVER YOU'RE ALREADY GETTING
LIKE THIS. EVERYBODY WALKING IN
THROUGH THE REGIONAL CENTER, SEE
THAT AND DO THE EMPLOYEES SEE
THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY? THAT'S
WHY I WANT TO KNOW MORE AS TO
HOW WE'RE REALLY GOING TO MAKE
SURE THIS CAMPAIGN WORKS AND
EVERYONE KNOWS ABOUT IT. THIS IS
REALLY EARLY ON IN THE GAME.
THIS PANEL REGARDING OUR
IMPLEMENTATION RIGHT IN JUNE
30TH. WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE FIRST TWO. I
DO WANT TO KNOW AND REITERATE,
TRAINED, BE INVOLVEMENT. WE
HEARD FROM A PREVIOUS PANEL. YES
WE HAVE ONE STAKEHOLDER WHO'S
WHO'S A SELF ADVOCATE ON THE
MASTER PLAN? WHO'S LATINO? I
MEAN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT PUBLIC
COMMENTS GOING TO LOOK LIKE THIS
YEAR, BUT LAST YEAR IT WAS
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKERS
THAT CAME UP TO SHARE. THE
CONSISTENT BARRIERS HAVE
FORESEEN THAT THAT'S THE
CONSISTENT DEMOGRAPHIC, AND
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THERE IS
EMBARRASSED FOR OTHER ONES, BUT
IT SEEMS THAT IT COMES UP A LOT,
THEN WE SHOULD HAVE MORE OF THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC BE REPRESENTED OR
REALLY FOCUSED WHEN WE DO OUR
ROUNDTABLES AND STAKEHOLDERS AND
SO FORTH. THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS HAVE DIVED INTO THIS
TOPIC I'VE HAD MEETINGS WITH
YOU, MR GOMEZ AND OVER 300
PEOPLE, ONE ZOOMS MORE THAN ONCE
. I'VE LISTENED IN, UM FROM
MONOLINGUAL SPEAKERS TO SHARE
THEIR CONSTANT BARRIERS. WATCH
THE VIDEO, AND THIS IS PROBABLY
JUST A PERSONAL EGG OF THE
ORIENTATION YOU NEED TO DO TO
START SDP. IT'S NOT EVEN A
NATIVE SPANISH SPEAKER. THAT'S
WHAT ME OFF EVEN MORE. THE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS EVEN WHEN YOU
GET SOMEONE, IT'S NOT EVEN
UNAIDED. SPANISH SPEAKER OKAY,
THE WORD I WOULD NEVER WANT TO
SIGN UP TO TRANSLATE SOMETHING
IN SPANISH. EVEN THOUGH I SPEAK
SPANISH. I WOULD NEVER BE ABLE
TO DO IT. JUSTICE. I WOULD HAVE
ONE. SOMEONE WHO IS TRUE SPANISH
SPEAKER TO BE THE ONE TO GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS AND SOME THINGS ARE
SO TECHNICAL. SO EVEN THAT SMALL
PIECE I FEEL LIKE THAT'S AN EASY
FIX. TO SHOW THE RESPECT WE HAVE
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
LANGUAGE IS ADEQUATELY BEING
TRANSLATED SO THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND IT ADEQUATELY. MR
GÓMEZ. OUTSIDE OF THIS RANT, I
DO HAVE A QUESTION. UM YOU KIND
OF STARTED TALKING ABOUT IT, BUT
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU A
DIFFERENT VERSION OF WHAT
SENATOR EGGMAN ASKED MS JUDY,
WHAT IS EQUITABLE TO YOU?
BECAUSE AMY'S ASKED, UM MS
WESLEY AND I APOLOGIZE. MISS
WRESTLING? ASKED, UM TO DEFINE
WHAT IS EQUITABLE. HOW WOULD WE
DEFINE ECO EQUITABLE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ELIGIBLE MEASURES
IF I CAN BRIEFLY USE AN EXAMPLE
WHEN I FIRST STARTED MY ADVOCACY
JOURNEY? UM BECAUSE OF MY SON
THE REGIONAL CENTER. THAT WAS MY
CATCHMENT AREA. THE DIRECTOR. UM
AT THAT POINT, WE BELIEVED IN
MANY OTHERS AS WELL, WAS THAT
THAT CENTER WAS THE LEADER IN
THIS SPACE. AND WHAT MADE IT A
LEADER WAS BECAUSE OF THE
DIRECTORS MINDSET. IN OTHER
WORDS, LET'S FIND A SOLUTION.
FOR WHAT THE NEED IS, AND THEN
WE'LL FIND HOW TO JUSTIFY IT.
AND THAT TYPE OF SERVICE
DELIVERY. YOU KNOW WAS REALLY
WHAT I BELIEVE WAS EQUITABLE
BECAUSE YOU FEEL RESPECTED. YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU CAN TRUST THE
SYSTEM MANY TIMES IF I OPEN UP
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EMOTIONAL
SITUATION, WE WERE HERE. WE'RE
DEALING WITH LIVES AND WHEN WE
WERE LOOKING TO GET TO THAT
EQUITABLE SPACE WHERE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT ACCESS TO SERVICES.
THAT'S JUST THE VERY BEGINNING.
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE TO LOOK AT
SAFETY. YOU HEARD ABOUT THOSE
YOUNG CHILD WHO'S I'M NOT GOING
TO GO THERE, BUT WELL, THEY'RE
STILL OTHER THINGS. MOUNTAINS
DECLINE. WE HAVE A LONG WAYS TO
GO, BUT THIS IS OUR SYSTEM AND
EQUITY EQUITY MEANS THAT WE'RE
IN BRACED. WE'RE NOT HAVING TO
FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL IN ORDER
JUST TO GET WHAT IS RIGHT. AND
NOW AND NOT SHARE WITH YOU THAT
FOR MY SON IN TRYING TO GET HIM
THE SERVICES THAT WE KNOW THEY
NEED AND THE PERSON THAT ACROSS
THE TABLE FROM ME AT THE CENTER
KNOWS THAT HE NEEDS THEM. BUT I
CAN'T GIVE THEM TO YOU. BECAUSE
THE SYSTEM DOES NOT ALLOW ME TO
BASED ON THE CRITERIA. SO THAT
IS THE ISSUES. THE CHALLENGE IS
THAT WHEN WE CAN FIGURE THAT
OUT, THEN WE'RE WE'RE EQUITY
MEANS I'M NOT SAYING THAT WE GET
YES ON EVERYTHING AND THAT WE
SHOULDN'T WE JUST SHOULD GET
WHAT WE NEED AND IT IS TO MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE. THAT'S IT. MS
WESLEY AND I KNOW YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION. BUT DO YOU HAVE A
DEFINITION OF YOUR OWN? I THINK
MY DEFINITION PROBABLY IS NOT
THAT DIFFERENT FROM MR GOMEZ IS,
I THINK EQUITY MEANS MEETING THE
NEEDS OF EACH PERSON WE SERVE IN
A WAY THAT IS RESPONSIVE TO
THEIR OWN NEEDS AND THAT OUR
SERVICES ARE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO TELL
PEOPLE. I KNOW YOUR CHILD NEEDS
IT. BUT I CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE A
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE KIND OF
BALANCES THAT OUR SYSTEM HAS
WALKED OVER TIME. WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE GREATER LEVELS OF
CONSISTENCY, BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
ENSURE THAT ON THE INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL, WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO TAILOR SERVICES TO MEET
INDIVIDUAL. YOU'LL NEED AND SO
WHETHER THAT MEANS WE NEED TO
SUPPORT UM, FAMILIES IN MORE
CREATIVE WAYS. THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE STRIVE TO MAINTAIN.
YOU KNOW, HONESTY IN OUR SYSTEM
IS THE ABILITY TO STRING
TOGETHER SERVICES IN A WAY
THAT'S GOING TO BE MOST
RESPONSIVE TO EACH INDIVIDUAL'S
NEED. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
REGULATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW ABOUT FUNDING AND ABOUT
THE STRUCTURE OF SERVICES, BUT
REALLY AT THE PLANNING TEAM
LEVEL, THERE'S THAT ABILITY TO
BE CREATIVE TO PUT THINGS
TOGETHER TO MEET THE NEED, AND
THAT'S THAT'S MY VISION OF
EQUITY. UM AND YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT OUR SYSTEM IN THE LAST YEAR
HAS ADDED OVER 1000 SERVICE
COORDINATORS. MEANS THAT WE ARE
GETTING TO A PLACE. WHERE
SERVICE COORDINATORS WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SPEND WITH
PEOPLE NOT ONLY TO EXPLORE THE
NEEDS THROUGH THE CONSISTENT
PROCESS, BUT ALSO TO THINK
THROUGH IN IN A MORE FLEXIBLE
WAY. HOW DO WE IDENTIFY THE NEED
AND THEN SAY, AND WHAT'S OUR
ROLE IN MEETING IT? I'M GONNA
ALLOW SOME FINAL THOUGHTS FROM
ANY PANELISTS. IF I COULD JUST
BRIEFLY, UM, RESEARCH FOUND THAT
THAT THAT THAT I BELIEVE THAT IN
AN IDEAL WORLD, I WOULD THINK
WOW, AWESOME. REALITY AND YOU
PROBABLY HEAR A LOT OF THIS IN
SOME OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS IS
NOW WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY? AND
IF YOU EVEN GO BACK TO THE
SERVICE COORDINATOR FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO TOLD OSCAR THAT
HE DIDN'T QUALIFY? AND LATER ON
IN LIFE. WE KNOW THAT HE SHOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED AT THAT TIME AND
YOU ASK THEM. WHY NOT? THE ONLY
THING THAT THIS COORDINATOR IS
GOING TO SAY OR THIS INDIVIDUALS
GOING TO SAY, I'M SORRY. AND
THAT'S IT. AND I'M SORRY, IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ENOUGH FOR A
WHOLE LIFETIME. AND IT DOESN'T
CUT IT. IT'S NOT. IT'S I'M
SORRY. IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH. AND
I'M NOT. YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE
WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY. BUT
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE HAS TO BE BECAUSE IF WHAT
AMY JUST SAID, WAS MORE OF A
REALITY. I WOULD I WOULD BE
SITTING HERE WITH A WHOLE
DIFFERENT MINDSET. BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT I'LL BE VERY QUICK WITH
THIS, UM I WANT TO CLARIFY ON
THE EQUITY ISSUES SINCE THAT IS
THE ISSUE ON THE FLOOR RIGHT
NOW, TODAY WILL BE VERY BASIC
WITH HIM. WE'RE ALL EQUAL AS
HUMAN BEINGS. WE CAN CONFIRM
THAT LOOK AROUND EACH OTHER. YOU
CAN SEE THROUGH YOUR RIGHT TO
YOUR LEFT. WE'RE HUMAN. BUT OUR
NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT. YOUR NEEDS
ARE DIFFERENT. MY NEEDS ARE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE HERE. THE
PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME.
EVERYONE HAS DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS, DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES, AND I'M NOT GOING
TO GET TOO TECHNICAL ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I'M NOT TOO
KNOWLEDGEABLE ON WHAT'S GOING
ON. BUT THE BASIC ESSENCE HERE
IS THAT ALL PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S
PEOPLE WITH SOME SORT OF
DISABILITY OR NOT? HAVE THEIR
OWN. AH NEEDS TO LOOK FOR TO
LOOK TO AND I WOULD APPEAL THIS
TO EVERYONE, UM THAT ESPECIALLY
NOW FOR THE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
MOST NEED OF THE SERVICES THAT
THERE NEEDS SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
JUST AS THE NEEDS OF THE COMMON
FOLK ARE ALSO ADDRESSED. SO FOR
ME, MY VISION OF EQUITY IS
SIMPLE. WE'RE ALL EQUAL AS HUMAN
BEINGS. BUT OUR NEEDS ARE
DIFFERENT. AND THAT SHOULD ALSO
BE ADDRESSED AND SHOULD BE
THOUGHT ABOUT I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO STANDARDIZE
TEMPLATES AND ALL THAT. THAT
SHOULD BE THE ONLY THING WE
STANDARDIZE RIGHT? AND THEN WHEN
WE PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL, IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL
PLAN FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON
BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT. WE ALL
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE UTILIZING A
TEMPLATE FOR THE SERVICES THAT
WE GIVE RIGHT. MHM. ANYONE ELSE
IF NOT RETURN TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR FINAL MISS WESTLING?
YEAH AND I APOLOGIZE. I KEEP
PLAYING OFF MR GÓMEZ, BUT, UM,
YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MR GOMEZ SAID, IS
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE IMPERFECT
AND MAKE THE WRONG DECISION THAN
WHAT THEY'RE LEFT WITH IS JUST
I'M SORRY. BUT THERE ARE SOME OF
US WHO HAVE THE HONOR OF HAVING
POSITIONS LIKE THIS WHERE WE GET
TO HELP BE A PART OF SHAPING
POLICY. UM AND SO YOU KNOW THE
ROLE. CERTAINLY THAT YOU PLAY
SENATOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE WHO
WILL BE SERVING ON THE MASTER
PLAN WORKGROUP. HAVE A WAY TO
THEN SAY BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
HERE'S CHANGES. I SUGGEST WE
MAKE TO THE SYSTEM SO OSCAR BY
UM, SORRY TO HEAR WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOU, BUT KNOW THAT CASES LIKE
YOURS ARE WHAT LEAD US.
COLLECTIVELY TO A PLACE WHERE WE
NOW HAVE AN ELIGIBILITY CATEGORY
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS KNOWN AS
PROVISIONAL ELIGIBILITY, SO THAT
AT AGE FOR OUR KIDS WHO ARE
BETWEEN THREE AND THEIR FIFTH
BIRTHDAY, WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HANG ON TO THOSE KIDS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. AND
THE IMPETUS FOR THAT WAS KIDS
LIKE YOU KIDS WHO IT BROKE OUR
HEARTS AT AGE THREE TO TURN THEM
AWAY, BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE. AND SO THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS THEN GIVE US THE
POWER TO MAKE POLICY CHANGE AND
TO MAKE IT BETTER FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. IT DOESN'T FIX IT
FOR YOU, BUT KNOW THAT THOSE
THINGS THEN DO SHAPE PUBLIC
POLICY. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. CHRIS O'DONNELL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND SHARING YOUR
STORIES AND NO FURTHER COMMENTS
FOR THIS PANEL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
WE'RE NOT MOVING INTO ISSUE FOR
WHERE WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
RATE REFORM DELAY.
PORTS.
DON'T WORRY. THIS PANEL WILL BE
HAVING A CONVERSATION DISCUSSING
THE DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL OF ONE YEAR
DELAY OF THE FINAL PHASE OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDER RATE REFORM.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH. WE'RE
GOING TO START FIRST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHO WILL
THEN TAG TEAM, THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IN OUR
PRESENT INITIALLY ON THE
PROPOSED SUMMARIZING THE
PROPOSAL ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND THEN PASS IT
TO MY COLLEAGUE, CARLOS
CASTANEDA WITH THE PERMANENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR OTHER
UPDATES IN DISCUSSION. THE
PROPOSAL YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS DRIVEN BY THE GENERAL
FUND SITUATION AND IS ONE OF A
NUMBER OF APPROACHES INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INTENDED
TO HELP ADDRESS THE OVERALL
FUNDING SHORTFALL IN THE
UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR. THE
OUTLINED APPROACH WOULD RETURN
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF DDS OR
RISK PROVIDER RATE REFORM TO THE
ORIGINAL TIMELINE ADOPTED
THROUGH THE 2021 BUDGET ACT.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT THE NEXT
ROUND OF RATE ADJUSTMENTS AND
ASSOCIATED FUNDING FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS SCHEDULED TO OCCUR ON
JULY 1ST 2024 INSTEAD INSTEAD
TAKE EFFECT. JULY 1ST 2025. THIS
APPROACH MAINTAINS RATES AT
THEIR CURRENT LEVELS THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR 2425 AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR THE QUALITY
INCENTIVES PROGRAM WHILE WE
CONTINUE FORWARD AND ACHIEVING
FORWARD REFORM FROM HERE, I'LL
PAST CHIEF DEPUTY KESSINGER
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR CARLA CÁC
YELLOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IN THE
NEXT QUESTION IN THE AGENDA IS
ASKING ABOUT POTENTIAL IMPACTS
OF THE DELAY ON THE WORKFORCE
CAPACITY AND ACCESS GIVEN THE
LENGTH OF THE WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE COVID
PANDEMIC. IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY
THAT SPECIFIC IMPACT, ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION, BEING A TWO
COMPONENT RATE MODEL, INCLUDING
UP TO 10% FOR QUALITY INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. WHAT WE DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT, THOUGH, ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL INITIATIVES AND I
THINK I HEARD ONE REFERENCED
EARLIER, BUT SOME ADDITIONAL
DIRECT SUPPORTS FOR WORKFORCE IS
THE TRAINING STIPENDS. THEY ARE
PROVIDING UP TO TWO TRAININGS
FOR DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
TO DATE ABOUT 52,000
PARTICIPANTS HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE TRAINING ALMOST 45,000 HAVE
COMPLETED THE TWO SETS OF
TRAINING. THERE IS THE INITIAL
PHASE OF THE INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
THAT AGAIN WOULD BE HELPING THE
PROVIDERS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT WOULD BE ABOUT 2500
PARTICIPANTS. AND THE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS. UM WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL ONGOING PROGRAMS FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS IN
PROGRESS IS THE DSP WORK FIRST
TRAINING PROGRAM AS WELL, WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE A TIERED WAGE
INCREASE UPON COMPLETION OF
CURRICULUM, AS WELL AS A
BILINGUAL STIPEND, I THINK WAS
ALSO MENTIONED EARLIER FOR
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
SPEAKING MORE THAN ONE I'M
SORRY. I THOUGHT I ANTICIPATED A
QUESTION FOR THE NEXT QUESTION
IN THE AGENDA, LOOKING AT THE
DELAY AND IN THE RATE REFORM AND
THE QUALITY IMPACT ON QUALITY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM, UM, AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES 137.5
MILLION TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM
WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING
AS THE CURRENT YEAR AS THE
PROGRAM HAS CONTINUED TO EVOLVE.
WE HAVE MODIFIED THE MEASURES
AND SO, FOR EXAMPLE, SOME OF THE
WELLNESS INITIATIVES HAVE LOOKED
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL SETTINGS
AND ITS EXPENDITURE INCLUDE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES, AS
WELL AS THE CURRENT PROVIDER.
DIRECTORY EFFORTS WILL WILL
CONTINUE. THIS PROVIDED
DIRECTORY IS ONE OF PROBABLY
MULTIPLE STEPS TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
DOES GET US TOWARDS MOVING TO
MEASURING INDIVIDUAL OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU. CHIEF DEPUTY BEFORE I
MOVE ON TO THE OTHER PANELISTS
NUMBER TWO. I REALLY THINK WE
JUST FLEW BY THAT, UM, LET'S
HAVE A LITTLE DEEPER INTO HOW
THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
WORKFORCE CAPACITY BECAUSE YOU
SPOKE ABOUT A STIPEND? IT'S A
ONE TIME THING. THESE ARE
PERMANENT, UM, RATE REFORMS, SO
I DON'T THINK WE CAN COMPARE
APPLES. YOU KNOW THEM SAYING
THAT THIS IS GONNA HELP. SURE
THE DELAY IN THE RATE MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION, SO THE CURRENT
LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT GOT THE
ADDITIONAL 25% INCREMENT THAT
INCLUDED LANGUAGE IN STATUTE
THAT SPECIFY THE MAJORITY OF
THAT RATE ADJUSTMENT WOULD GO TO
DIRECT SERVICE WAGES AND
BENEFITS. UM THESE ADDITIONAL
INITIATIVES WERE ALSO PART OF
THAT SAME ACCELERATION TO
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE. SO THE
DELAY IT JUST PAUSES. THE NEXT
INCREMENT. LET ME LET ME SEE IF
I CAN ASK DIFFERENT WAY. UM
GIVEN THAT THIS WORKFORCE IS, I
SAY THIS IS STRUGGLING, BUT
EVERY OTHER GIVEN THAT IN THIS
WORKFORCE, UM THE RATE IS REALLY
, REALLY LOW COMPARED TO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW GREAT FOR WORK
FOR FAST FOOD BROKER WORKERS.
THAT'S PHENOMENAL. I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD GET PAID AT
THAT LEVEL. BUT WE'RE NOT SO
MUCH IN THIS LEVEL, RIGHT? I
HEAR STORIES THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH DRIVERS TO PICK UP
CLIENTS TO GO TO THE PROGRAMS,
JOBS AND SO FORTH. THIS IS
DIRECTLY IMPACTING RAPES THE
CAPACITY FOR WORKFORCE. TRAVEL
IS NOT BEING REIMBURSED. YOU
KNOW, THAT'S A WHOLE OTHER
CONVERSATION, BUT IF THE RATE
WERE TO INCREASE THE OPPOSITE
SOME OF THE TRAVEL COSTS THAT IS
ASSOCIATED NOT REIMBURSED. SO I
GUESS I DON'T SEE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, BUT THE ENVIRONMENT DOES
NOT FEEL LIKE THIS WILL CAUSE A
WORKFORCE ISSUE OPEN DEFINITELY
DID NOT MEAN TO. IT CAN BE THAT,
UM, RECOGNIZING THAT THAT IS A
PAUSE IN A POTENTIAL IMPROVEMENT
IN THE AMOUNT THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS. THE PROPOSAL IS
TO DELAY ANY INCREASE, NOT A
REDUCTION, BUT WE DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS THE
INTENT. THE AUGMENTATIONS ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPORT WAGES AND
BENEFITS FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS. I APOLOGIZE,
CHIEF DEPUTY I GUESS I'M NOT
REALLY THINKING I'M GETTING NOT
THAT I'M LOOKING FOR A SPECIFIC
ANSWER. SENATOR CHRIS ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN. IT
THINK AS I MENTIONED IN MY
PRESENTATION, THE PROPOSAL YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU IS VERY MUCH
DETERMINED BY THE GENERAL FUND
SITUATION. THAT'S BEEN THE
THEME. OBVIOUSLY THIS THIS
BUDGET PROCESS AND I DON'T I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
MINIMIZE THAT THERE ARE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS AND THAT, UM,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE WE'VE BEEN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
SINCE THE OUTSIDE OF 20 SINCE
THE OUTSIDE OF RATE REFORM IN
2021, WERE ABLE TO GET
ACCELERATION IN 2022. IT WAS
ADOPTED AND A COUPLE YEARS
LATER, WE'RE HAVING TO RE LOOK
AT WHERE WE'RE HAVING THROUGH.
LOOK AT LOOK AT SOME HEART
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
AND SO I WOULD WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE'RE NOT MINIMIZING THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT AND WE HAVE WE
HAVE MET WITH STAKEHOLDERS? WE
AND WE ARE AWARE OF CONCERNS IN
THE COMMUNITY. BUT THIS PROBABLY
HAPPY FOR YOU IS VERY MUCH
DRIVEN BY THE BUDGET SITUATION,
RIGHT? OF COURSE, I KNOW THAT'S
A LOT FOR OUR PROPOSALS. RIGHT.
THE REASONING. I 100% GET THAT
WHAT CAN THEN AS A DEPARTMENT
ARE WE LOOKING AT TO HELP
MINIMIZE THIS IMPACT? SHOULD
THIS PROPOSAL GO THROUGH? I
THINK CONTINUED CONTINUED
EFFORTS ON THE DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL BENEFITS IN PLACE
TODAY, SO SOME OF THE
INITIATIVES MENTIONED ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
. SHOULD THERE BE CONCERNS FOR
PROVIDER? THERE ARE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVERS THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS. TO THE EXTENT THERE'S A
BROADER ISSUE. THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER PROCESS FOR WAVING
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS. YOU KNOW?
THIS IS BEFORE MY TIME, AND I
SEE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES.
WHO HELPED PUSH THIS YEARS AGO.
THESE RAIDS WERE BASED ON OUR
TIME FROM WHEN WAS A 2019. THOSE
RATES DON'T EVEN LIVE UP TO THE
STANDARDS THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW, IF WE FURTHER PUSH THAT
BACK ARE WE POTENTIALLY LOOKING
AT THEN SETTING A DIFFERENT
RATE, BECAUSE IF WE PUSH IT
ANOTHER YEAR BACK WE'RE GOING TO
BE FURTHER AWAY FROM THE LIVING
STANDARDS RIGHT NOW. SO IS THAT
OUR INTENT? BECAUSE THEY WERE
READY FOR THEIR BACK. WE'RE
ALREADY BACK FROM THESE RATES.
GREAT BUT IT WOULDN'T EVEN MATCH
LIVING STANDARDS. RIGHT WE PUSH
IT ONE MORE YEAR. WE'RE FURTHER
AWAY FROM MATCHING THE LIVING
STANDARDS. SO HOW DO WE THEN
ADJUST OR OFFSET? THE FURTHER
FALLING BACK FROM EVER EVERYONE
ELSE'S RATES. UM I THINK TO
ADDRESS THAT I CAN JUST
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE ITEMS IN
IN PLAY NOW. NOT THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS FOR THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE, UM WHAT? WHAT THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE, AND AS YOU
MENTIONED, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
LOWER WAGE WAGES IN THE
CATEGORIES, BUT IT DOES INCLUDE
THE ADJUSTMENTS FOR MINIMUM WAGE
AND THERE IS A STREAMLINED
PROPOSAL FOR THAT, SO THAT IT'S
MORE IT ADDRESSES THE PROVIDERS
WHO MODELS INCORPORATE THE
MINIMUM WAGE. HISTORICALLY
PROVIDERS HAVE HAD TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT NEED BEFORE
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS WERE MADE, AND
THEN SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
ONGOING PROGRAMS LIKE THE DSP
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WOULD
OFFER THE TIERED WAGES UPON
COMPLETION. CHIEF DEPUTY. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU YOU HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS ON YOUR PLATE. LISTEN
A COUPLE A HEARINGS AGO I
MENTIONED WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
CBS. FUNDING FOR HIS CAREER
PATHWAYS AND SO FORTH. AND WHY
OIL? I WOULD LOVE IDEALLY FOR
ALL THAT FUNDING TO GO THERE IF
WE DON'T SPEND THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE HAVE LEFT
OVER. I DON'T WANT THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO GO BACK. I'M
WONDERING SINCE THEN, IF ANY HAS
TALKED ABOUT IN THIS DEPARTMENT.
IF WE CAN UTILIZE THAT FOR
ADDITIONAL STIPENDS. I'M HERE OR
JUST USE SOME OF THAT FUND TO
HELP OFFSET THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT. OR MAYBE? YEAH, THIS IS
A QUESTION, SENATOR. CAN YOU
CLARIFY THE TH CBS SPENDING
PLANNED FUNDING? IS THAT OKAY?
AMOUNT THAT WHILE YOU FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE THAT WILL BE SPENT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE THAT. THAT THAT MARK, RIGHT
? UM PERHAPS UTILIZING SOME OF
THAT FOR ADDITIONAL STIPENDS. IF
IT'S NOT, I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T
KNOW THAT PART IF IT CAN BE
FULLY FOR PROBABLY CAN'T FOR THE
RIGHT RELATE AT THE RATE REFORM
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY FOR SIX
MONTHS. LET ME PHRASE THAT
BECAUSE I CONFUSED MYSELF. OKAY
H G B S FUNDING EXPIRES AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR. OH NO, WE
CAN'T UTILIZE THAT FOR THIS RATE
REFORM DELAY BECAUSE IT'S ONLY
SIX MONTHS OF IT. NOW I'M
WONDERING WITH THE POTENTIAL ON
SPENT DOLLARS AND THAT SECTION
CAN WE THEN MAYBE ADD MORE
STIPENDS TO WHAT THE CHIEF
DEPUTY JUST SHARED TO AT LEAST
OFFSET THE BLOW THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE COMING DOWN. ARE
YOU SPEAKING TO UNSPENT DOLLARS,
LIKE IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS LIKE
SPECIFIC TO? I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE DETAILS OF THE CAREER
PATHWAYS PROPOSAL ON THE
SPENDING PLAN. AND WOULD NEED TO
CIRCLE BACK ON WITH MAYBE IN
STAFF ON MECHANICS OF HOW THAT
HOW THAT COULD WORK. I KNOW, UM
BUT I BELIEVE I BELIEVE IN THE
HCPS SPAN IMPLANT QUOTE
GLOBALLY. THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FEDERAL APPROVALS. OBVIOUSLY
THAT NEED TO OCCUR FOR HOW WE
HAVE SUBMITTED THE PLAN IN THEIR
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE'RE SPENDING
THE MONEY, AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'VE MOVED
AROUND FUNDING WITHIN THEIR WITH
THEIR APPROVAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE. I KNOW IT'S THERE'S
ROOM TO DO THAT, FOR OTHER
THINGS SO LONG AS THEIR NEW
PROGRAMS SO I JUST WANT TO SEE
THAT WE'RE BEING AS CREATIVE
LITERALLY AS CREATIVE AS
POSSIBLE. WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH THIS BUDGET DEFICIT TO NOT
LEAVE A SINGLE PENNY ON THE
TABLE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HELP OPPOSITE
ANYTHING SO I MEAN, I'VE
SUGGESTED OTHER THINGS FOR HSS
AS WELL TO BE CREATIVE, JUST
SAYING IF ALL THE SISTER
DEPARTMENTS CAN TALK TO EACH
OTHER, HOW WE CAN, IF NECESSARY.
I'M THROWING EVERYTHING ON THE
TABLE HERE, CHRIS. I'M JUST LIKE
WHATEVER WE CAN WE CAN DO TO
GRAB RIGHT. SO I JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT UP. NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING FOR A RESPONSE HERE, BUT
JUST TO FLAG THAT FOR YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. LET'S MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT PANELIST. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. MHM MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS WENDY FOR CAS AND I
AM THE CEO OF A JOIN A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS PROVIDED
SERVICES TO HONESTLY THOUSANDS
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
OVER THE PAST 40 YEARS. AND I AM
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO START OFF
ACKNOWLEDGING THE CHALLENGING
BUDGET REALITY THE STATE IS
FACING REQUIRING SOME VERY HER
HARD DECISIONS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE THE DIFFICULTY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES WITH
MAKING TOUGH CHOICES THAT IT
ULTIMATELY IMPACT PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND THEIR WELL BEING. HONESTLY,
IF ANYONE I CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
IT WOULD BE THE EID COMMUNITY AS
WE HAVE BEEN FACING THESE HARD
DECISIONS WITHIN OUR BUDGETS FOR
THE LAST 16 YEARS DUE TO OUR
SERVICES AND OUR RATES BEING
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED. THE
GOVERNOR'S CURRENT PROPOSAL TO
DELAY THEIR FULL RATE
IMPLEMENTATION. THREATENS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY DEVASTATE AND
DESTABILIZE THE LIVES OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THIS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES, AND
IT'S GOING TO ERODE ALL THE
PROGRESS ALL THE PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE IN THE RECENT
YEARS TO, YOU KNOW, HELP
STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM AND AT
LEAST ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
BE HERE AND TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THE PEOPLE WE SUPPORT. AND
WHEN I SAY THE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE, I TRULY MEAN THAT THAT IS
BETWEEN THE ID COMMUNITY AND THE
LEGISLATORS. YOU HAVE BEEN RIGHT
THERE WITH US. YOU HAVE MADE
DECISIONS THAT HAVE HELPED US IN
THE PAST IT WAGE INCREASES FOR
THE WORKFORCE, AND IT REALLY IS
ESSENTIAL. UM AND IS IMPORTANT
TO HAVING THAT STRONG FOUNDATION
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE MEETING THE
PROMISE TO HAVE ARE ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS BE ABLE TO LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY IN I RECENTLY
SPOKE WITH ED, WHO IS A SELF
ADVOCATE AND HAS BEEN WITH THE
JOINT FOR ALMOST TWO DECADES
ABOUT THIS PROPOSED DELAY AND
THIS IS HIS WHAT HE SAID. HE
SAID. I'M TIRED OF TRAINING
STAFF AND I HAD TO SAY HEAD.
WE'RE TIRED OF TRAINING STAFF
TO, UM AND THAT IS THE REALITY
THAT UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE
HAVE DIFFICULTY AND RETAINING
HIRING, UM INDIVIDUALS TO
PROVIDE OUR SERVICES WE NOT ONLY
HAVE TO TRAIN THEM, BUT ED AND
OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY
SUPPORT HAVE TO SPEND TIME
GETTING TO KNOW THEM BUILDING
TRUST HAVING THEM UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY NEED AND
HOW BEST TO SUPPORT THEM AND
DOING THAT. UM AND AGAIN, UM FOR
US HAVING THE DELAY. ONLY ONLY
ALL IT DOES IS JUST PUSH THIS
PROBLEM OUT. AND YOU KNOW, I'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN SEEING. MADAM CHAIR AND YOU
GET IT. YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IF
WE DON'T HAVE A QUALITY, UM,
WORKFORCE AND A WORKFORCE IN
GENERAL, WE REALLY CANNOT ENSURE
THE HEALTH SAFETY OF THE NEEDS.
OF THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION
AND WE'VE MADE THAT PROMISE. WE
HAVE MADE THAT PROMISE THROUGH
THE LATTIMORE AN ACT. SO EXCUSE
ME. SO THE OTHER PART OF THIS IS
HOW HOW CAN YOU EXPECT US TO
PROVIDE QUALITY OUTCOMES WHEN WE
ARE CONSTANTLY HAVING TO START
OVER WITH NEW STAFF OR WHAT
WE'VE HAD TO DO IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS IS ACTUALLY RATION STAFF
HOURS. AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS FOR EXAMPLE, IF AN INDIVIDUAL
WANTS TO GO TO A DAY PROGRAM AND
THE DAY PROGRAMS FIVE DAYS A
WEEK BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE STAFFING, WE HAVE TO
TELL THEM WE'RE SORRY. YOU CAN
ONLY COME THREE DAYS A WEEK, AND
YOU HAVE TO FIND SOMETHING TO DO
ON THOSE OTHER TWO DAYS BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT FOR THEM. IF
IT'S A 1 TO 1 SERVICE, MAYBE
SOMEBODY IS AUTHORIZED FOR 30
HOURS OF INDEPENDENT LIVING
SKILLS COACHING A MONTH. WELL
WE'RE SAYING, HEY, YOU WERE
GOING TO GIVE YOU 10 BECAUSE WE
CAN THEN ALSO GIVE ANOTHER
INDIVIDUAL 10 AND WE HAVE TO
START RATIONING THAT AND AGAIN
THAT REALLY MAKES IT
CHALLENGING. FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO ENSURE THAT WORD WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THOSE QUALITY
OUTCOMES THAT WE KNOW ARE NOT
JUST EXPECTED, BUT ARE IMPORTANT
TO THE PEOPLE THAT WE SUPPORT.
UM. I CANNOT DISTRESS STRESS
ENOUGH THAT THERE WILL BE THERE
WILL BE A DIRECT IMPACT. IF THIS
IS DELAYED, AND IT WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE SUPPORT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ON OUR
GROWING WAITING LIST, THE
WAITING LIST THAT WE SHOULDN'T
EVEN HAVE BECAUSE THIS IS THE
STATE THAT WE HAVE AN
ENTITLEMENT FOR. AND ALSO THE
INABILITY TO DEVELOP SUFFICIENT
SERVICES TO MEET THE GROWING
POPULATION. AND ALSO IT MAKES IT
VERY CHALLENGING FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE STAFF AND A
WORKFORCE THAT CAN ACCESS THE
YOU KNOW AND HAVE THE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE SUPPORTING
ANYBODY. I HONESTLY WANT TO JUST
MAKE SURE WE DON'T FORGET THE
FAMILIES. THESE FAMILIES BEAR
THE FRONT OF THE WRAPPING UP.
OKAY UM, I HAD A PARENT THAT
ACTUALLY CONTACTED ME. SHE HAD
GONE THROUGH MULTIPLE SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR HER SON DUE TO
STAFFING ISSUES. SHE WAS FORCED
TO STAY HOME MULTIPLE TIMES
DURING THE WEEK, AND AT THIS
POINT, SHE WAS TELLING ME
CAREFULLY THAT SHE WAS GOING TO
HAVE TO QUIT HER JOB TO BE ABLE
TO STAY HOME WITH HER SON. UM SO
I JUST WANT TO REALLY STRESS
THAT THE DELAY OF THIS FULL RATE
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING TO HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
CONTINUING ISSUES WITH WORKFORCE
. WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE STAFF WERE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RETAIN THEM, AND WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE OUT THERE.
THANKS. SORRY. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANELIST FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES.
ALRIGHT. ALRIGHT. I THINK I GET
HI. UM, IT'S OFF. APPLE IS WHAT
IT'S LIKE. READY FAR. OKAY.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON
, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS AND
STAFF. MY NAME IS TONY ANDERSON
AND I AM THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES. SO I JUST GOT
THERE JUST STARTED THERE ON THE
EIGHTH OF JANUARY. SO OBVIOUS
SEEING YOU. WELCOME TO THE FUN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BUT I'M
NOT NEW. ALTHOUGH I LOOK VERY
YOUNG. I'M NOT NEW TO THE
SYSTEM. I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
SINCE 1987, WHICH IS A COUPLE OF
YEARS AFTER THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT, SO I'M AGED WISE.
YOU DO THE MATH? NO UM, I WANTED
TO ALSO GIVE SOME CONTEXT. I
LOVE THE REPORT THAT WE HAD FOR
THIS COMMITTEE. THE BACKGROUND
WAS REALLY GOOD, VERY HELPFUL,
SO I DON'T HAVE TO GET INTO ANY
OF THOSE THINGS. BUT THERE WERE
A COUPLE OF POINTS I THOUGHT
WERE REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WERE
MISSED IN. I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO DO
WITH THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. IT REALLY IS. THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND SO IN
2016 ISN'T NOTES THAT THERE WAS
A MAJOR INVESTMENT MADE INTO
THIS FIELD, AND, UM AND THAT WAS
WONDERFUL. IT WAS HARD FOUGHT,
BUT IT WAS MADE AT THAT TIME IN
AND AT THE SAME TIME THERE WAS A
RECOGNITION THAT THIS WAS NOT
GOING TO FIX THE PROBLEM. THIS
WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE WERE
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THIS ON THE ISSUE OF THE RATES,
UM, AND IT HAS FOLLOWED OVER TWO
DECADES OF FREEZES. AND DELAYS
OR WE CALLED THEM DISCOUNTS AT
THE TIME. THERE WERE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WERE DIFFERENT WORDS
THAT WE USE, BUT THEY WERE ALL
CUTS TO THE SYSTEM. SO THAT WAS
THERE WAS A RECOGNITION THERE,
THEN THE OTHER THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT WITH THIS IS THAT AT
THE TIME AS SOON AS WE PROVIDED
THE PROVIDERS WITH THE INCREASED
RATE THEN AND IT ALSO HAD A GOOD
PORTION THAT HAD TO GO TO THE
WORKERS, BECAUSE THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THE
WORKFORCE WOULD RECEIVE THE
MONEY THAT WAS CONCERNED THAT
THEY WOULDN'T SO THEY THAT WAS
BUILT IN THEN AT THE SHORTLY
AFTER THEN THE STATES MINIMUM
WAGE STARTED TO CHANGE, RIGHT
AND THEN SO EACH YEAR, THE
PROVIDERS WERE PAYING MORE AND
MORE HIGHER RATE. SO THESE ARE
ALL ALSO PART OF THE CONTEXT OF
THE OF THE RATE OF PROBLEM THAT
WE HAD. THEN YOU CAN YOU NOTED
IN THERE THAT 2019 IS WHEN WE
REALLY MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. SO I THOUGHT THAT
THOSE WERE IMPORTANT TO ADD AS
WELL AND THEN THE OTHER PIECE
AGENCY TOO MUCH HONEST, THE
CURRENT STATE THAT WE'RE IN
TODAY WITH OUR WITH OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICE SYSTEM. UM WE,
YOU KNOW, WE ALL OF US. SORT OF
WE DEALT WITH COVID. WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THAT MANY OF US HAVE
MOVED ON IN OUR LIVES. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MOVE ON IN OUR
LIVES, AND WE'RE OUT IN PUBLIC
FORUMS AND DOING FUN THINGS. BUT
WHAT WHAT REALLY SURPRISED ME.
I'M A FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER AS WELL. AND UM,
WHAT WAS SURPRISED ME IS THAT WE
DIDN'T WE COULDN'T JUST FLIP THE
SWITCH ON AND THEN PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN DESPERATELY NEEDING
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY LIKE ALL
OF US HAVE BEEN ISOLATED AND HAD
BEEN REMOVED FROM THEIR FRIENDS
AND LONELINESS IS AN ISSUE THAT
IS HISTORIC IN OUR COMMUNITY.
MANY TIMES WE DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT, BUT IT'S A IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS PERSONAL ISSUE THAT
COMES UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN. SO
THAT WAS EXACERBATED AT THE TIME
SO WE COULDN'T FLIP THE SWITCH
BACK ON. THERE WAS THIS THING
CALLED THE GREAT RESIGNATION
DURING THAT TIME WERE SO MANY
PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT JOBS RIGHT?
AND SO WHEN THEY DID THAT THEY
LEFT OUR FIELD IN A MUCH HIGHER
RATE. AND SO WE HAVE IN THIS NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA, BUT IT WAS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY IN THIS
FIELD OF FOR THE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS THEY LEFT BECAUSE
OF THE RATE. THEY ALSO LEFT
BECAUSE THE JOB CHANGE AND
PEOPLE WERE MOVING AROUND. BUT
WHAT HAPPENED FOR US IS THAT WE
DIDN'T GET THEM BACK RIGHT? SO
BECAUSE OF THAT WE COULDN'T. WE
COULDN'T GET PEOPLE BACK INTO
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN THEIR
PERSON CENTERED INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLANS THAT THAT'S THEIR
GOALS. THEIR WHAT THEY WANT IN
LIFE WITH THE REGIONAL SERVICE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO GET THEM BACK.
INTO THEIR WORLD THAT THEY WANT
TO LIVE IN, AND YET MANY OF THEM
ARE STILL AT HOME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. MANY OF THEM WILL BE
MAYBE IT MAY BE A LICENSE HOME
THERE, AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET TO THE DAY PROGRAM AS WINDY
HAD MENTIONED ON ON THE BASIS
THAT THEY WANT TO, SO WE, MAYBE
WE WERE GETTING THEM ONE OR TWO
DAYS A WEEK, BUT THAT'S NOT
THEIR GOAL. THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM. THEIR FRIENDS
ARE THERE OR OR THEIR SUPPORT.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WERE
LOST, AND THAT'S THAT'S WORK. SO
WE'RE STRUGGLING HERE, RIGHT? SO
THE REGIONAL CENTERS OUR PURPOSE
IS TO GET PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT ARE IN
THEIR HOPES THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLANS. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE. SO IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
SERVICES TO GET PEOPLE TO THOSE
PROGRAMS AND WHAT ELSE DO WE DO
SO OUR SERVICE COORDINATORS AND
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES? GETTING WHILE THIS
IS HAPPENING SO SOME. SOMETIMES
WE CAN DO THAT AND OTHER TIMES.
THERE'S JUST NOTHING THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. THAT'S GOING TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS. AND SO THOSE
PEOPLE ARE STILL THERE AT HOME.
IT'S NOT EVERYBODY, BUT THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL
NOT ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. SO YOU
HEAR ABOUT THE WAITING LIST. I
SHOULD BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE
MEAN TO BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
PROVIDERS ARE THE ONES WITH THE
WAITING LIST. SO YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA WE'RE EXCITED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A WAITING LIST LIKE
OTHER STATES DO BECAUSE YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE. YOU'RE IN RIGHT? YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TO GET IN.
BUT WITH IN TODAY'S WORLD,
YOU'VE GOT TO WAIT TO GET TO THE
PROGRAM IN MANY CASES THAT YOU
WANT TO GET TO BECAUSE THAT'S
THE ONE THAT WILL MEET YOUR
NEED. SO I. I THINK I WANTED TO
MAKE THAT THAT POINT REAL CLEAR
THAT IT'S NOT THAT AND THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE ALSO THEN
TRYING TO FIND SOME OTHER
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES THAT
YOU WOULD MATCH AND PRESENT TO
THE PERSON. THAT WE MEET SOME OF
THEIR OTHER NEEDS. SO WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CREATE A
NETWORK OF, YOU KNOW, UH,
SERVICE CAPACITY AND ALL OF OUR
GREAT, UH, COMMUNITY SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS AND THROUGHOUT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS DO THAT ALL THE
TIME. WE STILL BRING IN NEW
PROVIDERS, BUT THIS IS NOT ONE
OF THOSE PROBLEMS. THIS
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IS NOT ONE OF
THOSE PROBLEMS THAT'S GOING TO
GO AWAY BY US CREATING AND
BRINGING IN MORE AND MORE
PROVIDERS THAT WE CAN'T WE CAN'T
DEVELOP OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM. IT'S THE
WORST. I'VE SEEN IT AND I. I
LIKE I SAID. I'VE BEEN IN HERE
FOR A WHILE AND WE NEVER DO WELL
WHEN THERE'S A HEALTHY JOB
MARKET IN THIS FIELD, SO WE'VE
GOT TO COMPETE, AND THIS HEALTHY
JOB MARKET HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. SO THAT'S ON
TOP OF ALL OF THESE OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT ARE GOING ON. SO
YOU GET OK. SO UM, WELL, THERE
WAS THE QUESTION ON THE
INDIVIDUALIZED MEASURES AND I'LL
JUST SAY QUICKLY ON THAT FINAL
POINT, AND THEN TO MY OTHER ONE
IS THAT THE, UH WE REALLY WANNA
GET TO A REALLY ROBUST SYSTEM
WHERE WE'VE GOT MEANINGFUL
INDIVIDUAL OUTCOMES. AND UM, AND
IF THIS SCENARIO I JUST PAINTED
FOR YOU, OR WE'RE USING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES,
PATCHING THINGS TOGETHER. WHAT
ARE WE REALLY MEASURING? ARE WE
MEASURING SOMETHING THAT THE
PERSON REALLY DIDN'T EVEN WANT
OR OR THAT THAT'S NOT MEETING
THEIR FULL GOAL. I JUST SAY THAT
WE WE'VE GOT TO GET A HANDLE ON
THE WORKFORCE ISSUE IF WE WANNA
DO THAT, AND THEN A REAL FAST,
FAST, FAST POINT. IS THIS THAT
OUR PURPOSES. REGIONAL CENTERS
WHEN WE WERE CREATED WAS TO BE
THE ALTERNATIVE TO THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS, RIGHT THE
INSTITUTIONAL MODEL THAT
SEGREGATED PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SEPARATED FAMILIES THAT CREATED
ISOLATION FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WE WERE CREATED SO
THAT THAT WOULD NOT HAPPEN AND
THAT WE WOULD GET PEOPLE TO THE
LIVES THAT THEY WANT IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE SCENARIO GAVE YOU
SHOWS ISOLATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR GETTING YOUR PASS.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT PANEL IS
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA THANKS FOR YOUR HELP.
GOOD AFTERNOON, AND THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SUB-COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS VIVIAN HAHN.
AND IN ADDITION TO MY DAY JOB AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA I
ALSO HAVE A BROTHER, WHO HAS
AUTISM AND HAS BEEN SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM FOR
MOST OF HIS LIFE. I'M SO
GRATEFUL TO BE ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT RATE AND PAYMENT REFORM. I
CAN THINK A FEW THINGS MORE
ESSENTIAL THAN MAKING SURE WE
KNOW WHAT OUTCOMES WE WANT TO
GET OUT OF OUR SYSTEM. WHAT WE
NEED TO FUND AND HOW MUCH AND
WHERE IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THOSE
COMES. AND WHETHER, IN THE END
WE ARE GETTING WHAT WE PAID FOR.
AS PART OF THE RATE REFORM
ENACTED IN 2021, THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION COMMITTED
NOT ONLY TO INCREASING PROVIDER
RATES, BUT TO TYING THOSE
INCREASES TO INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
OUTCOMES. AND THAT'S A FANCY WAY
OF SAYING IF WE'RE GONNA BE
PAYING MORE FOR SOMETHING, WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING MORE IN RETURN. AND I
JUST BROADLY AT THE STATE LEVEL,
BUT AT THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL SO,
IN OTHER WORDS, ARE WE INVESTING
IN THE KINDS OF SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES DISABLED PEOPLE NEED TO
LIVE THE KINDS OF LIVES THAT
THEY WANT FOR THEMSELVES. THAT'S
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE. OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY MUST BE
ANCHORED IN HOW THE PROPOSED
DELAY AND THE POTENTIAL EROSION
OF OUR WORKFORCE WHICH SHOW UP
IN THE EVERYDAY LIVES OF THE
CHILDREN AND ADULTS SERVED BY
THE SYSTEM. BUT I WANT TO FOCUS
MORE ON ONE COMPONENT THAT I
THINK WE DON'T TALK OFTEN ENOUGH
ABOUT WHICH IS THE QUALITY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. QUALITY
INCENTIVES AND RATE INCREASES
HAVE BEEN LINKED IN STATUTE FROM
THE BEGINNING. AND THAT'S FOR A
REASON THEY GO HAND IN HAND.
WANNA TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHY? HOW WILL THIS SHIFT
TO A TRULY OUTCOMES BASED
FUNDING SYSTEM? HELP TRANSFORM
WHAT WE DO WE AT THE SAME TIME,
HELPING US TO BETTER FULFILL THE
PROMISE OF THE LANTERMAN ACT.
FIRST ONE OF THE CORE PRINCIPLES
OF THE LANTERMAN ACT IS THAT
SERVICES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE. WE HEAR THAT A LOT,
UH, AT DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA. BUT IN PRACTICE HOW
THAT'S OFTEN BEEN APPLIED IS
REGIONAL CENTERS APPROVING THE
SERVICE OR PROVIDER. THAT'S THE
LEAST EXPENSIVE. COST EFFECTIVE
DOESN'T MEAN CHEAPEST. IT MEANS
YOU GET THE MOST BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK. BUYING ONLY WHAT'S
CHEAPEST IN THE MOMENT IS OFTEN
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH. AS
THE SAYING GOES. BUT THAT'S WHAT
OUR SYSTEM DEFAULTS TO TOO OFTEN
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T REALLY KNOWN
HOW TO TELL WITH ANY CERTAINTY
WHAT PROVIDES THE MOST VALUE IN
THE LONG RUN. WHERE AND HOW,
WHEN WE BUY SOMETHING, IS THAT
THE THING THAT REALLY GIVES US
THE MOST VALUE FOR OUR DOLLARS
SO WHAT WOULD A SYSTEM TRULY
DRIVEN BY OUTCOMES LOOK LIKE? IT
WOULD LOOK AT THE IMPACT OF
SERVICES ON THE QUALITY OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND WHETHER
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE WHAT
THEY WANT TO BE ACHIEVING. IT
WOULD LOOK AT THINGS LIKE THE
DEGREE TO WHICH AN INDIVIDUAL IS
ABLE TO LIVE. WHERE AND HOW THEY
WANNA LIVE, SPEND THEIR TIME
DOING THINGS THAT ARE MEANINGFUL
TO THEM HAVE THE SUPPORT. THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE BOTH BIG
AND EVERYDAY DECISIONS IN THEIR
LIVES. AND NOT JUST BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT, BUT SEEN AND
KNOWN AND VALUED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT'S A SYSTEM THAT
WOULD COVER THE WHOLE OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES, NOT JUST THE
SERVICES THAT THEY GET. THROUGH
THE REGIONAL CENTER. IT WOULD BE
BASED ON RESEARCH. BEST
PRACTICES REGARDING QUALITY
MEASUREMENT FOR HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. I
WOULD MAKE THIS DATA AVAILABLE
TO DRIVE SERVICE IMPROVEMENT AND
INFORM WHAT TRAINING AND
RESOURCES WE NEED TO IMPROVE
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT SYSTEM YET.
BUT WE'RE CLOSE. WE CAN AND WE
WILL. IT'S IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING PILOTED RIGHT NOW, UM HAD
A FEW REGIONAL CENTERS OR WILL
BE PILOTED SOON. IT'S CALLED
PAVE. MANY OF US HAVE HEARD
ABOUT THE PAVE PROJECT. IT'S
FUNDED BY Dð Dð S¼ AND
SPEARHEADED BY èC èC L  N, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
COMMUNITY, THE NATIONAL QUALITY
FORUM, THE INSTITUTE FOR
COMMUNITY INCLUSION AND OTHER
NATIONAL EXPERTS ON QUALITY AND
OUTCOME MEASUREMENT FOR SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE. WITH I Dð Dð. AND
UH, HERE'S WHAT? WHERE I WILL,
UH, GO OFF SCRIPT A LITTLE BIT.
UH, AND JUST RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD
TODAY. I'M WITH YOU ON
IMPLEMENTATION. IT'S LIKE I AM
NOT HERE FOR JUST MAKING CHANGES
THAT LOOK GOOD ON PAPER AND
SOUND LIKE THEY MIGHT WORK. UH
I'M WITH YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
WANT TO STICK AROUND AND MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE CHANGES ACTUALLY
SHOW UP IN THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
AND THE WAY THEY WERE INTENDED.
UM ONE OF OUR PROBLEMS IS THAT
WE HAVE NOT REALLY HAD MANY GOOD
TOOLS TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
HAPPEN TO OPERATIONALIZE THEM AT
A SYSTEMS LEVEL AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR PAVE AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR QUALITY INCENTIVES
. QUALITY INCENTIVES ARE A TOOL
FOR MAKING SURE THAT THE THINGS
WE THINK ARE MOST IMPORTANT THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN. ACTUALLY
HAPPEN, BECAUSE WHEN YOU PAY FOR
THE THINGS THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT YOU MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE FOR STAFF, WHETHER IT'S
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF PROVIDER
STAFF, YOU ARE ALWAYS A JOY TO
LISTEN TO, BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO START WRAPPING UP, PLEASE. IT
IS, UM IT'S A TOOL YOU CAN USE
IT. TO INCENTIVIZE AND MAKE IT
MORE FINANCIALLY REWARDING TO DO
THE THINGS THAT ACTUALLY LEAD TO
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT WHEN
WE MEASURE IT, UM THAT IS NOT
REALLY A TOOL WE HAVE EVER
LEANED INTO IN OUR SYSTEM YET.
AND WE ARE ON THE CUSP OF BEING
ABLE TO DO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. UM WE'RE SO CLOSE, UM
CURRENT DELAY IN RATE INCREASES.
THAT IS NOT EVEN THAT IS NOT
EVEN THE END, AS MANY PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THAT IS NOT THE
PROMISED LAND IN ANY WAY, SHAPE
OR MEASURE BECAUSE JUST THE LIFE
RAFT OR JUST LIKE CLIMBING ON
AND WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CLING
TO IT SO WE CAN GET TO THAT
DESTINATION WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY DO THESE THINGS. THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE STARTING TO DO
THROUGH PAVE, WHICH IS TO REALLY
MAKE IT MORE POSSIBLE TO DRIVE
THAT CHANGE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT, UH,
PANELIST IS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK AND
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY, AND
I'M TRYING NOT TO DISEMPOWER
PEOPLE. I'M TRYING NOT TO BREAK
THINGS LIKE TONY DID. SO I'M
TRYING TO BEHAVE. HØI MY NAME IS
JACKIE FOSS. I'M THE BOARD
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK. AND
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER OF
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER PEOPLE ON
APRIL 1ST STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER
PEOPLE WILL CELEBRATE 30 YEARS
IN BUSINESS. WE WILL WE SERVE
ALL TO CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
CENTER NORTH BAY REGIONAL CENTER
, AND SINCE THE START, WE HAVE
DONE ALL INCLUSIVE SUPPORTS IN
THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTED LIVING
AND INDEPENDENT LIVING. YOU
KNOW, AS THE JANUARY BUDGET WAS
RELEASED, MY FIRST QUESTION WAS
AGAIN. WHY THE STATE ALWAYS SAYS
THAT THE BUDGET IS A STATEMENT
OF PRIORITIES AND VALUES. IF
THAT IS TRUE, THEN WHY ARE
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ALWAYS PRIORITIZE LAST? WHY WHAT
DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA VALUE? WHY IS IT THAT
WHEN THE BUDGET DEFICIT AFTER 30
YEARS I KNOW DDSS SERVICES ARE
GOING TO BE TARGETED ONCE AGAIN?
WHY IS IT THAT 100 AND 18,000
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
WILL AGAIN BE ASKED TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY SUPPORT FOR POVERTY
LEVEL WAGES. THE Dð S¼ ARE
EXPECTED TO GO INTO THE HOME TO
TEACH COOKING SKILLS, AND YET
THEY ARE GOING HOME WITH FOOD
INSECURITY. ARE THEY ABLE TO
FEED THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR
CHILDREN? THEY'RE ASKED TO
ACCESS THE COMMUNITY, BUT
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT HAVING
ENOUGH GAS TO GET TO WORK.
MAJORITY OF OUR WORKFORCE ARE
SINGLE MOTHERS AND WHAT WE KNEW
FROM AAA. UM QUESTIONNAIRE WE
DID A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IS THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ALSO ACCESS
CAL, FRESH AND MATA. WONDER IS
THAT ALSO A CALIFORNIA VALUE IF
WE VALUE HIGH QUALITY OUTCOMES,
THEN SHOULDN'T WE WANT A WELL
TRAINED WORKFORCE THAT CHOOSES
AND CAN AFFORD TO STAY? THAT
WILL NOT HAPPEN WITH POVERTY
LEVEL WAGES. THE MOST IMPORTANT
WHY WHY IS IT THAT OVER 400,000
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
ARE FACED ONCE AGAIN WITH
FIGHTING TO PROTECT? ONLY THE
VERY BASIC SERVICES? IS THIS A
CALIFORNIA VALUE? I WANT TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO DEBBIE. I'M
GONNA SHOW YOU THAT PICTURE
FIRST. UM I'M GONNA SHOW YOU HER
FAVORITE PICTURE. SHE TOLD ME TO
SHARE WITH YOU. THAT'S YOUR
FAVORITE PICTURE. THAT'S DEBBIE
AT VENICE BEACH WHILE MUSCLE
BEACH AND THAT'S AJ. UM DEBBIE
IS A 59 YEAR OLD WOMAN WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY. SHE REQUIRES
TOTAL ASSISTANCE WITH HER DAILY
ACTIVITIES FROM EATING TO
DRESSING TO BATHING IN PERSONAL
CARE. SHE WAS PLACED IN A 45 BED
NURSING FACILITY WHEN SHE WAS 14
YEARS OLD. CAN YOU IMAGINE THE
FEAR SHE EXPERIENCED AS A 14
YEAR OLD GOING FROM HER MOTHER'S
HOME TO A ROOM SHE SHARED WITH
THREE OTHER STRANGERS? HER
MOTHER AT THAT TIME HAD TO MAKE
THAT DIFFICULT DECISION AS SHE
HAD NÓ SUPPORT IN THE HOME. THE
SYSTEM FAILED. THE MOTHER AND
THE DAUGHTER AT THE AGE OF 31.
SHE HAD HAD ENOUGH. OF THE
SEGREGATED LIFE, AND SHE FINALLY
SAID, I'M DONE SO IN 1995, SHE
PACKED HER BAGS. SHE WHEELED OUT
OF THE GARDENS WITH A èC  N,
WHO SAID SHE COULD LIVE WITH
HER. WHEN SHE WAS TOLD SHE WAS
NOT CHOSEN TO BE PART OF THE S¼
L S¼ PILOT, SHE SAID TOO BAD
WHICH IS MY DEB. AFTER A FEW
BUMPS IN HER NEW INDEPENDENT
LIFE STEP WAS CHOSEN TO BE HER
SUPPORTED LIVING AGENCY. MUST
PROVIDE THE MOST INTIMATE CARE
FOR HER, SUCH AS BATHING AND
TOILET. IN HER PAST HISTORY, SHE
WAS A VICTIM OF SEXUAL ABUSE FOR
DEBBIE HAPPENED TO TEACH PEOPLE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN TO DO THE
MOST INTIMATE CARE IS
TRAUMATIZING. SHE HAS TO EXTEND
THAT TRUST OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SHE EXPRESSES TO ME. SHE JUST
WANTS CONSISTENT QUALITY STAFF
THAT HELP HER LIVE HER LIFE HER
WAY THE WAY SHE CHOOSES.
TURNOVER IS NOT JUST A NUMBER
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE LIKE DEBBIE.
IT'S PERSONAL, CONSISTENT
QUALITY SUPPORTS MATTERS. I
SHARE THE STORY OF DEBBIE
BECAUSE THIS IS WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY. THESE DECISIONS DIRECTLY
IMPACT DEBBIE AND THOUSANDS OF
DEBBIES ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
IS NOT A MATHEMATICAL FORMULA.
THIS IS HER LIFE. A VERY
INTIMATE LIFE THAT MUST ALWAYS
BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE. AT THE LAST
HEARING. THERE WAS A
CONVERSATION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND HOW THEY CAME TO THE
DECISION TO PROPOSE THE DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION. WAS THERE ANY
OTHER DETERMINANT? BESIDES MATH?
THE ANSWER WAS IT WAS DUE TO THE
CURRENT BUDGET, AND THAT WAS HOW
THE DECISION WAS MADE. THE
CONVERSATION LED ME TO REALLY
LOOK AT THE OTHER NUMBERS. THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
EQUATION. THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW
FROM THE 2022 NATIONAL DATA ON
THE WORKFORCE FROM THE NATIONAL
CAR INDICATORS ACROSS REFUNDING
AGENCIES. THE TURNOVER RATES FOR
S¼ ON AVERAGE IS 41% WITH A HIGH
LEVEL OF 59. 36% OF THOSE WHO
ANSWER THE SURVEY HAD BEEN
EMPLOYED AT THEIR AGENCIES FOR
ONE YEAR OR LESS. OF THE 62% WHO
LEFT THEIR JOB IN THE FIRST YEAR
. THEY HAD WORKED THERE FOR LESS
THAN A YEAR FROM THE L A Ó FROM
THEIR REPORT ON MINIMUM WAGE
HIGH LOW OR SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN. THE MAJORITY OF LOW
WAGE WORKERS ARE DEFINED AS
THOSE WHO EARN AN HOURLY WAGE OF
1750 OR LESS THEIR HOME HEALTH
CARE AND PERSONAL CARE AID.
THAT'S THE MAJORITY OF THE LOW
WAGE WORKFORCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OBVIOUSLY IT
FRUSTRATES ME FOR FAST FOOD
WORKERS. THEY MAKE UP THE SECOND
LARGEST LOW WAGE OCCUPATION. BUT
THAT LIKELY WON'T BE THE CASE ON
APRIL 1ST WHEN THEY GO UP TO A
$20 AN HOUR. UM THAT KICKS IN IN
APRIL. IN OTHER WORDS, THE
LARGEST LOW WAGE WORK GROUP IS
HOME HEALTH CARE AND PERSONAL
CARE AID. THE FAST FOOD WORKER
WAGES NEEDS WERE ADDRESSED, AND
THAT'S GREAT. BUT YET AGAIN OUR
WORKFORCE THAT SHOULD BE LOOKED
AT AS INVALUABLE CONTINUES TO BE
INVISIBLE. IS THIS A CALIFORNIA
VALUE? I BRING THESE FACTS
FORWARD TO EMPHASIZE THAT A
DELAY IN THE RATE IMPLEMENTATION
WILL ONLY WORSEN AN ALREADY
CRITICAL WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SHOULD BE A CORE
CALIFORNIA VALUE. IF WE ARE TO
ACHIEVE QUALITY OUTCOMES THEY
DESERVE, AND WE SHOULD EXPECT NÓ
LESS. CALIFORNIA MADE A PROMISE.
AND IT'S TIME WE KEEP IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
REMARKS. UM, NOW FINALLY, ALEO.
FOR YOUR REMARKS ON THIS.
PROPOSED DELAY. 100 L A Ó. UM
WE WANTED TO START BY NOTING
THAT THE PROPOSED DELAY WOULD
HELP THE BUDGET PROBLEM BY
PROVIDING ABOUT $600 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS IN 2024 25.
NONETHELESS AS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED BY MANY ON THE PANEL,
UM THE PROPOSAL COULD INTRODUCE
WORKFORCE ISSUES AS WELL AS
DELAYS IN SERVICE PROVISION TO
INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY DDS. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD THEREFORE
CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES THAT ADVANCE PART OF
RATE IN 2024 25 WHILE STILL
PROVIDING SOME DEGREE OF
SAVINGS. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
TARGETING SELECT SERVICE
PROVIDER CODES WHERE THE Dð S¼ P
SHORTAGES ARE THE MOST ACUTE. UM
AND THOSE TARGETED CODES COULD
RECEIVE THE RATE INCREASE
SCHEDULED FOR JULY. 1ST 2024
UNDER CURRENT LAW. WE ARE
WORKING ON IT. NÓ THERE WE GO,
OK? YOUR WISH IS MY COMMAND. OK,
I'LL CONTINUE. UM WE WANTED TO
NOTE, THOUGH, THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES THAT FUND
SOME DEGREE OF RATE REFORM, THIS
WOULD REQUIRE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DETERMINE WHAT
TYPE OF TARGETED OR SCALED BACK
APPROACH WOULD MAKE THE MOST
SENSE ADMINISTRATIVELY. AND A
KEY POINT TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT ALTERNATIVES THAT REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING DELAYED
WOULD STILL REQUIRE DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR SOLUTIONS ELSEWHERE IN
THE BUDGET. UM AND THE L A Ó IS
AVAILABLE, UM, TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE IN IDENTIFYING ANY
ALTERNATIVES, AND WE CAN ALSO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
EVALUATING TRADE OFFS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. Ó I HAVE ONE SUB CHAIR
FELLOW. UH, FOR SUB FIVE, I
THINK CENTER WHA THAT ALREADY
COMMITTED TO ALL THE CUTS IN HER
SUBCOMMITTEE'S JUST GONNA GET
ALL THE OTHER SUBCOMITTEE CHAIRS
TO BE ON BOARD AND CUTTING
EVERYTHING THERE TO SAVE
EVERYTHING ON HÌ HÌ S¼.
PARTICULARLY HUMAN SERVICES.
PORTION I THINK I FORGOT ONE OF
YOU. WHO SAID THAT? I THINK
MAYBE IT WAS YOU, JACKIE, THAT
YOU SAW THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IN
JANUARY. AND YOU SAID, OF
COURSE, Dð Dð S¼ IS GONNA GET
SOME CUTS. I LOOKED AT IT IN
JANUARY, SAID. OF COURSE, HUMAN
SERVICES IS GETTING CUTS. UM I
THINK FOR SOME REASON WHY I
STILL DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WOULD
LIKE SOMETHING MORE THAN GIVEN
THE SITUATION. HOW WE PRIORITIZE
SOME OF THESE THINGS. AND I
THINK, UM, EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT UNDER HÌ HÌ S¼ HAS
HEARD ME LOUD AND CLEAR AS TO
WHY DID SOME THINGS NOT GET CUT
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN OFF THE GROUND
BY OTHER THINGS THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR A WHILE OR WERE
REALLY PROMISED FOR A LONG TIME
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED FOR CUTS AND
DELAYS. AND I HOPE IN THE MAY
REVISE, WE HAVE A BETTER ANSWER
TO THAT. I KNOW THINGS ARE
GETTING WORSE IN THIS SITUATION.
I AM ACTIVELY LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO SUPPLEMENT DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR.
IF WE'RE PROPOSING TO KEEP THIS
IN PLACE, I APPRECIATE YOUR
OTHER SUGGESTION AS TO LOOKING
AT SERVICE PROVIDER CODES AND
SEE THE ONES THAT NEED THE HELP
THE MOST UM, TO MAKE TO KEEP
PART OF THAT PROMISE. MOVING
FORWARD. EVERYTHING IS, UM ON
THE TABLE. AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WHEN WE SEE EACH OTHER
AGAIN. DEPARTMENTS IN MAY IS
THAT WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
BETTER METHODOLOGY TO EXPLAIN
HOW WE GOT TO SOME CUTS IN SOME
AREAS AND NÓ CUTS IN OTHER AREAS
AND DELAYS AND SO FORTH, BECAUSE
I MEAN, THESE ARE ISSUES IN SUB
THREE THAT REALLY IMPACT THE
ACTUAL LIFE. OF AN INDIVIDUAL,
THE QUALITY OF LIFE AND SO
FORTH. I'VE BEEN PART OF MY
TOURS. I VISITED THE ADULT
CENTERS I VISITED, UH, SKILLED
CENTERS FOR JOBS AND THE I Dð Dð
POPULATION AND SO FORTH. LIKE I
SEE THE SUCCESS AND THEN I THINK
IF WE DON'T INVEST NOW. COUPLE
YEARS. IT'S GONNA BE WORSE. UM
THE REACTIVE COST IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE. SO
WHEN WE I THINK YOU SHARED THE
CHEAPEST OPTION IS ACTUALLY THE
MORE EXPENSIVE OPTION BECAUSE
THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO REPEAT
IT AND REPEAT IT VERSUS
INVESTING IN A ONE TIME REALLY
QUALITATIVE APPROACH. UM TO THEN
GET A BETTER RETURN FOR OUR
BUCK. VIVIAN I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
READY TO SHARE SOMETHING ELSE.
NÓ? YES JUST JUST VERY QUICKLY.
THANK THANK YOU, UH, SENATOR, UM
, I JUST WANTED TO SHARE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE. UH, THE L A Ó
S¼ SUGGESTION, TRYING TO LOOK AT
POSSIBLE WAYS TO FIND SOME KIND
OF COMPROMISE. OR OR SOME MIDDLE
GROUND TO, UH, FUND SOME
SERVICES, UM, EARLIER, RATHER
THAN HAVING TO WAIT UNTIL JULY
2025. I WILL SAY, THOUGH, THAT
WHAT CONCERNS ME IS THAT WHILE
IT MAKES SENSE LOGICALLY, TO TRY
TO FOCUS ON SERVICES WHERE THE
SHORTAGES ARE MOST ACUTE. I
WORRY THAT WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
THAT WE DON'T OUR SYSTEM DOES
NOT REALLY HAVE THE DATA YET TO
TELL IN ANY CONCRETE, RELIABLE
WAY WHERE THAT IS, WE CAN'T
PINPOINT. I WISH THAT WE COULD,
BECAUSE THAT LOGICALLY MAKES
SENSE. BUT I WORRY THAT IF WE
SAY OK, WELL, LET'S DO THAT. HOW
ARE WE GONNA PICK? HOW CAN WE
TELL? I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
NUMBERS TO BACK IT UP. SO WHILE
I APPRECIATE THE APPROACH TO
PROBLEM SOLVING I WORRY ABOUT
THAT APPROACH FOR THAT REASON,
AND THAT WILL FEEL UNFAIR IF WE
GO DOWN THAT ROUTE WITHOUT GOOD
DATA. SENATOR ROTH, WOULD YOU?
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON THIS I?
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ADD FOR THE
MAY REVISE. I THINK IT'D BE
REALLY, REALLY HELPFUL. I KNOW
CHIEF W. YOU SHARED THESE
STIPENDS AND SO FORTH, BUT I
THINK IT'S FOR ANY OF OUR
PROPOSED CUTS OR DELAYS. WHAT?
HOW ARE WE REALLY GONNA OFFSET
THE HITS. UM BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING BEHIND THAT. I MEAN, IN
IDEAL WORLD, THIS DOESN'T GET
DELAYED RIGHT? UM BUT HOW ARE WE
REALLY GOING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE MAKE THEM
WHOLE OR HAVE THEM SURVIVE ONE
MORE YEAR? RIGHT I? I STAND FIRM
WITH MY ASSEMBLY, UH, CHAIR ON
HUMAN SERVICES AND SAYING THIS
IS ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES,
RIGHT? REALLY ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES. UM I THINK I HAVE
MAYBE, LIKE FOUR. I'M TRYING TO
BE REALLY REALISTIC IN THIS, YOU
KNOW, AND REALLY KEEP IT TO THE
TO THE MOST MOST MOST MOST DIRE
SITUATIONS THAT WE WANNA PROTECT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE, GIVEN
SITUATION, BUT IT'D BE HELPFUL
FOR YOU TO COME BACK TO ME AND
SAY YES, WE'RE DELAYING, BUT
THIS IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO. UM, I WOULD PREFER YOU COME
BACK, SAYING WE'RE NOT DELAYING
BUT LET LET'S I'M WORRIED. I
KNOW YOU'RE WORRIED. WE'RE
REALLY WORRIED THAT THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT CONTINUES TO NOT
BE MADE WHOLE IN ANYTHING.
WHETHER IT'S REGIONAL CENTERS,
WHETHER IT'S BEING AUTONOMOUS IN
THEIR LIFE, WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO ADOPT DATE PROGRAMS,
WHETHER IT'S SUB MINIMUM WAGE,
IT'S I. IT'S HARD TO PINPOINT
ONE THING THAT WE'RE LIKE, HEY,
WE'RE DOING A GREAT JOB IN THIS
SITUATION. WE THERE PROBABLY IS,
BUT THE OVERARCHING THEME HERE
IS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH
THE IG Dð POPULATION THAT JUST
ME AS A WHOLE. IF THERE'S
NOTHING FURTHER UM, WE'RE GONNA
UM HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN AND, UM,
TAKE A QUICK FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
RIGHT? WE WILL NOW RECONVENE. ON
BUDGET SUB-COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WE HAVE NOW MOVED ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. THIS WILL BE THE
LAST ISSUE BEFORE WE BREAK FOR
SOME PUBLIC COMMENTS AND THEN GO
BACK TO THE REST OF OUR AGENDA.
WE ARE JOINED BACK IN THE HOT
SEAT OF THE DIRECTOR. AND OUR
SECOND PARTICIPANT IS GOING TO
BE ON ZOOM. SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE DIRECTOR. ON ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM
PLAN MEETINGS. MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NANCY
BARGEMAN, DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO, UM
ON ISSUE FIVE ON INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLAN MEETINGS. THERE'S
TWO QUESTIONS THAT ARE PART OF
THE AGENDA TODAY, AND THE FIRST
ONE IS JUST TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSED AND THAT ON THE AGENDA
PAGE 33 REALLY PROVIDES A
SUMMARY OF WHAT THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL IS. I'LL JUST GIVE
A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND. AND
THEN THE INTENT LANGUAGE THAT IS
INCLUDED. SO DURING THE PANDEMIC
, IT BECAME EVIDENT THAT WE
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO BE FLEXIBLE
TO HAVE ACCESS NOT ONLY TO
SERVICES BUT MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS AND SERVICE
COORDINATORS WERE COORDINATING
AND CONTINUING THE WORK ON IP P
MEETINGS AND AL ALSO ANY OTHER
CHECK INS THAT NEEDED TO HAPPEN.
SO THAT'S WHEN WE HAD TO
IMPLEMENTED THE REMOTE OPTION.
REGIONAL CENTERS HAD GONE. WE
HAD FUNDING AVAILABLE TO ACCESS
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS AND REGIONAL CENTERS
DURING THAT TIME. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WE EXTENDED OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME, BUT NOW WE'RE
PROPOSING TO GO AHEAD AND STOP
THAT FLEXIBILITY THAT'S IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSED. WE HAVE HEARD
SERIOUS CONCERNS FROM SOME OF
OUR COMMUNITY TO THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THE REMOTE SERVICE IP,
UM, THAT THE BENEFITS WERE BEING
ABLE TO HAVE ADVOCATES PRESENT
DURING THE MEETINGS. WE'RE
CERTAINLY NOT LOOKING TO REMOVE
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ADVOCATES TO ATTEND, UM WERE
MERELY LOOKING AT PRIORITIZING
HAVING THE INTENT OF THE VALUE.
WE TALKED A LOT OF CONVERSATION
TODAY ABOUT TRUST. YOU KNOW, MY
BACKGROUND WAS A SERVICE
COORDINATOR AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I REALLY VALUED, AND
WHAT I WAS ABLE TO DO. WORKING
WITH THE FAMILIES IS REALLY THAT
TIME SPENT IN PERSON. SO WHY IS
IT THAT THE IP P MEETING IN
PERSON IS SOMETHING THAT LIFTING
UP IS A PRIORITY IS BECAUSE THAT
IS REALLY A TIME WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT COMPREHENSIVELY.
WHAT ARE THE SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES, PARTICULARLY DURING
TIMES OF TRANSITION OR CHANGES
FOR THE FAMILY? IT COULD BE, UM,
GOING INTO, UM, EDUCATION. IT
COULD BE EDUCATION. IT COULD BE,
UM, CHANGING JOBS. THERE'S
DIFFERENT TIMES. RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S ONLY UM, A MANDATE OF AN
IP P EVERY THREE YEARS. THERE'S
TIMES. IT'S MUCH MORE FREQUENT.
BUT OVER TIME I'VE JUST BECOME
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE NOT LOSE
THOSE CONTACTS BECAUSE WE KEEP
GETTING FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
THAT'S WHEN IP P MEETINGS
STARTED GOING ONCE EVERY THREE
YEARS, AS OPPOSED TO ANNUAL IP
S¼ THE OTHER THING THAT I'LL
JUST NOTE IS THAT IN THE
MEETINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REALLY ARE FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN
FAMILY HOMES. THERE'S MANDATES
FOR IN-PERSON VISITS WHEN
SERVICES ARE BEING PROVIDED
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME, SO I JUST
CONTINUING GETTING A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THAT
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING, YOU KNOW,
WORKING WITH FAMILIES AND
RECOGNIZING CHANGES AND
DEVELOPMENT OR BEING ABLE TO SEE
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT SUPPORTS ARE
NEEDED, BUT I ALSO DO
UNDERSTAND. WE'RE ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THE TRUST FACTOR PLAYS A
ROLE IN THIS I. I WANT TO ALSO
JUST FLAG THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT
MANY OF THESE ISSUES, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT KIND OF THIS IN AN
ISOLATION, SAYING, OK, HERE'S A
TRAILER BILL FOR THE IP P REMOTE
MEETINGS EARLIER, YOU HAD THE
STANDARD STANDARDIZATION, UM AND
LOOKING AT THE EQUITY AND
OVERSIGHT. SO THAT INCLUDED A
STANDARDIZED IP THAT WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT. I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ALSO CONSIDER KIND
OF HOLISTICALLY. TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS BECAUSE AS WE'RE STANDING,
STANDARDIZING IT, WE WE'VE
WORKED ON IT OVER THE LAST YEAR
IN MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
GETTING INPUT ON WHAT SHOULD
THAT UPDATED PERSON CENTERED
LOOKING? UM IP P, UM, BE
AVAILABLE SO WE ARE HAVING WE
HAVE A DRAFT. WE'VE HAD INPUT
FROM THE COMMUNITY WERE
REDRAFTING. WE'RE GOING TO GET
ADDITIONAL INPUT. I THINK FOLKS
ARE GONNA BE VERY, VERY
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED AND SEEING
HOW IT'S REALLY LEANING INTO A
STANDARD. A PERSON-CENTRED
APPROACH, REALLY WORKING WITH
THE FAMILY AND THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE OTHER ELEMENTS THAT'S GONNA
BE INCLUDED IN IT IS THE WAY FOR
AFTER THE IP P PROCESS, HAVING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A SURVEY.
WERE THERE, QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
DO THEY FEEL SATISFIED WITH WHAT
WAS BEING, UM, INFORMATION BEING
PROVIDED? DID THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY HAD A CHOICE? SO ALL OF
THESE THINGS I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WE HAVE
THOSE MEETINGS, I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALSO DOING
A CHECK BACK TO SEE IS IT REALLY
KIND OF MEETING THE NEEDS? SO
WITH THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE? UM UM WE'RE NOT
EXTENDING THE REMOTE IS WHAT OUR
PROPOSAL IS. BUT WITH THE INTENT
OF SAYING, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
IT, UPDATING THE LANGUAGE FOR
INTENT OF THE VALUE OF IN PERSON
THE VALUE OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE HAVING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES,
BUILDING THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND
BEING ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SERVICES FROM A WHOLE PERSON AND
A WHOLE INDIVIDUAL. UM PERSON
CENTERED APPROACH. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS, UM, TO THIS
ISSUE. UH SINCE IT'S REALLY
SHORT PANEL, I'LL TURN OVER TO
THE ONE ON ZOOM FROM CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. HELLO
UM, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SUB COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS ROSIE FREIH
HART AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
APOLOGIZING THAT I AM APPEARING
REMOTELY. IT IS MAYBE APROPOS
GIVEN THIS ISSUE, BUT IT IS NOT
A REFLECTION OF THIS ISSUE'S
IMPORTANCE. UM, I WISH I COULD
BE THERE IN PERSON AND WHAT I
UNDERSTAND AS A PACKED HOUSE I
AM AN ATTORNEY AT CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE
COURT APPOINTED COUNSEL TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH OF LOS ANGELES,
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES.
THAT'S ROUGHLY 25,000 YOUTH,
MANY OF WHOM ARE DULY SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM. MY
JOB AT èC èC IS TO FOCUS ON
THOSE DUALLY SERVED YOUTH IN MY
YEARS IN THIS ROLE. I HAVE
WORKED TO SUPPORT CLOSE TO 1000
FOSTER YOUTH AND ACCESSING
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES FROM 13
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS,
WHICH MEANS I HAVE ATTENDED MANY
MANY IP P MEETINGS BOTH REMOTELY
AND IN PERSON, AND ONE THING I
HAVE LEARNED DOING THIS WORK IS
THAT FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO
PROPERLY SERVE CONSUMERS, THERE
MUST BE AN OPTION TO HOLD THE IP
P MEETING REMOTELY. DIRECTOR
BARTMAN CORRECTLY POINTS OUT.
NOT ONLY THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE IP P MEETING BUT ALSO THE
IMPORTANCE THAT THEY BE USED TO
BUILD TRUST. THEY'D BE
COLLABORATIVE AND PERSON
CENTERED FOR IP Tð MEETINGS TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND FOR THE
RESULTING PLANS TO MEET CONSUMER
NEEDS, CONSUMERS AND THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEM MUST BE EQUAL
PARTNERS TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
COLLABORATING TOGETHER. AND
WHILE THERE ARE ADVANTAGES TO
HOLDING THESE MEETING IN PERSON,
UM THERE ARE ALSO ADVANTAGES TO
HOLDING THEM REMOTELY, FOR
EXAMPLE, HOLDING MEETINGS
REMOTELY MAKES IT EASIER FOR
BUSY SOCIAL WORKERS, PROBATION
OFFICERS, PUBLIC DEFENDERS,
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ATTEND
IMPROVING CROSS SYSTEMS
COLLABORATION. BUT THE PROBLEM
THAT I REALLY WANT TO POINT OUT
IS NOT THAT THESE PROFESSIONALS
MAY BE EXCLUDED FROM THE
MEETINGS THAT THEY WERE ONLY IN
PERSON OR THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
TO CALL IN. SO THAT COULD IS A
CONCERN BUT THAT THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SO CRUCIAL TO THE IP P MEETING
OUR EXCLUDED THAT THE MEETING
DOESN'T MEET THE BASIC LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS TO EVEN BE CALLED
AN IP P MEETING. FOSTER CHILDREN
PRESENT A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF THIS
ISSUE. WHEN A CHILD ENTERS
FOSTER CARE. THEY ARE DETAINED
FROM THE HOME OF THEIR PARENT OR
LEGAL GUARDIAN IN PLACE IN
ANOTHER PERSON'S HOME OR
SOMETIMES A GROUP HOME. THEY
COULD BE WITH A RELATIVE WHO
KNOWS THEM WELL OR A TOTAL
STRANGER WHO HAS NÓ IDEA. THEY
EVEN ARE A REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMER, LET ALONE WHAT THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS ARE. AND JUST
BECAUSE A CHILD IS IN THE CARE
OF A FOSTER PARENT OR GROUP HOME
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE PERSON OR
STAFF PROVIDING CARE HAS ANY
AUTHORITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
REGARDING THEIR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. WE CALL THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, DECISION
MAKING RIGHTS AND THOSE REMAIN
WITH A PARENT. EVEN WHEN A CHILD
IS REMOVED FROM THEIR CARE. IT
IS ONLY WHEN THE COURT FINDS
THAT LIMITING THAT RIGHT IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT THE CHILD THAT
THAT WOULD CHANGE. AND WHEN THE
COURT DOES GRANT THOSE RIGHTS TO
ANOTHER PERSON, IT MUST BRING
THEM TO SOMEONE WHO KNOWS THE
CHILD WHENEVER POSSIBLE. EVEN IF
THAT PERSON DOES NOT LIVE IN THE
SAME HOUSEHOLD AS THE CHILD. MY
POINT IS, IS THAT THERE ARE
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS WHO DO
NOT LIVE NEAR THE PERSON WHO
KNOWS THEIR NEEDS OR THE PERSON
WHO HOLDS THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DECISION MAKING RIGHTS
FOR THESE CONSUMERS. THERE MAY
BE NÓ CONVENIENT LOCATION TO
HOLD THE MEETING IF IT MUST BE
IN PERSON. I'M ALREADY SEEING
REGIONAL CENTERS INSIST THAT
MEETINGS BE HELD IN PERSON AND
SITUATIONS WHERE OUR CLIENTS AND
WHOEVER HOLDS THEIR DECISION
MAKING RIGHTS LIVE APART. I'VE
SEEN REGIONAL CENTERS RESPOND
THREE DIFFERENT WAYS. THE FIRST
IS THAT THE REGIONAL CENTER ASKS
FOR THE DEVELOPMENTAL RIGHTS
HOLDER CALL IN WHILE EVERYONE
ELSE ATTENDS IN PERSON. THIS IS
NOT A VIABLE OPTION. THIS DOES
NOT BUILD THE TRUST THE DIRECTOR
BARGEMAN CORRECTLY POINTS OUT IS
NEEDED WHEN ONE PERSON IS
CALLING INTO A MEETING WHERE
EVERYONE ELSE IS ATTENDING IN
PERSON. IT DOESN'T CREATE THE
COLLABORATIVE ENVIRONMENT. WE
ALL KNOW IS NEEDED. IT JUST
ALIENATES A PERSON WHO MAY
ALREADY BE MARGINALIZED DURING
THIS PROCESS. THAT IS NOT A
PROPER IP MEETING. AS TROUBLING
AS THAT IS, THE SECOND RESPONSE
I'VE SEEN FROM REGIONAL CENTERS
IS EVEN MORE TROUBLING, AND THAT
IS TO PROCEED WITH THE MEETING
IN PERSON WITHOUT INCLUDING THE
PARENT OR THE PERSON WHO HOLDS
DECISION MAKING RIGHTS. FOR
EXAMPLE, I HAVE A CLIENT WHOSE
GRANDMOTHER HOLDS HIS DECISION
MAKING RIGHTS, BUT HE LIVES IN A
GROUP HOME. REGIONAL CENTER HELD
AND IP P MEETING THAT INCLUDED
MY CLIENTS, A MINOR AND GROUP
HOME STAFF WHO WOULD ONLY KNOWN
HIM A FEW WEEKS BECAUSE HIS
GRANDMOTHER COULD NOT TRAVEL TO
THE MEETING. THE RE THIS
REGIONAL CENTER JUST HELD THE
MEETING WITHOUT HER. THEY HELD
IT. NOT ONLY WITHOUT ANY ONE WHO
KNEW THIS CHILD WELL BUT ALSO
WITHOUT ANYONE WHO HAD ANY LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT HIS SERVICES. THAT IS NOT
AN IP MEETING AND THE RESULT FOR
THIS YOUTH WERE DISASTROUS. THIS
REGIONAL CENTER TOOK ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT WERE IN HIS
PREVIOUS IP P OUT OF HIS PLAN AT
THIS MEETING WITHOUT EVER
DISCUSSING IT WITH HIS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES DECISION
MAKER. THIS REGIONAL CENTER WAS
SO FOCUSED ON SEEING HIM IN
PERSON THAT THEY FORGOT IT WOULD
MEAN A CRUCIAL PERSON WOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM THE MEETING. I AM
EXTREMELY SORRY TO SAY THAT THIS
HAPPENS WITH SHOCKING FREQUENCY.
IN FACT, I ESTIMATE THAT A
ROUGHLY 20% OF THE IP P S¼ THAT
I REVIEW WERE CREATED AT
MEETINGS THAT DID NOT INCLUDE
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DECISION MAKER. NOW FOR THE
THIRD THING I HAVE SEEN REGIONAL
CENTERS DO AND THAT IS RISE TO
THE OCCASION AND BE NIMBLE. I
HAVE SEEN SERVICE COORDINATORS
SAY, OK, WE NEED TO HOLD AN IP P
MEETING. GIVEN THIS CONSUMER
SITUATION, LET'S HOLD THE
MEETING REMOTELY, AND NEXT WEEK
I'LL STOP BY THEIR HOME OR THEIR
SCHOOL OR THEIR JOB OR THEIR
DATE PROGRAM AND SEE THEM AND
CHECK IN AND BUILD THAT TRUST
THESE SERVICE CO COORDINATORS
GOT TO HAVE THE IN PERSON
INTERACTION BUT STILL HELD IN IP
P MEETING THAT MET THE CONSUMER
UNIQUE IT. ALL IT REQUIRED WAS
SOME FLEXIBILITY. I AM SPEAKING
ABOUT FOSTER YOUTH, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT MY EXPERIENCE IS.
BUT THIS ISN'T JUST AN ISSUE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. EVERY REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMER IS DIFFERENT.
THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT SUPPORT
NEEDS AND DIFFERENT SUPPORT
SYSTEMS. IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THESE MEETINGS THAT ARE MEANT TO
BE PERSON CENTERED RESPOND TO
EACH CONSUMER'S UNIQUE SITUATION
. WE CANNOT MAKE THE ASSUMPTION
THAT IN PERSON MEETINGS WILL
MEET THEIR NEEDS. THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE MAKES THAT ASSUMPTION
AND NOT ONLY OFFERS NÓ GUIDANCE
ON WHEN A REMOTE OPTION WILL BE
PERMITTED. IT REMOVES THE OPTION
ALTOGETHER. I CAN CONFIDENTLY
SAY THAT REQUIRING THAT MEETINGS
BE IN PERSON WITHOUT ANY
FLEXIBILITY WILL LEAD TO
INADEQUATE MEETINGS FOR SOME
CONSUMERS. BECAUSE THAT IS
ALREADY HAPPENING EVEN BEFORE
THIS LANGUAGE HAS TAKEN EFFECT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. TODAY.
I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK LEO ANY
FURTHER COMMENT TO PERMANENT
FINANCE? UM DIRECTOR, I AGREE
WITH YOU, I. I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF IN PERSON. IT'S
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH, UH, A VULNERABLE COMPLEX
SITUATIONS AND SO FORTH. I GET
IT. I'M WONDERING IF WE CAN GET
TO A COMPROMISE HERE BECAUSE I
YOU YOU MENTIONED, UM MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS LANGUAGE WITH
THE INTENT. I'M WONDERING, I'M
HOPING THAT WITHIN THE LANGUAGE,
WE ADD MORE FLEXIBILITY WHILE WE
WORK ON THE INTENT. RIGHT THE
FINAL GOAL. I KNOW, MEETING ONE
TIME IN PERSON AND THE THREE
YEARS IT'S NOT ENOUGH. DOESN'T
REALLY COVER ANYTHING. UM AND
THINK MEETING IN PERSON ONCE A
YEAR, BACK BEFORE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION WOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER. I AGREE WITH YOU, BUT
YOU KNOW ARE THE IP P MEANS
LIKE, YOU KNOW, HAPPEN MORE THAN
THAT MORE FREQUENTLY THAT S¼ Dð
P S¼ NEED A CHANGE AND SO FORTH.
IF SOMEWHERE WE CAN FIND A
COMPROMISE WHERE WE'RE MEETING
ONE TIME A YEAR IN PERSON ONE
TIME EVERY THREE YEARS IN PERSON
, BUT WHEN WE HAVE TO DO THOSE
QUICK IP P MEETINGS TO CHANGE A
PLAN OF THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
THOSE CAN BE REMOTE OR THAT THE
THIRD SUGGESTION IS WHAT I ALSO
HEARD ADVOCATES SHARE WITH ME IS
THAT LET'S HAVE THESE MEETINGS
AND, UH, ZOOM BUT ALSO COME
CHECK UP ON ME WHEN I'M IN
SCHOOL WHEN I'M HERE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THAT PERSON A PERSON
CONTACT. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
GONNA REQUIRE HUMAN POWER TO DO
THAT, ADDING EXTRA WORKLOAD TO
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW. UM, IS WE HAVE A NOT THE
STRONGEST WORKFORCE, BUT I'M
HOPING THE MAYOR REVISE. WE GET
SOME COMPROMISE THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS THAT I THAT YOU SHARE THAT
I THINK ARE VERY, VERY VALID.
BUT ALSO FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO HAVE LIKE, UM,
MISS. F FREAR. UM MENTION
REGARDING HAVING A SOCIAL WORKER
, THE DEVELOPMENTAL RIGHTS
HOLDER. UM OR ANY OTHER PERSON
IN IN IN THAT MEETING. I THINK
THE CALL IN IS NOT THE GREATEST
OPTION, BUT I DO THINK IF YOU
WANNA SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
JUST SOME KIND OF EXTRA
FLEXIBILITY. SENATOR. WE ARE IN
A NEW AGE OF TECHNOLOGY, YOU
KNOW, SO AND I. I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT TAKEN A STEP BACK. AND
SEEING THE VALUE OF BOTH. OF
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE YOU KNOW
AGAIN? I AM A SOCIAL WORKER AT
HEART. I MEAN, I. I WEAR IT ON
MY SLEEVE. I MEAN, I. I JUST I
MY FOUNDATION OF MY WORK WAS AS
A SERVICE COORDINATOR AND BEING
ABLE TO BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS, SO I AGREE. I'M
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS. UM
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S ADDITIONAL WAYS TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
RELATIONSHIPS ARE BUILT IF THE
INTENT AND THE SUPPORTS ARE
THERE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT,
UM IN SITUATIONS IF WE ARE DOING
THIS THROUGH A PERSON APPROACH
INDIVIDUALIZED AND MAKING SURE
YOU KNOW AND I. I GUESS I'D SAY
IN RESPONSE. IS THERE A WAY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION TO LOOK AT
SOME FLEXIBILITIES OR TO LOOK AT
A WAY THAT CAN KIND OF MARRY?
KIND OF TWO BENEFITS? UM OPEN TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WE HAVE
SAID THAT ALSO IN THE ASSEMBLY,
UM AND WE'D WELCOME UM,
CONVERSATIONS TO SEE. HOW DO WE
LOOK AT STILL BUILDING THAT
TRUST? BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO
BUILD THAT TRUST. HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN A FAMILY OR AN
INDIVIDUAL CALLS TO SERVICE
COORDINATOR, THEY'RE CALLING
SOMEBODY THEY KNOW AND SOMEBODY
LIKE IF THERE IS AN URGENT NEED,
THERE'S TIMES WHEN THINGS HAPPEN
, AND THEY NEED TO MAKE A PHONE
CALL, YOU KNOW IF THEY FIRST
TIME THEY'RE MAKING THAT CALL IS
ONLY BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD A
VIRTUAL KIND OF RELATIONSHIP. IT
MAKES THAT PHONE CALL A LITTLE
BIT HARDER. SO I THINK THAT AS
WE HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS IF
WE CAN THINK THOSE SITUATIONS
THROUGH, UM I CERTAINLY WOULD
WELCOME. YOU KNOW, HOW DO WE
KIND OF MOVE FORWARD WITH IN A
WAY OF BEING ABLE TO HELP
FAMILIES EMBRACE THEIR ADVOCATES
OR EMBRACE THOSE THAT KNOW THEM
TO BE PART OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS? UM, AND BE HAPPY
TO DO THAT? WE'RE GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTING THIS, YOU KNOW IP P
TEMPLATE STARTING IN JANUARY.
WHAT I DON'T WANT IS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ALREADY IS ALREADY
REGIONAL CENTERS SEE NÓ MORE
ZOOM, EVEN THOUGH THAT'S STILL
IN EFFECT RIGHT NOW, BUT
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WE'VE SEEN
ARE NOT ALL UNIFORM. UM AND
THEY'RE STOPPING THAT I THAT'S
WHY I WANNA MAKE SURE WE ADD
SOME FLEXIBILITY. EXTEND THE
FLEXIBILITY. HYBRID I THINK FOR
ANYTHING POST COVID. IT'S LIKE
REALLY IDEAL WORLD, RIGHT. WE'VE
SEEN IN THE CORPORATE WORLD OR
JUST WORKPLACE OVERALL. EXCEPT
FOR US. WE HAVE TO COME IN EVERY
SINGLE TIME IN PERSON. BUT LIKE
WE SAW THE BENEFITS OF HAVING
THINGS WORK FROM HOME AND SO
FORTH. BUT THERE IS BENEFITS OF
COMING IN PERSON. I MEAN,
FINDING A HYBRID MOT A HYBRID
APPROACH TO THE IP S¼ WHILE WE
GET THIS FULL TEMPLATE,
STANDARDIZED IN JANUARY, JUST A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER. NOW WOULD BE
GREAT. WHAT I DON'T WANNA SEE IS
JUST CUTTING. ENOUGH. NOW SIX
MONTHS OF WAITING THE
UNCERTAINTY AND THEN JANUARY
COME BACK WITH A NEW PLAN. AGAIN
DIRECTOR. I GET IT. YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT I THINK
ABOUT DURING COVID THE CASES
THAT WE SAW ONE VIDEO WENT VIRAL
OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR
WHO WAS WHO ATTENDED COURT. AND
THEY'RE PERPETRATOR WAS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM, AND THEY COULDN'T
TELL. I UNDERSTAND. SO I GET
THAT I THINK THAT'S REALLY,
REALLY VALID. UM BUT I ALSO WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY WHEN
IT COMES TO I THINK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION. YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO ENSURING HAVING YOUR
YOUR BATTLE, BUDDY, RIGHT NEXT
TO YOU, THAT MAKES YOU FEEL MORE
CONFIDENT AND SURE. IN WHAT THE
QUESTIONS YOU WANNA ASK? THERE'S
A WHOLE IT THE INTERDISCIPLINARY
TEAM SURROUNDING THE CARE OF
THIS INDIVIDUAL, RIGHT? IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO BE THERE, SO I KNOW
DIRECTOR THAT YOU WANT THE SAME
THING. UM AND I THINK WE CAN
FIND A COMPROMISE FOR THE MAY
REVISED TO GIVE SOME CERTAINTY
WHILE WE GET THAT
STANDARDIZATION. THANK YOU,
DIRECTOR. SENATOR OK, WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
ON ZOOM. I REALLY APPRECIATE AND
BRINGING THAT FOSTER CARE
PERSPECTIVE. I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE TOPICS THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY TALKED ABOUT HERE. RIGHT
UM INDIVIDUALS HERE WITH OTHER
COMPLEX ISSUES. WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN, AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA DO PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FIVE UNDER
DDS. ISSUES ONE THROUGH FIVE
UNDER Dð Dð S¼. THIS IS NOT THE
TIME WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
COLIN. FOR THE COMMENT. THE
COLIN PORTION IS GOING TO COME
AT THE END. I WANT TO QUICKLY
KNOW SOMETHING REGARDING OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS SITUATION. YOU
MAY HAVE NOTICED THAT WE NÓ
LONGER ARE DOING, UH, CALL IN
PUBLIC COMMENT. THAT IS OUR
WHOLE LEGISLATURE HAS MOVED AWAY
FROM THAT. AND WHAT WE DID TODAY
WAS ATTEMPT TO GET AS MUCH OF
THAT BACK AS POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE WERE EQUITABLE IN
HEARING THE VOICES OF MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. IT'S NOT A
PERFECT SYSTEM. UM, BUT WE DID
AS MUCH AS WE COULD TO ENSURE
THAT WE HEARD PEOPLE THAT WERE
UNABLE TO COME TO THIS MEETING.
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE HERE TO SHARE. UM SO I
WILL BE LIMITING YOU TO NÓ MORE
THAN ONE MINUTE. AND WE I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO DECREASE
THAT AMOUNT AS WE SEE MORE AND
MORE OF THIS LINE GET LONGER. SO
YOU MAY BEGIN. HELLO MY NAME IS
TRACY MUNCH I. I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY, AS IN AND,
UM I JUST WANNA SAY I'M AN
ADVOCATE. YEAH. I MEAN, WE CAN
AND, UH, HE GOOD. COULDN'T WE DO
IS IT TH SERVICES I, A CLIENT? I
WORK IN THE FIELD, ALTHOUGH, AND
I, UM I THINK EVERYTHING IS
IMPORTANT WHAT WAS SAID TODAY.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE ALL NEED
TO COME TOGETHER AS ONE AND IN
HELPING TO OTHER ALL THINGS
TOGETHER FOR ALL OF US, BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS SAID JUST
A WHILE AGO ABOUT, UM UM OR LIKE
STABBING HIS SHOE. UM SO JUST TO
GIVE ME A MINUTE TO FINE. HAVING
ISSUE I THINK THAT, UM THAT WE
NEED TO REALLY WORK ON THERE
BECAUSE I LIVE ON MY AND I HAVE
STUFF COME IN AND HELP ME. YEAH,
THERE'S SO MUCH TURNOVER BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH UM BECAUSE OF
THE WAGES. PEOPLE STARVING IS
WING OVER BECAUSE THEY'RE LIKE
GETTING PAID ENOUGH TO HELP ME
WITH MY NAMES AND EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT. AND I JUST WANNA SAY
TOO. THE UM, UM, THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT. EVERY ISSUE TODAY
THAT WAS FOR ALL THE AGENCIES I
WANNA SEE CHANGE. AND EVERY WAY
ME TOO PUZZLE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THIS WEEK. AND
FOR THOSE WHO AREN'T HERE WHEN I
ANNOUNCE UM PLEASE, IF YOU'RE
NOT A FAMILY MEMBER OR A SELF
ADVOCATE, IF YOU COULD GO TO THE
END OF THE LINE, WE'RE DOING
FAMILIES AND SELF ADVOCATES.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME. MY NAME
IS MOHAMMED RASHID. I AM MYSELF.
ADVOCATE I'M SERVED FROM, UH, BY
VALLEY MOUNTAIN REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO, UM, STRESS
THE IMPORTANT OF THE SERVICES.
UH, WHETHER IT BE TRANSPORTATION
DAY PROGRAM. UM. CAREGIVERS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THESE
SERVICES ARE NOT CUT BECAUSE IT
IS VERY DETRIMENTAL TO, UM THEIR
THE CONSUMERS LIFE AND THEIR
INDEPENDENT AND ALSO, UM I WOULD
LIKE TO TOUCH ON THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS, UM, THEY REALLY NEED
A UM PAY RAISE, UM IN REGARDS TO
HOW MUCH THEY WORK, AND THEY GET
, UM BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW. SO THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. HAVE A
GOOD DAY. YOU TOO. SO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA FRANZONI. I'VE BEEN
RECEIVING INDEPENDENT DENTAL
SERVICES FROM MY ORIGINAL CENTER
FOR 27 YEARS. I ONE SECOND ONE
SECOND OK? THANK YOU. STATEMENT
TO YOU TODAY IS BECAUSE OF MY
SERVICES. I AM ABLE TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY ON MY OWN. THE
SKILLS I GET ARE COOKING CREAMY
TRANSPORTATION SO I COULD BE OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY. WITHOUT THESE
SERVICES, I WOULD NOT BE WHERE I
AM NOW. I CAN'T UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE MY INDEPENDENT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I AM VERY
PROUD OF IT. I WANNA BE ABLE TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY. MORE YEARS
TO COME. PLEASE TAKE MY SPEAK
INTO CONSIDERATION AS WELL IS
IMPORTANT TO ME AND OTHERS. I'VE
BEEN LIVING ON MY OWN NOW FOR 27
YEARS IF I DIDN'T HAVE SAID.
SERVICE I WOULDN'T BE ABLE I
GAIN MY INDEPENDENCE. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I WANNA LOSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW WHAT. HØI I AM. HOLD ON.
IT'S NOT ON YET. ONE SECOND I'M
A STAFF FOR NÓ NÓ. I'M A STAFF
FOR ELIZABETH DRAKE AND I WILL
BE PRESENTING HER SPEECH TODAY.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH DRAKE. I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR MORE MONEY
FOR MY STAFF WHO NEED BETTER PAY
BECAUSE THEY DEAL WITH LOTS LIKE
OUR MOODS AND ACTS. THEY HAVE
FAMILIES AND BILLS LIKE US. I
ALSO THINK THE WHOLE COMPANY
SHOULD GET MORE FUNDING SO THEY
CAN EXPAND THEIR COMPANY AND
PROVIDE CARE TO MORE PEOPLE WITH
BETTER PAY. AND FOR, UM OUR
STAFF. I THINK IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE MORE TO JOIN OUR TEAM.
ANOTHER REASON WE COULD USE MORE
FUNDING IS SO WE COULD GET
BETTER SUPPLIES SUCH AS MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT LIKE SHOWER CHAIRS,
HOYER LIFTS AND MORE TO LIVE
MORE COMFORTABLE AND MORE
COMFORTABLE LIFE AND MAKE OUR
STAFF'S JOB EASIER. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING ME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OH,
I'M NANCY SAGER AND I REPRESENT
THE INFANT DEVELOPMENT
ASSOCIATION. SO THE INFANT
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
AGREES WITH. I MEAN, ARGUES THAT
FOR THE REJECTION OF THE DELAY
OF THE INCREASES FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION PROVIDERS AND ASKED
THAT THE STATE TO FULFILL
FULFILL THE RATE INCREASE, AS
PROMISED, WE ARE COMPELLED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RATE MODEL. THAT THAT
STAFF MEMBERS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED AND COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR WORKER WORK, SO THAT
QUALITY AND ACCESSIBILITY OF
SERVICE IS ST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. DOES THE DOG HAVE ANYTHING
TO SAY? UM NÓ? HE DOESN'T OK.
ALWAYS. WELCOME BACK. THANK YOU.
OH, YEAH, TRYING TO SHOW UP.
YEAH. I'VE BEEN ASSIGNED THE
TESTER OF THE MICROPHONE.
DOESN'T SEEM TO HOW ARE WE
DOING? HOW ABOUT NOW? THERE WE
GO. ALL RIGHT, SO THANK YOU,
SENATORS. MY NAME IS MARK WOLF.
AND I AM A FATHER OF SO MANY A
SON WITH AUTISM WHO SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER. I AM ALSO
THE VOLUNTEER PRESIDENT OF THE
TRI COUNTY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
REGIONAL CENTER, AND CURRENTLY I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF ARCA. AMY WES'S
ORGANIZATION. MY COMMENT IS
SIMPLY THIS. MY SON WHO WORKS AT
A GROCERY STORE AS A CASHIER,
MAKES MORE MONEY THAN HIS DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER WHO HAS TO HAVE
THE SKILLS TO WORK WITH THE
COMPLEXITIES OF SOMEONE WITH
AUTISM. THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
, WORKING EVERY DAY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OTHERS TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY AND CONTRIBUTE TO A
BETTER SOCIETY, OUR PAID WAGES
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANTLY OUT OF
ALIGNMENT WITH THE TIMES AND THE
WORK THAT THEY DO. THESE FOLKS
WERE PROMISED A RATE INCREASE,
AND NOW THEY ARE TOLD THAT THAT
MAY BE DELAYED A YEAR WHILE
THEIR RENT, FOOD AND OTHER COSTS
CLEARLY WON'T FREEZE FOR A YEAR,
THEY WILL GO UP. SENATOR NA
MENJIVAR EARLIER YOU SAID THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE SOLVES
FOR THE ISSUES TRICKLED DOWN
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO THE GROUND FLOOR
OF THE PEOPLE WHO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH OUR PEOPLE. TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. WE CAN'T DRIVE THOSE
VERY SAME DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDERS OUT OF THEIR JOBS, AS
WAS EARLIER, UM, AS AS IT WAS
EARLIER SAID THAT THERE'S AN
ASTRONOMICAL TURNOVER ALREADY
ATTRIBUTED TO THE LOW WAGES. THE
HEADLINE IS THAT WE COULD SAVE A
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE FINANCE
GROUP WAS MENTIONING HOW WE MUST
SAVE MONEY. HOWEVER, I ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER I'M RIGHT THERE. I
ASKED THE KING CONSIDER NOT ONLY
THE UNFAIRNESS OF FREEZING THEIR
LOW WAGES, BUT ALSO THAT HALF OF
THAT BILLION COMES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO WE REALLY
ARE SAVING HALF A BILLION AND IF
YOU DIDN'T FREEZE THE RATES,
THAT BILLION WOULD BE SPENT BY
PEOPLE PAID THEIR TAXES AND COME
BACK INTO THE ECONOMY. SO I ASK
YOU TO LOOK AT THAT. THANK YOU
GUYS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS PAT HORN. BECKER I'M
BOARD PRESIDENT FOR THE ARC OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT TODAY I'M HERE
SPEAKING FOR MY SON, JOSEPH.
ANGELMAN SYNDROME SERVED BY THE
GATE REGIONAL CENTER. HE LIVES
IN HIS OWN APARTMENT IN SAN
FRANCISCO, WITH 24 7 SUPPORT
FROM THE ARC Dð S¼ P S¼ ASSIST
HIM WITH HIS PERSONAL HYGIENE
DRESSING EATING MEDICATION FOR
SEIZURES, SLEEP DISORDER,
EXERCISING SOCIALIZING IN THIS
COMMUNITY. HE'S HIS OWN BOSS,
AND HE LOVES HIS LIFE. AND 69
1969, CALIFORNIA ADOPTED THE
LANMAN ACT RECOGNIZING THAT
PEOPLE WITH I DESERVE A LIFE OF
RESPECT AND DIGNITY EQUAL TO ANY
OTHER CITIZEN IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LETTERMAN X PROMISE WAS TO FUND
THE SYSTEM. AND THAT WOULD
CREATE THIS REALITY. HOWEVER, WE
HAVE NEVER BEEN A FULLY FUNDED
SYSTEM. WE TOOK A $1.4 BILLION
HIT IN 2008, WHICH WE NEVER
RECOUPED. IN 2015. THE RATE
STUDY REVEALED A $2.2 BILLION
FUNDING GAP AND THAT'S NOW NINE
YEARS OLD, AND THE TWO YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AGREED TO
THEM IS BEING DELAYED. NÓ MORE
DELAY. WE NEED TO FULFILL THE
PROMISE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OH, SURE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
. MY NAME IS RAYMOND HAMPSON.
I'M A PARENT CAREGIVER TO OUR 30
, THREE 30 THREE YEAR OLD SON,
WHO LIVES AT HOME AND DOES
RECEIVE REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES
. WE HAVE ENDURED YEARS AND
YEARS OF BUDGET CUTS AND DELAYS.
I ASK YOU WHY MY SON AND HIS
PEERS HAVE BEEN CONSTANTLY
TREATED LIKE FOURTH CLASS
CITIZENS. WHY HAS THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE ALWAYS
BALANCED THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET
ON THE BACKS OF OUR COMMUNITY?
WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY SEEN THE
DECLINE AND DELAY OF SERVICES
PROVIDED BY REGIONAL CENTER.
SERVICES THAT ARE IN MY SON'S IP
ARE NOT BEING FULLY PROVIDED. WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THE LACK OF
PROVIDERS AND STAFF ARE THE
REASONS WHY THESE SERVICES
CANNOT BE PROVIDED. WHEN DOES
OUR ID COMMUNITY BECOME A
PRIORITY WITHOUT EQUALITY?
WORKFORCE THE MASTER PLAN
DOESN'T MATTER. THE GOVERNOR'S
RATE REFORM. DELAY MUST BE
REJECTED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY CAN YOU
HEAR ME? RIGHT MY NAME IS
ROSEMARIE PEREZ. I SERVE ON THE
ARCA BOARD AND THE REGIONAL
NORTH BAY REGIONAL CENTER BOARD.
MY SISTER SUSIE LIVES IN A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY IN SANTA
ROSA. HER CAREGIVERS ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN HER
LIFE. SHE ALSO ATTENDS A DAY
PROGRAM. CONSISTENCY IS CRUCIAL
TO HER BECAUSE SHE IS
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED DOESN'T
SPEAK. AND SHE'S ALSO BLIND, SO
SHE REALLY NEEDS CAREGIVERS TO
GUIDE HER THROUGH HER DAILY
THROUGH HER DAY. SHE ALSO HAS A
SEIZURE DISORDER. HER
MEDICATIONS ARE VERY FRAGILE. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE PER
CAREGIVERS UNDERSTAND AND DON'T
MAKE MISTAKES WHEN IT COMES TO
HER MEDICATIONS. IT IS HER
CAREGIVERS ARE UNDERPAID. WHICH
IS AND HAVE BEEN UNDERPAID. AND
THIS DELAY IS NOT GOING TO FIX
THAT. UM SO WE REALLY WERE AS
I'M ASKING THAT YOU REALLY
REJECT THIS DELAY. THANK YOU,
MA'AM. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS EDITH. AND I'M I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY 32 YEAR OLD
ELISA ARIAS. WHO WAS BORN TO
IMMIGRANT PARENTS FROM MEXICO
AND SAN FRANCISCO. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US THAT HE HAS
RECEIVED SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS SINCE HE WAS
FOUR YEARS OLD AND WAS THRIVING
UNTIL THE PANDEMIC. LAST YEAR. I
BECAME HIS SOLE CAREGIVER AND
NOW ALSO APPOINTED MEMBER OF THE
WORK GROUP FOR THE MASTER PLAN.
WHEN ELISA'S TRANSITION FROM
SCHOOL TO THE COMMUNITY HE WAS
ATTENDING AN ADULT PROGRAM IN
PERSON FOR FIVE DAYS A WEEK AND
FOUND A JOB PLACEMENT IN HIS
COMMUNITY. HE WAS BEING TRAINED
TO TRAVEL INDEPENDENTLY. IT WAS
PART OF DIVERSE LEISURE
ACTIVITIES, BUT THE PANDEMIC IN
2020. HE STAYS HOME FOR TWO DAYS
A WEEK TO DO VIRTUAL CLASS
MEETINGS. HE ONLY GOES OUT THREE
DAYS A WEEK WITH THE ADULT
PROGRAM FOR UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF
HOURS AND AT TIMES LESS DAYS IF
THE STAFF PERSON IS NOT
AVAILABLE OR NEEDS A DAY OR WEEK
OFF. PRESENTLY HE WORKS SIX
HOURS A WEEK. DESPITE DESPITE
OUR LOCAL ADVOCACY, ULIS HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES, JOB COACHING,
LEISURE ACTIVITIES OR OTHER
SERVICES THAT WOULD HELP HIM
THRIVE IN THE AND LEAVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT HE DESERVES
. THIS IS DUE TO THE SHORTAGE OF
STAFF, THE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
ALREADY AUTHORIZED HIS SERVICES
FOR HIM SINCE HIS LAST IN 2020
THREE. DIRECT SUPPORT SERVICES
NEED LIVABLE WAYS TO SUPPORT OUR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU. HØI KELLY
PENNINGTON. THANK YOU, UM,
SENATOR AND COMMITTEE FOR
CHANGING THE WAY THAT THIS
WORKED SO THAT MANY OF OUR
CLIENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS COULD
BE HERE TO TESTIFY AND GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF 30 PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES THAT WERE HERE FROM 830
TO 1230 THAT HAD TO LEAVE DUE TO
BUSSING PROBLEMS WITH THEIR UM,
DAY PROGRAMS. BUT WE TRULY
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING THAT
ALTERATION SO THAT MANY PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO SPEAK. I ASKED THEM
AS THEY WERE LEAVING. I STOPPED
AND CHATTED WITH THEM. I'M A
PARENT OF SOMEBODY THAT THEY BRA
. BRADLEY IS MY SON AND THEY
PLAY SPECIAL OLYMPICS WITH HIM.
AND I ASKED THEM. WHAT'S YOUR
MESSAGE? I GUESS, SENATOR, I'LL
SEND YOU THAT PICTURE. UM I
ASKED WHAT THEIR MESSAGE WAS.
AND THEY SAID THAT, UM MOST OF
THE FAMILIES ARE FAMILIAR WITH
SELF-DETERMINATION AND SAID THAT
THAT WOULD NOT WORK FOR THEM.
DUE TO THEIR SCHEDULES AND
THINGS THEY REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER PROVIDES FOR THEM. THEY
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT A PERFECT
SYSTEM, BUT IT HAS HELPED THEM
TREMENDOUSLY. AND THE OTHER
THING THAT MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
ASKED ME TO SAY IS PLEASE HEAR
US. PLEASE SEE US AND PLEASE
SUPPORT US. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
HOPE THE PHOTO CAME OUT GOOD.
HØI. MY NAME IS NORMA RE I. I AM
A SOUTH ADVOCATE FOR MYSELF AND
MY COWORKERS FROM DARK FROM
FRESNO. AND PLEASE HELP US,
PLEASE. SO BECAUSE I WENT TO
SEVEN DIFFERENT JOB COACHES IN
MY PROGRAM, AND THAT HURTS ME
THAT THEY DON'T PASS THIS THEY
THAT WOULD JUST STAY HOME WITH
JUST LIVING A NECESSARY PLACE.
AND AS AND èC BR èC THE LAW
FOR ME AND I LIVE IN INDEPENDENT
ON MY OWN. FOR MANY YEARS WHEN I
WAS 27 YEARS OLD AND I WENT WITH
èC VÆ R SINCE SINCE I WAS 31
YEARS OLD. AND PLEASE HELP US,
PLEASE. SO THEY CAN GET MORE
STAFF TO TAKE US TO HELP US.
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS. THE
CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM IS IMPERATIVE TO ME AND
THE PEOPLE I SERVE. MY NAME IS
ALICIA CONLEY. I AM A PERSON
CENTERED ADVOCATE WITH THE ARC,
FRESNO MADERA COUNTIES. I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED A LIFE
CHANGING IMPACT OF THE SERVICES
REGIONAL CENTER PROVIDES THE
DELAY IN THE RATE REFORM WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
INDIVIDUALS I SERVE. PLEASE KEEP
YOUR PROMISE TO REGIONAL CENTERS
REGARDING RATE INCREASE TO
ENSURE SERVICES FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS I SERVE. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MÀ GAINES. I'M
FROM THE A F OF MADERA COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO HOPEFULLY HAVE
THEIR FUN. BE. BE UP SO WE CAN
KEEP THE STAFF BECAUSE I DO NOT
WANNA LOSE STAFF ANYMORE. I'VE
BEEN THROUGH STAFF FOR NINE
YEARS. THEY HELPED ME A LOT AND
HOPEFULLY THAT DOES NOT CHANGE.
HOPEFULLY, IT'LL KEEP STUFF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WHEN I
STARTED A TODOS MY NAME IS NORMA
RAMOS. I SERVE AS THE IMMEDIATE
PAST CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL CENTER. I AM A PARENT
TO A YOUNG MAN WHO IS SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER. HE'S 19
YEARS OLD, AND HE HAD BEEN
SERVED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER
SINCE HE WAS 18 MONTHS. SO WE'VE
BEEN IN THE IN THE SYSTEM FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. UM THE REASON
FOR ME BEING HERE, UM, FROM SAN
DIEGO IS TO SHARE THAT I HAVE TO
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OF BEING A
BOARD MEMBER AND A PARENT. I
KNOW THE FRUSTRATIONS THAT
PARENTS FEEL WHEN TRYING TO
ACCESS SERVICES. BUT I ALSO KNOW
HOW HARD THE STAFF AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER WORKS FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT THEY SERVE SO I
COULD GET TO SEE BOTH SIDES. UM
AGAIN. MY SON HAD PICTURES OF
HIM LIVING A FULL LIFE BECAUSE
WE SUPPORT HIM. REGIONAL CENTER
PROVIDES 40 HOURS OF RESPITE. UH
HOURS FOR MY SON. BUT WE ONLY
USE 20 HOURS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF THAT THAT THAT IS
NEEDED FOR HIS CARE. HE NEEDS
HELP WITH TOILE WITH BATHING
WITH FEEDING WITH, UH, GETTING
THEM DRESSED. WE CAN'T HIRE
SOMEBODY THAT GETS PAID CLOSE TO
MINIMUM WAGE TO DO THE WORK THAT
IS REQUIRED. PLEASE REJECT THE
RATE DELAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK IN THE MASTER PLAN.
STAKEHOLDER MÐI NOMBRES LUCERO
LOPEZ SO IN MADRE DE OSOS
SPECIALIST QUÊ PER NATIONAL
CENTRO Dð COST LAS MULTIPLES.
FAS IVA QUÊ SONOS ROJOS CONO
SYSTEM DE LOS CENTROS DEOS LIST
DESPER ALTA PARATO TERM FOR MAO.
I LÀ OTRA DE LOS PROBLEMAS CON
DE LÀ DEE LÀ MIA DEL CAMINO
QUANTUM CUENTAS OTRA PERSONA
FACILITATOR QUETA TERMINA PROO
10 CESAR DE SERO UN CUENTO DE
UNCA. IS THE. PERSONAS QUÊ LÀ
ESPERA NOSOTROS QUEREMOS PARTE
DE ESTE PROCESO. JOIN ME, PERNIA
. I CIENTO MUCH DE SAD AND DE PL
NOSOTROS TAOS MUCHO PARA MASSO
SPECIAL PEDANT TENER CERVI DE
CUERO UNIDAD ILO POCOS SERVICESS
QUEDA NOS ROCIO SENORA OKA WHEN
I STARTED, UM IN HOMBRE ES
JUANITA SANTA CRUZ, EVEN GO DEL
CENTRO REGION, DECO. UM FOR MY
MOTHER TO SEE. UM CONO UNO DE VÀ
DE TRES, UM. OR AS A CAMINO DE
JAMON FAMI FAMILIAS PORRA.
ASSISTANT RESO. VÀ VÀ. MADRI.
INS INS CUANDO NOS NE NÓ
CERVICIS. CERVICIS, AS MUST BE
NON GROUP. NÓ, UH RAZA DE COLOR
BLANCO, PERO YO ESTESO OR MUCH
DISCRIM IS THE UM. PERO SI. UN
MINI A QUICK QUESTION IS THERE
ANYONE FROM THE DEPARTMENT?
THAT'S UN UNDERSTANDING THE
SPANISH OK? UH SO YOU ME? YO
MADRE DE UNA AND NIQUE SYNDROME.
KONDO YER PRIMERA VEZ NÓ. CENTAL
YO NÓ FOR I èC GRACIAS. YOU.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR ROTH I THERE'S
ONE COMMENT THAT I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU YOU HERE TOO. UM AND
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME I'VE
HEARD IT FROM MONOLINGUAL
SPANISH SPEAKERS IS THAT IS WHEN
A MOM COMES TO A REGIONAL CENTER
TO ASK FOR SUPPORT. ONE OF THE
PHRASE THEY GET IS WHEN ARE YOU
GOING TO START BEING A REAL
MOTHER? BECAUSE THEY'RE COMING
TO ASK FOR HELP. FOR THEM COME
AND ASK FOR HELP AT REGIONAL
CENTERS DEEMS THEM AS A BAD
MOTHER. BECAUSE I GUESS THEY'RE
THEY THEY NEED TO DO IT ON THEIR
OWN, AND THAT TENDS TO HAPPEN A
LOT WITH OUR BPO COMMUNITIES.
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS. MY NAME IS
JILL MARTIN. I WORK AT AVENUE
SUPPORTED LIVING SERVICES AND
INDIVIDUALS ARE WITH ME. THEY'RE
ALSO WITH AVENUES AND, UM, I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IT
BOILS DOWN TO. WHICH IS THE
QUALITY OF LIFE. UM, I'M
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE THAT I
WORK WITH THAT I COORDINATE AND
SUPPORT I HAVE FOR ALMOST 30
YEARS. UH, SOME OF THEM HAVE
SERIOUS HEALTH ISSUES. SOME OF
THEM I HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN
THROUGH HOSPICE AND WITHOUT THAT
EXTRA SUPPORT AND EXTRA TRAINING
. WE CAN'T DO THOSE THINGS AND
I'VE GOT SOME PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH ISSUES. SO WE
NEED THAT FUNDING NOT TO BE CUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. REALLY?
YEAH. GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS Tð.
WHAT WAS AND HE LEFT IN OUR OWN
APARTMENT. BUT YOU SEE THAT? FOR
22 YEARS RECEIVING SUPPORTING
THE UM, FUNCTION AFTER HER. YOU
SEE ME SEARCHING IN I'VE SEEN  N
1993. MAN REGION èC SEVEN PER
TO BE P èC TO PAY FOR A AND THE
COACHES. HE RECEIVE ME AND AM
JING JOBS. THANK THANK YOU. I'M
GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
VOUCHER. YEAH. YEAH. YEAH. AND
THIS IS CHERYL MAYFIELD. AND I'M
JUST GONNA DO THE INTRO AND TURN
OVER TO HER. I AM A CHRISTIAN, A
BOARD MEMBER, A FRIEND AND AN
AUTHOR. AND SHE LIVES NEAR YOU
IN, UH, MISSION HILLS. THIS IS
MY CONSTITUENT AND BUDDY AND
JILL. ALSO ALL OF US. DID I HEAR
HIM SAY REITA? YES, I THOUGHT I
HEARD OF RAITA. UM OH, MM. UH,
YEAH. UM A SOMEONE WHO HAS
RELIED ON SERVICES ALL MY LIFE.
OH, I DON'T KNOW. YEAH. I'VE HAD
A HARD JOURNEY. YEAH. YES.
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
UNDERFUNDED. YEAH. MAKING IT
DIFFICULT. WELL. DID. TO HIRE
THE STAFF. I NEED GOODNESS. UM
THE PEOPLE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THE PEOPLE MOST IMPORTANT TO ME.
UH, PUT YEAH. NÓ ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO SUPPORT ME. HAVE DAILY
CONVERSATION WITH ME, NOT THE
PEOPLE WHO SIT BEHIND A DESK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'LL SEE YOU
IN MISSION HILLS, OK? YEAH WE'RE
GONNA COME SEE YOU IN APRIL. WE
GOTTA GO READY. SO MY NAME IS
RUBY GONZALEZ AND I AM FOR SALE
MORE. CALIFORNIA GOES TO VISUAL
HILLS ALSO, AND I CAN SUPPORT
SHE AND MY BROTHER. MY BROTHER
ALSO HAVE, UM GENE DISABILITIES.
I AND PERNIA. TENGO VÀ. VÀ. I
NOTE L LÀ PAGA. MARIA DE STAIR.
SO HØI BILE. S¼. GRACIAS.
GRACIAS. AND I'M SCOTT SHEPHERD
AND ALSO WITH AVENUE SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES WE PROVIDE
SUPPORTS IN SAN FERNANDO AND
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY AREAS, AND,
UH, OVER 70% OF THE PEOPLE WE
SUPPORT NEED 24 7 CARE, BUT THEY
ALL LIVE IN THEIR OWN PLACE.
HAVE JOBS AND, UH WE PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED OVER 40% OF
OUR STAFF HAVE BEEN WITH US FOR
10. YEARS OR MORE. IT'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE WAGE. IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE RELATIONSHIP THEY
DEVELOP WITH PEOPLE. AND, UH,
WE'RE WE'RE ALL WE ALL HAVE GRAY
HAIR. SO WE'RE HOPING THAT
BEFORE WE DIE THAT THE MASTER
PLAN WILL BE IMPLEMENTED, UM
I'VE GOT TO SAY I'M NOT
INCREDIBLY OPTIMISTIC BECAUSE I
THINK AS YOU SAID EARLIER, MADAM
CHAIR THAT THE NEED IS NOW SO
AGAIN. WE HOPE OUR OUR THAT I'M
WRONG. BUT A MASTER PLAN FOR THE
SYSTEM IS A SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
WHOSE QUALITY HAS BEEN
UNRAVELING IN THE PAST DECADE
DUE TO UNDERFUNDING SEEMS TO BE
A PIPE DREAM. UM AGAIN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. UM AND WE
URGE YOU NOT TO DELAY THE
PROVIDER INCREASE. AND MAYBE FOR
THAT WARM SHUTDOWN AT FAIRVIEW.
MAYBE WE FIND A WAY TO EITHER
SELL IT. OR KEEP THAT MONEY IN
THE SYSTEM. UH, THAT WOULD BE
GOOD, BECAUSE, UH, WE SERVE SOME
PEOPLE THAT USED TO LIVE IN THAT
PLACE. THANK YOU, SIR. NÓ.
PAMELA. GRACIA. A LADA DE MICA
CAMBIO ITS AI ELSA DEL CENTRO.
WE JUST GRADUATED, WHICH IS
GRACIAS A BEY. FLA. LÀ LÀ ZUMBA
MISTA COMIS AMIGOS. I. WHEN I
START NOREA LÀ LÀ SO IN MY
MOTHER, TREJOS MARSO ATTEN PUN
CENTRAL REGIONAL NECESITAMOS QUÊ
LÀ PETA FOR DICE. MOSQUE. GRAS.
UH, WHEN I STARTED PARADOS I
MEAN HOMBRES MARIA GUTIERREZ. SO
IN MY MOTHER THAT GUTIERREZ UM A
NECESITAMOS. CONSIST
TRANSPARENCIA DESALES, MANUEL
MANO PARA LÀ VIDA ESTE, MASS DE
LAS FAMILIAS. IT. I SUPPORT A
ME. I WANT TO BE FRIENDS. YEAH,
I GUTIERREZ GRAIN CONTENT ON IN.
OK, SO AS A FACIL NORAS BY THE,
UH. OLA. Kò A PO, UH, ARE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT THE I DON'T
SPEAK TOO MUCH ENGLISH, BUT I
WANNA TRY TO EXPLAIN TO I WANT
TO. I WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM IS CRE IN OCTOBER. 2013
FOR THE GOVERN THE GOVERNING
MOON AND MOON BROWN. AND SHE
SAID INTO THE LAW TO CREATE THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR FAMILIES
WITH A MORE FREEDOM CONTROL AND
RESPONSIBILITY, RESPONSIBILITY
IN CHOOSING SERVICE AND SUPPORTS
SO MEANS UM THIS IS CREATING.
THIS IS THE LAW. AND THEN TODAY.
I HEAR ABOUT THIS PROGRAM ABOUT
THE PLAN. UM LET'S SEE THE PLAN.
MASTER PLAN THE MASTER PLAN, WHY
NOT IN SELF DETERMINATION? THE
MASTER PLAN? WHY NOT PUT THE, UH
TRANSPORTATION THE EDUCATION?
UH, ADD TO THE SELF
DETERMINATION THE MASTER PLAN
PUT AT OVER THERE LIKE A
HOUSING, EMPLOYMENT
TRANSPORTATION. THOSE WORDS SAY.
DDS PAGE ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN
IN SELF DETERMINATION. UH TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE PEOPLE. UM
FOLLOWING THIS THIS PLAN. WELL,
THANK YOU FOR THE FERNANDO
GOVENS JUDY MARQUE. AND I èC
ELIZABETH GÓMEZ. UM THANK YOU,
JOHN. THANK MANY PEOPLE, UH, DO
IT FOR THIS. ALL THIS? THESE
PLANS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE. YOU DIDN'T SAY YOU
WERE. HE'S PAMELA'S BROTHER, THE
ZUMBA. THANK YOU FOR OH, SORRY.
THANK YOU FOR TONY TO FOR, UH,
FOR THE BALI CENTER REGIONAL DE
STOCKTON, THE DIRECTOR. OK? YES,
THERE IS A. ON MY NAME IS FINE.
FRANCISCO. NAME IS JUAN
FRANCISCO PEREZ. AYE. WORK. LIKE
. USE. OH,
THESE SO. YEAH. SEE SERVICES. NÓ
PROVIDERS. I WOULD LIKE TO
CHOOSE MY OWN SERVICES AND
PROVIDERS. AYE. OH, COURT. B.
138 I SUPPORT THIS, THE 138.
THANK YOU. MY I 100. NÓ THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GRISEL
DE ESTRADA. ISOLA MADRE DE JUAN
PEREZ IS TE JUANA TRAS NOSE,
GRACIA SALAO, THE DISPOSITIVE DE
COMMUNIC E LAA PUEDE DESIR. HOY
PARA PORTAL QUÊ EL SENOR
FERNANDO GÓMEZ LAS RADIO DEAR
AND IN LUGO. Dð PARTICIPANT,
COMO EL QUIRE LEOS PRODO AO LAST
PERSON AS IN DEO ALEE CONTRA
AGAINST OF PERSONALITY AND SOAR.
VIR TAMBIÉN DEAR EL DERE A THE
èC. I PROVE TAMBIÉN CITA
CONSIST, CALIDAD EQUID IS WE IS
THE RESPECT OF PLAN MAESTRO GLOO
SOLICITS QUESA CæA LÀ COMUNIDAD
REPRESENTANTES DE LAS MINOR IS
THE MESA PARTICIPANT DE TRAJAN
TOMAN DESS YO QUEREMOS NA. MÁS
DE LÀ PLATA. GRACIAS MUY MARLI.
èC M. ANDREA. ESTAMOS AND NOT
DETER PEROLA MULTIPLES. BARRERA
I PROMA CON FME Dð  N A DES D¯ÚI
ARI DELANO PAO QUÊ NÓ CELE PAGA
CINCO IN NOS ADO FOR WHAT? FOR
THE LÀ. LÀ DANZA DEL CENTRO
REGION IN A PROBL PLAN. DE GS IS
THE MASS THE PREVIOUS, UH, YOUNG
MAN THAT CAME AND SPOKE WITH THE
VOICE. DEVICE. UM SHE HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CLIENT AND
HASN'T BEEN PAID BY REGIONAL
CENTER TO CLOSE TO ALMOST SIX
MONTHS AND HASN'T LEFT THE
CLIENT. AND SO THE MOM WAS HERE,
SHARING ANOTHER STORY. HOW IT
LAGS FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO PAY
VENDORS AND SO FORTH, BUT SHE'S
CONTINUED TO WORK WITH THE
CLIENT. WELL I WHEN I START TO
ESTE NOMBRES MARIA GRANADOS, SO
I MADE DOS IOS CON DISABILITY
THAT CASA. AQUI. FOR SOME SURVEY
HOLD THE CHICO AND ET CETRA
CANAL, OUR AURA MIJO UM Tð  N,
UM EL DERECHO THE BUS CAROS
PROGRAMAS OR BOCAO PROGRAMAS
CALE HTA ESTÁN CANTA IN THE
LOCAL UH, PHONE CAN BE A BUENO
PARA PORQUE PARA COME YOU DE
VIDA FUE PO. UH, FU Ó. UH, WHAT
ARE COM KENYA? YO TENGO ME
CIENTO MEJOR PORQUE IN CASA I
PUES AQUITA MIJO ELES. YEAH.
HELLO MY NAME IS OMAR GRANADOS.
I AM 26 YEARS SOON TO BE 27 AND
I AM WAS BORN WITH AUTISM. I
LIVE WITH MY PARENTS STILL AND I
ACTUALLY HAVE A FEW HOBBIES THAT
I ACTUALLY LIKE TO SHARE THAT I
ENJOY DIGITAL SKETCH DRAWING.
AND I GO TO GYM TO THE GYM IN MY
HOMETOWN, 5 TO 6 DAYS A WEEK.
PROXY NOE MIJO BARRE SARAS, WHO?
COLEGIO TOMO EL SUPPORT AN THEE
ANOS ATRAS, A MIJO BAR REGRESAR
COLE AND PORQUE AUTO DE TERM. I
èC èC A CONS. UH PARA STELI
LOCAL OCCUPY A LOCAL CAR, SIR.
SIR. MIRES ALEJANDRA IS SO MÀ
MÁS NINOS CENTE. IS TOYA PARAGRA
DE èC. I èC èC QUÊ ACEDO ALOS
CONI YAS MUCHOS PROBLEMAS COMIN
SOUTHEAST MURO NÓ SAVIA LOS
CERVICIS CAVIA. PERO GRACIAS I
èC èC MÐI JOO CERVICIS ARADO
MUCHOS COMOS MÀ YO TA MILO
SERVISS, ANA AND NERO. I MÀ DE
SU PORQUE UNA FOR MAMA FACIL
PARA SO QUESTA AND ESTE PROCESS
GRACIAS. WHICH IS GRACIAS. UH
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UM THEY I AM
HERE IN REPRESENTATION OF MY SON
, WHO IS 25 YEARS OLD AND HAS
AUTISM AND, UM I Dð Dð.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE COULDN'T BE
HERE. BECAUSE CROWDS LIKE THIS
MAKE CAN BECOME DEREGULATED. MY
SON IS IN THE IN THE
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM. I AM
HERE TO EXPRESS TO THIS
COMMITTEE. WE SUPPORT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. UM, IT'S
A WONDERFUL PROGRAM. BUT WE ARE
HERE TO REQUEST THE STATE. YOU
GUYS, UH, TO HELP US. BREAK DOWN
THE BARRIERS. PARTICIPANTS ARE,
UM, ARE FACING IN THE WHICH ARE
SO PARTICIPANTS ARE FACING IN
THE PROGRAM. UM SO, UM THEY, UM
TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
THEIR SERVICES AND PROVIDERS IN
THE WOODS IN THE GOODS THEY
CHOOSE. UM FINALLY, UM, I ASK
YOU TO GIVE US THE OPTION TO
MAINTAIN THE ZOOM, UH, OPTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. HØI GOOD AFTERNOON,
EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS JOSE MUNOZ
. UH, I HAVE A YOUNGER SISTER
WHO IS ON THE SPECTRUM, AND IT'S
A PARTICIPANT IN THE
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THE
IMPACT THAT THE PROGRAM HAS HAD
ON MY SISTER'S LIFE CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED. IT HAS PROVIDED HER
WITH THE CONFIDENCE AND
FOUNDATION TO LEAD A NORMAL
LIFE. ALTHOUGH THIS IS TRUE, WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED MANY BARRIERS
THAT KEEP THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM FROM BEING AS EFFECTIVE
AS IT POSSIBLY COULD BE. WE ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT EACH
INDIVIDUAL'S FREEDOM TO SELECT
THE PROVIDERS AND SERVICES THAT
THEY SEE BEST FIT FOR THEIR
INDIVIDUAL SCENARIOS. AND ALONG
WITH THIS FREEDOM I HOPE THAT WE
ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT NOT
EVERYONE IS IN A POSITION TO
SPEND MONTHS WAITING ON THE END
OF THE PROGRAM. AND WE REQUIRE
THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO PROMPTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY AUTHORIZE FM S¼,
SO PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF AND I
IMAGINE MANY OTHERS IN THIS ROOM
. UM DO NOT MISS OUT ON VITAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SERVICES.
THANK YOU. GOD BLESS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I. I MEAN, I WOULD
WANNA POINT OF PRIVILEGE HERE. I
HAVE, UH S¼ B 1281 THAT IS
LOOKING TO MODERNIZE. UM THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM AND I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE ADVOCATES TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THAT BILL.
POINT OF PRIVILEGE OVER BUT I
MEAN NOMBRES, CONSUELO CARDENAS
MUNOZ, SOY MADRE DE UNA CAPA DE
DE ARROYO, MIJA PARTICIPANT
EINION GRACIOSA THE PROGRAM A
MÐI CONTRA SUBO TALENTO ABA DE
TRABAJO EQUIPO CONO CERVICIS I
CERVICIS I A POOS AS NEDA DE
UNAS LUCHA PARD THE BOARD IN THE
GRAZA LÀ COMIDA APES DESSA THE
GRUPO. THE APOLLO IS VICIOUS.
OK? UM TÂM EXIST A ERAS PROGRAM
PROGRAM. LOS B  N èC SERVICES
AT QUIS AND EL PLAN DE GASTOS
NEST OBLIGADO ARE NÓ CERVICIS
QUÊ COMPONENT EL PRESO
INDIVIDUAL. GRACIAS. GRACIAS.
BUENAS AIRES. GRACIAS, FORESTER
FOR S¼. SO MADRE MINOS BLANCA
MERCADO. SO IN MADRE DE UNO
CONO. WHO UH, LÀ RAZON SO ES
PORQUE. DE SAR. DE SARO AND SA.
UM THERE IS A KLM PERSONA
PROGRAM A DIÆN. P, A PESO DE
CIRQUE YATE PORQUE NÓ CREEL.
GRASS, PROGRAMAS AND ULA PARTIC
I INTEGRA. LRE SORE. I. VANS,
AND BRAD IS THE TO COMIDA CONES.
CAPA QUÊ POR CONTIN APOLLO OUT
THE TERMINATION. TERMINO. AS
UNZA. THE CALIDAD DE VIDA PARA
NUESTROS UNA UNA DE UNA MEJOR AS
SUAS. GRACIAS, OSS. MY NAME IS
DORIC CONTRERAS AND I TO SPEAK.
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE FROM THE
SAME AREA THAT COME TOGETHER. I
THINK YOU'VE SEEN ME BEFORE.
RIGHT I'M GRANDMOTHER TO A 31
YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN THAT I RAISED
FROM THE TIME HE WAS A TODDLER.
HE'S HAD A LOT OF TRAUMA IN HIS
LIFE. CONSEQUENTLY HE'S VERY
AGGRESSIVE AND HAS A LOT OF
BEHAVIORS WHEN HE WAS 12 THE
REGIONAL CENTER EVER ADVOCATED
FOR HIM. IN FACT, THEY SUGGESTED
THAT I PUT HIM IN A CARE HOME. I
WAS SINGLE. I WAS A SINGLE
GRANDMA SO WORKING FULL TIME AS
A SCHOOL TEACHER AND PRINCIPLE.
SO AT 12 YEARS OF AGE, I PUT HIM
IN A SERIES OF GROUP HOMES WHICH
CAUSED HIM A LOT OF TRAUMA AND
TERRIBLE THINGS THAT HAPPENED TO
HIM WHEN COVID HIT. I BROUGHT
HIM HOME AND THANK YOU TO THE
ICC THAT I DISCOVERED THEY
HELPED ME BE ABLE TO GET
SERVICES FOR HIM TO HAVE THE 24
7 CARE NOW HE HAS PROVIDERS THAT
COME TO THE HOME AND HE THAT HE
CALLS HIS FRIENDS. SO I WONDER
WHY AT 12 I WAS NOT OFFERED A
PERSONAL ASSISTANT. WHY I DID
NOT HAVE ANY OTHER SERVICES
OFFERED TO ME AT THAT. POINT SO
THAT I COULD KEEP HIM AT HOME. I
IT HAD TO BE THE COVID FOR ME TO
SAY I HAVE TO TAKE MY GRANDSON
BACK BECAUSE IN CONGREGATE
SETTINGS, WE ALL KNOW WHAT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED. PLEASE HELP US.
HOLD THE RE REGIONAL CENTERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUNG MEN LIKE
MY SERGIO. IT'S TIME FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE FAMILIES
WITH ZERO SERVICES PROVIDE FOR
ALL TO GIVE EVERYBODY THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR
US. I'M MAUREEN FITZGERALD AND I
HAVE FRIENDS WHO ARE SERVED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM. I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO FIX THE $14
BILLION DATA HOLE IN THE DDS
MASTER PLAN. WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS. PUBLIC
EDUCATION. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. REGIONAL
CENTERS AREN'T WE NEED THEM TO
BE IF YOU'RE GOING TO REALLY LET
US DO A MASTER PLAN? WE NEED
ACCESS TO THE DATA, AND THE
REGIONAL CENTER DATA IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND LASTLY, I DON'T
THINK MOST PEOPLE REALIZE THAT
14 OF THE 21 REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE MEMBERS OF CALPERS. I'D SAY
IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF CALPERS,
THEY'RE PUBLIC AGENCIES, AND I
HOPE YOU'LL POTENTIALLY STRIP IT
OUT OF A B 1147, WHICH IS ON
SENATE THIRD READING WITH NOT A
SINGLE NÓ VOTE AND PUT IT IN THE
TRAILER BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS STEVO
GUERRA. I REPRESENT THE ARC,
FRESNO, MADERA COUNTY AS A
SPECIAL PROJECT COORDINATOR AS A
Dð S¼ P MYSELF. I HAVE SEEN THE
DRASTIC CUTS OF STAFF THAT HAS
RESULTED IN THE LOSS OF
INDIVIDUAL RELATIONSHIPS. IT
BREAKS MY HEART, MORE AND MORE
AFTER EACH CONVERSATION WE HAVE
WITH OUR INDIVIDUALS THAT THEIR
DEAR THAT THEIR Dð S¼ P IS NÓ
LONGER WITH THE COMPANY. IT
BRINGS ME SUCH SADNESS TO SEE
OUR INDIVIDUALS LOSE A LITTLE
BIT OF LOSE A LITTLE BIT OF
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY GROW AN
ATTACHMENT TO A Dð S¼ P, AND
THEY HAVE TO LEAVE BECAUSE OF
PAY. I HAVE SEEN TOO MANY Dð S¼
P S¼ COME AND GO WITHIN OUR
PROGRAM AND, UNFORTUNATELY PAYS
HUGE REASON TO WHY THEY LEAVE.
I'M NOT HERE FOR PAY, BECAUSE
ONCE I STARTED THE ART, I KNEW
THIS WAS MY CALLING. BUT
ULTIMATELY, ULTIMATELY, THIS
WILL BENEFIT THOSE WHO HAVE A
VOICE, BUT SOMEHOW THEY ARE
BEING IGNORED, WHICH ARE ARE
INDIVIDUALS. LET'S MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS BUDGET SO WE CAN
SUPPORT THOSE WHO NEED IT. THE
MOST ARE INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HØI MY
NAME IS JEANNIE RIDER AND I'M A
MOM OF 14 8 OF THE CHILDREN THAT
I HAVE HAVE BEEN SERVED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS. SO I PICKED
ONE BECAUSE I KNEW I DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF THEM.
BUT UM KAYLA CAME TO ME WHEN SHE
WAS FOUR, AND SHE HAD BEEN
ABUSED AND NEGLECTED AND HAS
AUTISM. AND SO HER TRUST LEVELS
ARE REALLY, REALLY LOW. AND WHEN
I FIRST GOT HER, SHE WOULDN'T
EVEN LEAVE. S¼ FOR ABOUT SIX
MONTHS. SHE WOULD SCREAM EVERY
TIME I EVEN WENT TO THE BATHROOM
BECAUSE SHE WAS SCARED, AND, YOU
KNOW, NOW SHE'S 32 YEARS OLD.
SHE LIVES INDEPENDENTLY IN HER
OWN HOME 24 HOUR AWAKE STAFF
BECAUSE SHE REQUIRES TO HAVE A
WAKE STAFF AT ALL TIMES WHEN HER
STAFF LEAVES HER BECAUSE THEY
GET A BETTER JOB. IT'S REALLY
TOUGH FOR HER. IT'S REALLY,
REALLY HARD AND THEY'RE NOT
MAKING A LIVING WAGE THERE, YOU
KNOW, QUALIFYING FOR FOOD STAMPS
, HAVING TO GO TO THE FOOD BANK
TO GET FOOD TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES. WE NEED THEM TO GET A
LIVING WAGE. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR ALL OF OUR PEOPLE. THANK YOU
FOR SHARING HER STORY. UM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS SANDY
MARTIN AND I HAVE A SON WITH
DOWN SYNDROME AND AUTISM. THE
ADDITIONALLY I'M ALSO AN ARCHED
DEEG AND I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR ORANGE COUNTY
REGIONAL CENTER. MY SON HAS A
PERSON CENTERED PLAN AND HE
SERVED VERY WELL BY THE REGIONAL
CENTER. UM HIS PLAN INCLUDES
RESPITE AND JOB COACHING.
UNFORTUNATELY THE RESPITE GOES
UNCOMMITTED BECAUSE THE LOCAL
VENDORS DON'T HAVE PEOPLE. WORSE
WHEN THEY DO COME. THEY ASK IF
WE WILL PAY THEM ON THE SIDE. SO
BECAUSE THEY'RE DESPERATE NOT
BECAUSE BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE
NOT BEING PAID. ADDITIONALLY MY
SON'S BEEN WORKING FOR SEVEN
YEARS IN A RESTAURANT NEAR OUR
HOME. IT'S BEEN LIFE CHANGING.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO FOR OUR COMMUNITY. HE
WORKS ALONGSIDE EVERYBODY. HE'S
HE'S ASKED SO MUCH PRIDE. HE'S
GOT STRUCTURE. IT'S FABULOUS. HE
ALSO WORKED. HE ALSO IS PAID
MORE THAN HIS JOB COACH OF SEVEN
YEARS. HIS JOB COACHES
WONDERFUL. HE'S A MEMBER. OF THE
FAMILY, BUT HE INFORMED ME THAT
HE MAY LEAVE TO WORK IT IN AND
OUT. BECAUSE HE WILL MAKE MORE
MONEY THERE. THANK YOU. UM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND I HOPE
THAT WE GET THE VENDOR INCREASE.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
PAULINA GAMA. I COME FROM COUNTY
AND I AM HERE TO SPEAK UP TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT MY SERVICES.
I GO TO MORE IN VINTAGE DAY
PROGRAM AND I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT BECAUSE I HAVE A VERY
GOOD STAFF AND GOOD SUPPORTING,
AND I ALSO I HAVE A JOB TOO, BUT
I JUST WANTED TO CONTINUE AND I
AM VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND
DEFEND MYSELF THAT I AM HERE TO
SPEAK UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS. SO MUCH FOR COMING.
HELLO. THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. MY NAME IS ALEX
MELFORD. I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESCUE
ASSOCIATION. SO I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE RESPITE SERVICES.
YOU CAN RAISE THE MIC. I DON'T
KNOW. I DIDN'T WANT IT. THE
NOISE WAS BOTHERING ME AS WELL
TOO. SO THERE WE GO. PERFECT NÓ.
OH, SO CLOSE. UM SO I WANNA ECHO
ALL OF THE SENTIMENTS TOO, ABOUT
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT THE RATE
STUDY. THIS IS CRITICAL,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE WORKFORCE.
RESPITE IS A CORE SERVICE THAT
OFTEN LINKS PEOPLE. ONE OF THE
FIRST TOUCH POINTS WITH PEOPLE
GETTING CONNECTED WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE. IN A
CRITICAL SERVICE THAT HELPS
TRANSITION TO ADULT SERVICES AS
WELL SPECIFICALLY FOR RESPITE.
ONE OF THE CORE PROBLEMS IN THE
RATE STUDY IS THAT, ADDITIONALLY
FOR ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS, THE ASSUMED
PAY RATE FOR RESPITE WORKERS IS
1530 THREE. THAT'S 67 CENTS
BELOW THE PRESCRIBED CALIFORNIA
MINIMUM WAGE AND SO RESPITE
PROVIDERS ARE HAVING TO MAKE
THAT UP WITH THE REST OF THEIR
RATE IS A CRITICAL ASPECT OF
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT THE RATE
STUDY ON THE CURRENT TIMELINE
AND ADDRESS THESE DISPARITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH. HELLO MY NAME IS ED
SKIS AND I REPRESENT MANOS HOME
CARE AND THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
DELAY WOULD DESTABILIZE
CALIFORNIANS WITH I Dð Dð, THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR SERVICE
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS THEM. IT
WILL DECREASE THE ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED NOW, UH,
WITH EVEN MORE STAFF, TURNOVERS,
AND MORE VENDORS WILL BE FORCED
TO ULTIMATELY CLOSE HIS DOORS.
CURRENTLY ORGANIZATION HAS 150
INDIVIDUALS ON THE WAITLIST
BECAUSE WE'RE UNABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH STAFFING DEMANDS. AND WITH
THE PROPOSED BUDGET THAT LAY THE
PROMINENCE WILL OBVIOUSLY WILL
MAKE MATTERS SIGNIFICANTLY
WORSE. BUT NOW RECEIVING
SERVICES THAT THEY CURRENTLY
NEED. THEY WILL REQUIRE THEM TO
ACCESS MORE INTENSIVE AND
EXPENSIVE SERVICES LATER IN
LIFE. AND WE COULD ALL ASSURE
YOU, IT IS LESS EXPENSIVE TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST NOW, RATHER
THAN ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
LATER. TO REBUILD THE SYSTEM
AFTER THE ROADS. CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE COUNTING
ON THE LEGISLATOR TO DELIVER THE
PROMISE ON THE LANTERMAN ACT.
PLEASE REJECT THE RATE DELAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OH, NÓ
NERVOUS NOW. GOOD I'M NOT EITHER
. OK MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STAFF
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF S¼ RU
, CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF MY TWO DECEASED COUSINS WHO,
IF THERE WAS A LANTERMAN SYSTEM
THEY MIGHT STILL BE ALIVE, BUT
THEY END UP IN MONTANA AND WHAT
REALLY BOTHERS ME IS THE SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW IS DYSFUNCTIONAL. IT'S
NOT WORKING. AND IF THE RATE
STUDY DOESN'T HAPPEN, ALL THE
PLANS FOR GOING FORWARD WITH THE
MASTER PLAN ARE BASED ON NÓ
FOUNDATION WHATSOEVER BECAUSE
THE RATES THAT PEOPLE GET PAID
NOW THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY Dð S¼ P
S¼. THEY'VE GOTTEN 53,000 SIGNED
UP FOR THE CLASS TO GET THE
STIPENDS. THE DATA SHOWS THERE
SHOULD BE 100 AND 18,000 IN
CALIFORNIA, SO THERE'S NÓ NÓ WAY
TO EVEN LOCATE THE PEOPLE,
RIGHT? SO OUR OUR OUR PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN SYSTEM OR MOSTLY SERVICE
COORDINATORS AT REGIONAL CENTERS
. WE HAVE A FEW 100 WHO WORK
FOR, UH, PROVIDER AGENCIES, AND
THEY DO IT FOR LOVE, BUT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE. THANK YOU,
SIR. THANK YOU. IF MY NAME
MARSHALL DO YOU WANT TO SPEAK
FIRST? GO AHEAD. SECOND YEAR. GO
AHEAD, MARSHALL. A M MARCEL I
HAVE A CAR. HOW. I GOT GOOD
TOMORROW. TOMORROW IS BODY. THE
WEAKER I DO JB MY B. UM RIGHT?
AND I'M TIM, AN ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF MARINE VENTURES. UM
AND WE HAVE A FEW OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS HERE, INCLUDING
MARCIA. I JUST WANTED TO SPEAK
TO, UM THE RIGHT MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE HAD
STARTED TO MAKE INROADS WITH THE
FIRST PHASES IN ALLEVIATING SOME
OF OUR STAFFING PROBLEMS. AND
SINCE SINCE THE, UH THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WAS ANNOUNCED. WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED TO SEE SOME OF
THOSE INROADS ERODED. WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED TO SEE PEOPLE.
UH, LEAVING AFTER WE'D SEEN
PEOPLE COME BACK WHO'D LEFT US
BEFORE? UH, BECAUSE THEY LOVE TO
WORK. THEY LOVE THE WORK. THEY
LOVE THE JOB, AND THEY THEY WENT
TO OTHER OTHER POSITIONS WHERE
THEY COULD EARN MORE. I I'M ONE
OF THE ART THE ART STAFF THERE.
THE ART CREATIVE ARTS. EVERY
SUSY EVERY TUESDAY. YEAH, UM ALL
RIGHT NOW I'VE LOST MY TRAIN OF
THOUGHT. UH IN ANY CASE, UH, I
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO, UH,
REFUSE THE DELAY. UM, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKLAHOMA. OH, THANK
YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS, UH,
ANDREA BALL HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPEECH HEARING
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS WHO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AS THEIR VENDOR OR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. THROUGH THE
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM. WE
JOINED WITH THE LANMAN COALITION
AND OTHERS TO URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE DELAY IN THE RATE INCREASE.
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS. MANY OF
THEM ARE SMALL. CONSULTANT SMALL
FIRMS RUN BY WOMEN, UH MANY OF
THEM MORE AND MORE BILINGUAL,
AND THEY PROVIDE SERVICES THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO INFANTS AND
TODDLERS. AND WE KNOW WHEN WE
REACH YOUNG CHILDREN WITH THESE
SERVICES JUST IMPROVES THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT LIFE.
AND I ALSO WANNA THANK YOUR
STAFF. WE HAD THE CHANCE TO
SHARE WITH HER SOME OF THE MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE. UM
MADAM CHAIR. I JUST WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TOUGH QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ASKED TODAY AS WELL AS
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT MAKING THE I
Dð Dð, UH, COMMUNITY A PRIORITY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. MY NAME
IS TAMIKA HILL. I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE ARC
OF FRESNO IN MADERA COUNTIES. UM
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
DELAYING THE RATE STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION IT WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO OUR INDUSTRY. IT
WOULD HURT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS THAT RELY ON THESE
VITAL SERVICES AND STAFF. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR STAFF ARE
THE KEY. THERE WAS A PROMISE
THAT WAS MADE AND THAT PROMISE
SHOULD BE KEPT. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PASS THROUGH A MAJORITY
OF THAT WOULD GO TO THE DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS WITHOUT
THE WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL AND INTELLECTUAL
WILL FACE THE RAW REALITY OF
THEIR SERVICES NOT BEING MET. SO
THIS IS AN ENTITLEMENT THROUGH
THE LATMAN ACT, AND OUR FOLKS
DESERVE IT. I AM ASKING FOR THE
PROMISE TO BE KEPT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR, SENATOR ROTH STAFF. MY
NAME IS JORDAN. LINDSEY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARC OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE ARC
AND UNITED SUPER PALSY,
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AS WELL
AS CO CHAIR OF THE LETTERMAN
COALITION. AS YOU KNOW, THERE
HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
HERE TODAY AND THOUSANDS MORE
WATCHING ACROSS THE STATE, AND
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THERE IS
SHOCK AND DISMAY THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WANTS TO CUT $1 BILLION
FROM CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES,
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
WORKFORCE. THERE ARE ALREADY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ON WAIT
LISTS AND NOT RECEIVING THE
SERVICES THEY NEED. THIS CUT
WOULD CAUSE IMMEDIATE AND DIRECT
PAIN TO PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. SO
WHY WOULD GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION AIM THEIR
LARGEST SINGLE CUT IN HIS ENTIRE
BUDGET, LARGEST SINGLE CUT IN
HIS ENTIRE BUDGET AT
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES?
THIS COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY WHILE
WAGES ARE GOING TO INCREASE FOR
WORKERS IN HEALTHCARE SETTINGS
AND WORKERS IN FAST FOOD
SETTINGS, MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
HEARD STRONG COMMENTS COMING
FROM THE COMMITTEE ALREADY TODAY
ABOUT THE RATE MODEL DELAY AS WE
JUST HEARD FROM A SPEAKER. A LOT
OF DAMAGE IS ALREADY BEING DONE
JUST FROM THE PROPOSAL ITSELF.
I'VE HEARD THE ADMINISTRATION
SAY THIS IS A STARTING POINT
DAMAGE HAS ALREADY STARTED. WHAT
WE NEED FROM THE LEGISLATURE IS
A STRONG RESPONSE REJECTING THIS
IMMEDIATELY SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM
CHAIR, SENATOR ROTH. MY NAME IS
BARRY GIARDINI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION AND YET ANOTHER
CO-CHAIR OF THE LETTERMAN
COALITION. THERE ARE A LOT OF
US. UM I I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO TELL YOU ANYTHING YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD TODAY. UM WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE DELAY. WE KNOW THAT IT
WILL BE HARMFUL WHEN I HEAR THE
DEPARTMENT TALK ABOUT MAKING
THESE TOUGH BUDGET DECISIONS.
I'M NOT SURE THEY WANT TO DO IT
EITHER, RIGHT? BUT THIS IS MORE
THAN MATH. I GET PAID TO BE HERE
. MOST OF THE PEOPLE HERE ARE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES. THIS
IS WHAT MATTERS. SO THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO THEM. THANK YOU
FOR PARTNERING WITH US ON THIS.
I KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
FIND A SOLUTION TOGETHER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOU DID SAY
SOMETHING I HADN'T HEARD YET.
OH, OK. YEAH. HARD ACT TO FOLLOW
. UH MADAM CHAIR SENATOR ROTH
RAND MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
AVIANA HEALTHCARE. AVIANA IS ONE
OF THE LEADERS IN PROVIDING
DIRECT SERVICES TO ABOUT 25,000
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. UM, WE ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES. WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CUT ON THE RATE
DELAY. I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO RETAIN
PEOPLE. THE RATES THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED SO FAR HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL, BUT WE'RE SEEING THE
WORKFORCE ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY DOING MUCH
BETTER IN OTHER FIELDS THAN THEY
IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
FIELD. UM AND WE NEED TO
EQUALIZE THAT IN SOME WAY IN
ORDER TO KEEP OUR FOLKS ONE LAST
THOUGHT. I WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
AROUND OR IN THE DARK BUDGET
DAYS OF THE RECESSION. WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMETHING GETS
DELAYED A YEAR. IT DOESN'T GET
DELAYED A YEAR. IT GETS DELAYED
A SECOND YEAR OR THIRD YEAR AND
WE MAY NEVER SEE THAT MONEY.
COME WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. TRUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
ALICIA SCHOTT. I AM A PARENT OF
A REGIONAL CENTER. CONSUMER. UM
ECHO OTHER PARENTS WHO'VE
ALREADY BEEN UP HERE SAYING, YOU
KNOW, IT'S HARD TO GET THROUGH
Dð S¼ P S¼ TO COME IN AND DO
WORK, BUT ALSO I AM A BOARD
MEMBER, UM FOR A REGIONAL CENTER
, AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO GO INTO
SEVERAL FACILITIES VENDORS THAT
WE WORK WITH AND HEARD THEIR
COMPLAINTS THAT THEY ARE HAVING
HIGH TURNOVER RATES BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T KEEP STAFF WHEN TACO BELL
PAYS MORE SO I JUST WANTED TO
ECHO EVERYBODY ELSE SAYING THAT,
UM THEY'RE THEY'RE STRUGGLING,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO BE A LESSON
FOR THEM. BUT PLEASE. PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT OUR POLICE SO
THANK YOU. I HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE IN CARRUTHERS,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. THE
STATE COUNCIL IS A BODY OF
GOVERNORS, APPOINTEES AND PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES,
FAMILY MEMBERS AND AGENCIES HERE
TO ADVISE THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE ON ISSUES IMPACTING
THEM. THEY MET THIS WEEK TOOK A
NUMBER OF VOTES AND LETTERS WILL
BE FORTHCOMING AND EVERYTHING
I'M TALKING ABOUT FIRST ITEM IS
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. S¼ B 1281
ON SELF DETERMINATION. THANK YOU
FOR WRITING LEGISLATION BASED
OFF THE EVALUATION THAT THE
STATE COUNCIL ISSUED NEXT IS
URGING FLEXIBILITY FOR IP
MEETINGS. THIRD IS WELL, WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE RATE STUDY
AND ITS IMPACTS ON PROVIDERS. I
BROUGHT MY OWN TIMER, SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WATCH. UM THE
COUNCIL'S CONCERNED ABOUT ITS
IMPACT ON PEOPLE AND FROM THEIR
OWN EXPERIENCES THEMSELVES. WE
HAVE ON 11 HAND COUNCIL MEMBER
JULIE GD GET BATHE, GET GOING
FOR THE DAY AND ON THE OTHER
HAND, WE HAVE COUNCIL MEMBER
NICOLE ADLER, WHO IS HOSTING A
RADIO SHOW FOR PEOPLE CALLED THE
NÓ NÓ SHOW. OF ALL THE ISSUES
PEOPLE DEVELOP. DISABILITIES
SHOULDN'T BE TALKING ABOUT AND
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT HIM. SO UM,
ON THAT WHOLE CONTINUUM OF
EXPERIENCE, UH, THESE EXPERIENCE
WILL BE IMPACTED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LAST BUT NOT LEAST
MADAM CHAIR. I WISH I WAS
SERVING WITH YOU RIGHT NOW IN
THIS TIME, SO WE COULD DO THIS
TOGETHER, SENATOR ROTH, YOU AND
I THOUGHT MANY BATTLES TOGETHER.
I'M ASKING YOU, I'M IMPLORING
YOU TO REJECT THE DELAY. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WORKED ON IN
THIS LEGISLATURE TO PROMOTE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. AND WE CANNOT
RENEGE ON THAT PROMISE. WE HAVE
AN ABILITY. TO IMPROVE SERVICES.
WE HAVE AN ABILITY AND A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THESE
POPULATION THAT IS UNSURPASSED.
IT SITS ON YOUR HANDS OF HOW WE
NOW. CAN CONTINUE THAT PROMISE.
YOU ARE AMAZING CHAIR. I'VE SAT
HERE ALL DAY AND WATCHED YOU AND
I LOVED YOUR KNOWLEDGE. I KNOW
THE ELIZABETH IS A BIG PART OF
IT AND I. I COMMEND HER ALSO FOR
ALL OF THE BACKGROUND THAT SHE'S
DONE. BUT WE DO NEED YOU CHAIR.
TO TODAY TO ANNOUNCE THAT YOU
WILL REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WE NEED IT PUBLICLY,
AS DID ASSEMBLY MEMBER COREY
JACKSON WHEN HE DID HIS HEARING.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU DO THAT
THERE'S 35 SIGNATURES IN THE
ASSEMBLY RIGHT NOW CIRCULATING A
LETTER REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN
DO THE SAME IN THE SENATE ALSO.
BUT WE'RE HOPING THAT YOU COME
THROUGH THIS AFTER SEEING ALL OF
THESE FOLKS. UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACTS. OF WHAT THE WILL DO AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WHEN I STARTED RESALE, TAO
ME CORRESPOND, èC EVEN GUAPO
YANO DE TERMIN BARRERAS. MEI
LUCION. ALBERTO DOLO, LAS
PIEDRAS CAPONE AND EL CAMINO.
PARA CANNO QUITA EL ZUM. IT. LÀ
REUNION. SARA PROXIMA S¼ AS MUCH
PER S¼. A DEE PARAS PUEDAN DARE
TAMBIÉN OPINION YA MUCHAS
FAMILIAS VINE DE DE LEO. LÀ COSA
FUE SILLA FOCI IN FRENTE, PERO
COMO 10 TUVIMOS CINCO TEMAS
TUVIMOS CINCO TEMAS QUÊ ALAMOS.
COMMENTARY PUBLICO DEPO CADA UM
UM. YS SOME PERSONAS CONDI
CAPACIDAD DE YOU NÓ NÓ GUAN
MUCHOS TAQUI Tð. NÓ. MAMA 10 ON
EM IN MENTAL PALA PROXIMA QUÊ,
FERNANDO GÓMEZ JUDY MARQUI
ESPERO INOS NOSA YA PROVAS ES L
A GRACIAS. SEE NÓ OTHER FURTHER
COMMENT. I KNOW I WAS ASKED BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON MY STANCE
. I THINK I SAID IT EARLIER. YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS I'VE CHOSEN 34
ISSUES IN HÌ HÌ S¼ THAT I REALLY
WANNA UH, PUT MOST OF MY ENERGY
IN IN IN PRIORITIZING, REJECTING
THE DELAY OR CUTS AND THE DDS
RATE REFORM IS WITHIN MY, UM,
TOP FOUR PRIORITIES OF IT, UH,
WE ALL KNOW AND YOU KNOW,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. UM UM ALL OF
THIS IS A THREE PARTY THREE
PARTY DEAL, AND THIS ITEM IS
STILL OPEN AND WE'LL COME BACK
IN MAY, UM, WITH WHATEVER THE
DEPARTMENT IS GONNA COME BACK
WITH US, HOPEFULLY WITH A BETTER
PLAN AND TO SEE HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS BUT ALSO WITH THE MIND
THAT HOPEFULLY WITH A BETTER
PLAN. I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
UM, WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. ON THE
PRESCHOOL INCLUSION GRANTS
DELAY.
WELCOME BACK, CHIEF DEPUTY YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR CARLA CADA WITH DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ISSUE.
SIX IS THE PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE
PRESCHOOL INCLUSION GRANTS THESE
WERE AUTHORIZED IN THE 2022
BUDGET. UM THEY WERE INTENDED TO
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION IN
PRESCHOOL FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES, AS WELL AS TO
INTEGRATE INTO PROGRAMS WITH
CHILDREN WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
UM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. L A Ó. DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENT ON THIS? KARINA
HENDRA, EO. UM WE JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT GIVEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTS, MULTIYEAR
DEFICITS, THE PROPOSED DELAY
UNTIL 2026 27 IS BEST CONSIDERED
TO BE A REDUCTION IN EFFECT. UM
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER ELIMINATING THIS
PROGRAM. AND WE SAY THAT BECAUSE
THE PROGRAM HAS NOT YET BEEN
IMPLEMENTED, AND SO ELIMINATING
IT WOULD NOT DISRUPT ANY
EXISTING SERVICES. TO DEPARTMENT
IN FINANCE ANYTHING ELSE, TAD.
I'M I'M JUST, UH DOVETAIL OFF
THAT, UM, MADAM CHAIR. IT'S IT.
UH UM IT IS AN ONGOING PROGRAM
THAT WOULD PICK IT BACK UP IN
2627. IT'S A, UH THANK YOU OK
ENOUGH FOR THE QUÊ QUESTIONS ON
MY END, WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM PARTICIPANT CHOICE
SPECIALIST.
WE HAD TO CLEAR A ROOM. THING.
MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR, BRIAN WHEN PHIL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES I WAS
ASKED TO ANSWER THE THREE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE ON THE AGENDA
REGARDING THE PARTICIPANT.
CHOICE SPECIALISTS. UM SO FIRST
OF ALL, THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAD
FUNDING OF $7.2 MILLION ANNUALLY
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO HIRE
PARTICIPANT CHOICE SPECIALISTS.
THESE SPECIALISTS WERE REALLY
AIMED AT ASSISTING REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM GOING
STATEWIDE AND TO REALLY HELP
WITH THAT RAMP UP OF THE PROGRAM
. UM, WE HAVE HEARD FROM SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS AND ADVOCATES,
UH, CONCERNS ABOUT THE FUNDING
ENDING AT THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH AND COLLABORATE WITH OUR
SYSTEM PARTNERS TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE SELF DETERMINATION
AND TO CONTINUE THE CURRENT
EFFORTS. WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE? AND I'LL I'LL GET THERE.
YES THANK YOU. UM THE SECOND
QUESTION WAS DOES Dð G SS
ANTICIPATE THE EXPIRATION OF THE
STUDY TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
PARTICIPANTS AND NEW ENROLLMENTS
? UM AS I SAID, BEFORE, DDS HAS
REALLY PRIORITIZED SELF
DETERMINATION, AS HAVE REGIONAL
CENTERS, AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE THIS WORK. UM WE'VE
RECEIVED LOTS OF INPUT FROM
SYSTEM PARTNERS, AS WE HAVE
DEVELOPED THE PROGRAM SINCE IT
WENT STATEWIDE AND AS IT NOTES
IN THE AGENDA. VS WILL ADD
INCENTIVE FUNDING THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTER PERFORMANCE
MEASURE, UH, TO SUPPORT THE SELF
DETERMINING ETHNIC SELF
DETERMINATION. EFFORTS TO
INCLUDE THE ABILITY TO HIRE
PARTICIPANT CHOICE SPECIALISTS.
SO, UM THERE IS A WAY A
MECHANISM WHEREBY WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE REGIONAL CENTERS FOR
WITH THAT FUNDING SO THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE THE CURRENT
EFFORTS. CAN YOU? UM WHAT WAS
YOUR NAME? MR WINFIELD. WHERE
ARE WE GETTING THAT FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE? YES HOW
ARE WE, INCENT? YEAH AND THIS IS
, UH THROUGH OUR SYSTEM REFORM.
UH, PEOPLE SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT
THERE BEING SORT OF TWO PIECES
TO IT. ONE IS THE REGIONAL
CENTER PIECE, AND THE OTHER SIDE
IS THE QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS. AND SO WE
HAVE A MAPPED OUT WITH, UM,
ENGAGEMENT. THE PRIORITIES
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM, AND THOSE ARE
GOALS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON. TO
REALLY STREAMLINED AND
STANDARDIZED AND MAKE THE SYSTEM
ROVE BEEN ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE
THINGS, FOR EXAMPLE, LIKE
EMPLOYMENT, INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE AND OTHER
ITEMS LIKE THAT, SO WE WOULD USE
SOME OF THAT FUNDING FOR TO
INCENTIVIZE THE PROGRESS AND
SELF DETERMINATION AS WELL.
THANK YOU. L A Ó ANY COMMENT ON
THIS? CHRIS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD SOMETHING TO THAT? THANKS
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK JUST TO
CLARIFY. I THINK THE IT'S THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURE FUNDING WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTERS, NOT THE
9010 QUALITY. AND OH, SORRY, UM,
THAT'S HELPING WITH THIS EFFORT.
OK, THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA NÓ
FURTHER QUESTIONS. WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT REGIONAL
CENTER. FAMILY FEES. OK, THANK
YOU.
GOSH! GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR, SENATOR ROTH STEVEN, PA.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. SO THE AGENDA
PROVIDES A GREAT OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL. SPECIFICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES TO REPEAL
THE FAMILY COST PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM. AND THE ANNUAL FAMILY
PROGRAM FEE. A LITTLE BACKGROUND
ON THE PROGRAM, SO THERE ARE
INCOME BASED AND MEDICAL MEDICAL
ELIGIBLE BASED SO FOR THE FAMILY
COST PARTICIPATION. REGIONAL
PROGRAM REQUIRES REGIONAL
CENTERS TO ASSESS THE COST
PARTICIPATION FOR PARENTS OF ANY
CHILD THROUGH 17 YEARS OF AGE.
AUTHORIZED TO RECEIVE RESPITE
DAY CARE AND CAMPING SERVICES.
IN THE MANUEL FAMILY PROGRAM FEE
REQUIRES REGIONAL CENTERS TO
ASSESS AN ANNUAL FEE TO PARENTS
OF CHILDREN THROUGH 17 YEARS OF
AGE. THEY MEAN SPECIFIED
CRITERIA. SO BOTH PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY ARE SUSPENDED THROUGH
JUNE 30TH 2024. IN RESPONSE TO
THE PANDEMIC. UH, THESE PROGRAMS
ARE COMPLEX TO ADMINISTER. HARD
TO EXPLAIN TO FAMILIES AND
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITIES
RESULTING COST OFFSETS AND
REVENUE THAT'S LARGELY
INDETERMINATE, SO THE AIM OF THE
REPEAL IS TO ALLOW REGIONAL
CENTERS. FOCUS ON THE CORE
FUNCTIONS OF CONDUCTING
ASSESSMENTS OF DOING SERVICE, CO
ORDINATION AND PROVIDING
SERVICES. THANK YOU. A ONLY
COMMENT. JUST ONE COMMENT.
KARINA HENRY AND L A Ó, UM
ALTHOUGH THE PROPOSAL WOULD
REMOVE A SMALL REVENUE SOURCE,
UM WE JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT
KEEPING THE REVENUE SOURCE
SHOULD BE WEIGHED AGAINST THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS ANY
POTENTIAL ACCESS ISSUES FOR
FAMILIES THAT IT COULD CREATE.
AND THAT'S APPROXIMATELY LIKE UP
TO ONE POINT THREE MILLION. SO
UH, THE PRE COVID LEVELS, UH,
FOR THE ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM
FEE WAS APPROXIMATELY 1 MILLION.
UH, RIGHT NOW. THE ESTIMATE IS
CLOSER TO THREE 100,000 FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. IT'S STILL KIND OF
INDETERMINATE ON WHAT THE NEW
NORMAL WOULD LOOK LIKE IF THIS
WAS TO BE RESTARTED. I THINK
THIS IS THE ONE OF THE ONLY IF
NOT THE ONLY POSITIVE ISSUE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, CHRIS A
DEPARTMENT OF CHRIS O'NEILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOTHING
FOR THEIR DAD. I'M SURE OK?
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
MR I FORGET. WINFIELD I HAD
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR YOU, SIR.
IF YOU COULD COME BACK UP, THAT
WAS OK. I WANT TO GO BACK TO S¼
Dð P. UM I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
THE INCENTIVES AND SO FORTH.
HAVE THE CASEWORKERS HAVE THEY
OPEN TRAINED ON STP NOW? SINCE
WE UTILIZE THE SPECIALIST CASE.
WHAT'S THE ACTUAL TERM SINCE WE
UTILIZE THE CHOICE SPECIALIST AS
THE CORE INDIVIDUAL TO HELP WITH
THEM LEAVING? HAVE WE STARTED OR
WILL WE START TRAINING EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT'S LEFT TO KNOW ABOUT
S¼ Tð P VERY WELL. YEAH REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE HAD A PRACTICE OF
TRAINING THE SERVICE
COORDINATORS ABOUT SELF
DETERMINATION PRIOR TO THE
PARTICIPANT CHOICE SPECIALISTS
AND THAT WILL CONTINUE. YES OK,
SO OK, SO I WAS MAKING SURE WE
DIDN'T LOSE EVERYBODY THAT YOU
KNOW A NEW ISSUE. OK, THAT WAS
IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SIR. I
APPRECIATE IT. SO ISSUE EIGHT
WILL REMAIN. WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE ON Dð Dð S¼
ITEMS IN HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES SPENDING PLAN H¹
èC B S¼. SO AGAIN, UH, STEVEN
PAUL OF THE DEPARTMENT. UH, THE
AGENDA DOES A GOOD JOB OF
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE KEY
CHANGES. OVERALL THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES NÓ CHANGE TO THE HÌ
èC B S¼ R BUT FUNNY LEVEL, SO
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY 1 BILLION
OVER THE MULTIYEAR
APPROPRIATION. THERE IS A CHANGE
OF 36.9 MILLION IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY, AND THIS IS DUE TO
INCREASED ACTUAL FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION IN PAST
YEARS. WITH REGARD TO SOCIAL
RECREATION AND CAPPING SERVICES.
SO IN THE CURRENT YEAR, GIVEN
THE ACTUAL COSTS AND UTILIZATION
TRENDS, THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
UPDATES THE FISCAL FOR THIS
INITIATIVE. SO UH, IT RETAINS
THE $19.7 MILLION OF WHICH 12.8
MILLION IS GENERAL FUND. UH,
THIS IS FROM THE ENACTED BUDGET
WHILE SHIFTING 22.9 MILLION IN
APA IN APA RELATED REIMBURSEMENT
FUNDING. TO THE SERVICE PROVIDER
RATE REFORM. AND THEN INTENT IS
TO MAXIMIZE, UH, ELIGIBLE CLAIMS
, GIVEN THE LIMITED TIME AND
AVAILABILITY OF THE HÌ èC B S¼
FUNDING. JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF ACTUAL EXPENDITURES. SO
AS OF SEPTEMBER, 30TH 2023
APPROXIMATELY 1.4 OF THE $1.9
BILLION HAS BEEN EXPENDED. UM
AND WITH THE RATE STUDY BEING
THE KEY DRIVER OF EXPENDITURES,
UH Dð Dð S¼ PROJECTS THAT ALL OF
THE HÌ èC B S¼ AND
REIMBURSEMENT FUNDING WILL BE
EXPANDED BY THE END OF THE
CURRENT YEAR OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
2324 WITH THE LIQUIDATION
CONTINUING THROUGH DECEMBER,
2024. THANK YOU. DO WE KNOW
WHERE THAT IS GOING TO BE SPENT
ON WHICH OF THE PROGRAMS THE
REMAINING UM SO IT 500 MILLION.
SO YOU YOU HAVE, UH, THE RATE
STUDY. UH, YOU HAVE ARE
COORDINATING FAMILY SUPPORT
PROGRAM. YOU HAVE LANGUAGE
ACCESS. YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES AT HEADQUARTERS FOR
OUR YOUS AND SMS MODERNIZATION.
I PRODUCT IT'S SPREAD OUT ON
MULTIPLE INITIATIVES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR LAST ISSUE. ISSUE NUMBER 10
PROBABILITY SAMPLING AND
STATISTICAL EXTRA POPULATION.
GO AHEAD. WELCOME BACK. THANK
YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS, P
CHAIR MINKA AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. I APPRECIATE AS
WELL THAT YOU AND STAFF HAVE
SAVED YOUR MOST EXCITING ISSUE
FOR THE END. UM MY GOAL TODAY IS
TO ASSOCIATE THIS ISSUE WITH THE
COMMENT YOU MADE EARLIER ABOUT
POSITIVE THINGS IN THE BUDGET.
UM APPRECIATE, UM, TH THIS ISSUE
VERY SIMPLY THOROUGH. WRITE UP
WITH INFORMATION ON PAGE 40
THREE. UH WHAT'S ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOLKIT OF OUR AUDITORS?
HISTORICALLY THE DEPARTMENT'S
PRODUCED SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 10
AND 18 AUDITS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. WE HAVE LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM. MUCH IN THE WAY THAT YOU
AND I COULD GO TO LUNCH AND WALK
INTO A RESTAURANT AND KNOW
FAIRLY QUICKLY. WHETHER IT'S A
GOOD PLACE TO EAT. UM THERE
SHOULD BE AN AUDIT EQUIVALENT TO
THAT WE HAVE BEGUN TO DO THOSE
THIS YEAR. WE'RE ON TRACK TO
PASS OVER 60 AUDITS THIS YEAR,
SO REALLY PROUD OF THAT,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THE RATE
STRUCTURE. THERE ARE TWO COMMON
AUDIT FINDINGS THAT WE FIND WHEN
WE AUDIT VENDORS. ONE OF THEM IS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN PAID AT THE
INCORRECT RATE THAT WORKS IN
BOTH DIRECTIONS. I WOULD ADD
THAT TO THE DESCRIPTION ON PAGE
40 THREE. UM AND THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE AFTER HERE
WHEN WE GO IN, AND WE AUDIT TWO
DIFFERENT MONTHS ACROSS THE YEAR
, AND WE IDENTIFY SOMETHING, THE
OTHER THING THAT WE WOULD FIND
COMMONLY IN AN AUDIT IS
SOMETHING LIKE BILLING FOR
AUTHORIZED HOURS INSTEAD OF
ACTUALLY WORKED HOURS. AND WHEN
WE FIND A BUSINESS PRACTICE THAT
OCCURS IN TWO DIFFERENT MONTHS
DURING A YEAR, UH, THIS
EXTRAPOLATION WOULD BASICALLY
ALLOW US TO FILL THAT GAP, SO
IT'S ONE MORE TOOL FOR AUDITORS
TO IDENTIFY THE AMOUNT OF STATE
MONEY AT RISK STATE AND FEDERAL
MONEY AT RISK. NOTHING ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL CHANGES ANYBODY'S
DUE PROCESS FROM THE PROVIDER
SIDE AGAIN. THIS WE CAN IDENTIFY
OVERPAYMENTS OR UNDERPAYMENTS,
UM AND THEY WOULD STILL HAVE ALL
THE DUE. AS THEY NORMALLY WOULD.
SO THIS IS JUST ONE MORE TOOL
KIT, BUT IT'S A GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY MEASURE IN MY MIND
BECAUSE IT MINIMIZES THE
PAPERWORK BURDEN ON THE
PROVIDERS TO DOCUMENT WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING, AND IT MAKES
OUR AUDIT TEAM FASTER AT WHAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO SO WE CAN
COVER MORE GROUND TO PROTECT
STATE INVESTMENTS. THANKS HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. MAYBE I
SHOULD HAVE LED WITH THE TWO
POSITIVE THINGS SO EVERYBODY
COULD HAVE HEARD RIGHT? UM ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THIS
MATTER, JUST NOTING THAT WE
REVIEWED AND HAVE NÓ CONCERNS,
CHRIS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD MADAM
CHAIR. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN. AND UH, CLOSE OUT
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES
SIX THROUGH 10. PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ONLY ISSUE SIX THROUGH 10.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING THAT YOU
SKIP STICK TO THOSE ISSUES AT
HAND. AND AFTER THE PEOPLE DOING
PUBLIC COMMENT IN PERSON, WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO OUR OUR PHONES.
MAY PROCEED MUCH SHORTER LINE
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARC OF
CALIFORNIA. THE ARC IS A
MOVEMENT OF PARENTS AND ALWAYS
HAS BEEN, AND SO THAT IS WHY WE
WERE SO SUPPORTIVE AND SO
THANKFUL FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE ALL REGIONAL CENTER
FAMILY FEES BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
IT FOR YEARS, ESSENTIALLY WHAT
IT TURNS. IT TURNS TO REGIONAL
CENTERS INTO TAX COLLECTORS, AND
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT TO FAMILIES.
THE FAMILIES HATE IT. THERE'S
THIS ANIMOSITY THAT HAPPENS,
THEN BETWEEN FAMILIES AND
REGIONAL CENTERS, SO WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT. WE THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD AND WE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THAT TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BARRY GIARDINI,
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION, SIMILARLY, IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE REGIONAL CENTER,
FAMILY FEES VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
DO SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NÓ ONE ELSE IN PERSON.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN QUEUE THE
PEOPLE ON THE ON THE PHONE THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR ISSUES, SIX THROUGH 10, YOU
MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE, THEN
ZERO RIGHT NOW THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE, THEN ZERO AND WE
HAVE A COMMENT. LINE 12, PLEASE
PRESS 10 AGAIN. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LANE 12. YOUR LINE
IS YOUR MIC IS OPEN AND PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I ONE Tð. YES. YES,
YOU ARE. OK, THIS IS STEVEN
HENKEL. AND I MUST STOP ADVOCATE%
WHO IS NOW IN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. AND I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT IT'S BEEN GREAT
SO FAR, BUT YOU NEED TO FIX THE
FLAWS. AND SUPPORT THE THAT IS
GOING TO DO THAT. IN TERMS OF
THE FM S¼ ISSUES. I ALSO SUPPORT
KEEPING THE FUNDING FOR THE.
PARTICIPANT CHOICE SPECIALISTS
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHEN THEY GO INTO
THAT IT'S MORE COMPLICATED, BUT
IT IS FAR BETTER THAN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM. WHEN I WAS ON
THE COURT, THE OLD SYSTEM, I GOT
ZERO BUDGETS MANY YEAR YEARS IN
A ROW. AND NOW I'M ON SELF
DETERMINATION. I GET TO PICK
WHAT I WANT. FOR WHAT? THE
DIRECTION I'M GOING AND THAT CAN
BENEFIT EVERYONE OUT THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SIR. NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU, SIR. AND
MADAM CHAIR. THERE ARE NÓ MORE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. IT WAS
NOT EXPECTING THAT WE WENT
THROUGH SO MANY HURDLES JUST TO
SET THIS UP. UM MODERATOR, CAN
YOU JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME?
SURE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY.
YOU CAN DO SO BY PRESSING ONE,
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO. OK AND LINE. LANE 12
QUEUED UP AGAIN. WOULD YOU LIKE
ME TO OPEN THEIR LINE? NÓ? THEY
ALREADY SPOKE. OK YEP. AND THEN
WE HAVE NÓ FURTHER COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. OK, UM WAS IT READY
TO GIVE SO EARLY NOW? JUST
KIDDING. UH, WELL, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC COMMENTS
SECTION. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHERE EVERYBODY
ALREADY LEFT. SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO ARE NÓ LONGER HERE
FOR COMING. I'M IN THE
DEPARTMENT AGAIN FOR JOINING US
AND ALL THIS AND COLLABORATING
AND FINDING A WAY THAT COMING
COME MAY. UM WE ARE BOTH
REALISTIC IN WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH, BUT ALSO VERY STRATEGIC
AND MINDFUL